Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich hab die Oscars nicht gesehen, aber du sicherlich.
Nein, denn ich schlafe lieber.
Warum hast du die Oscars nicht geguckt? Du bist doch, du hast drüber getwittert.
Jaja, also der Krieg als inneres Erlebnis ist ein Text von Ernst Jünger und der mit Vorsicht zu genießen ist, aber dieser Geist, der weht hier und wir hören mal weiter.
Die Entscheidung leicht gefallen?
Ich glaube unter Bewußt habe ich mein Leben lang auf sowas gewartet. Jetzt nicht, dass das was Gutes wäre, aber das ermöglicht mir halt die Rückkehr. Gewissermaßen habe ich auf so eine Situation gewartet. Natürlich ist es nicht gut, dass der Krieg das bewirkt, aber so ist es nun mal.
Auf eine solche Situation hat er immer gewartet und wir müssen hier konstatieren, das ist jemand, der auch nicht modern sein will. Er ist in Deutschland aufgewachsen, hat mit sechs Jahren die Ukraine verlassen, das ist in dem Sinne nicht sein Land, das er da verteidigt. Es gibt dann auch so eine Szene, wo er sagt, ja, dann kannst du deine Familie verteidigen. Die Familie sitzt aber in Stuttgart, die Familie ist ja gar nicht in der Ukraine. Und wir haben es hier tatsächlich mit einem unmodernen Denken zu tun, wo man nochmal sagt, aber so ist eigentlich mein Heimatland und da hat es mich immer hingezogen. Und deswegen ist das jetzt ein guter Anlass, mit dem Krieg dort wieder hinzuziehen. Es ist sehr absurd und wird dann auch immer abstruser, wenn man sich dann diese Szenerie noch anhört, die eben Zug stattfindet.
Um sich für den Ernstfall vorzubereiten, wird zitiert, aus dem Einmal-eins der chinesischen Kriegskunst.
Auch wenn eine kleine Einheit verbissen kämpfen kann, wird sie von einem größeren am Ende gefangen genommen. Die Kleine ist die Ukraine und der Große Russe.
Eine Waffe hatte der angehende Kämpfer noch nie in seinem Leben in der Hand.
Also dieser Drang zum retrospectiven Sense-Making, irgendwas zu beobachten, sich das nicht erklären zu können, Gefühle zu spüren und dann versuchen, eins plus eins ist, was eigentlich zusammen zu zählen. Und dann sich so einen Sinn daraus abzuleiten, dann dankenswerterweise noch auf irgendwelche Zitate zu stoßen, die einen dabei angeblich unterstützen. Also hier haben wir es wirklich mit Therapie notwendigen Vorfällen zu tun.
Da hat man auch eine ideologische Verblendung. Also Ideologie im Sinne von falschem Bewusstsein ist glaube ich das, was wir wieder ganz stark gerade erleben, wenn wir uns diesen Diskurs ansehen. Geradezu wütend ist deshalb auch Konstantin Wecker, der Liedermacher, der immer sich engagiert hat gegen Faschismus für den Frieden und der ist zugeschaltet im Deutschlandfunk und warnt hier sehr eindrücklich.
Ich möchte einfach, dass die pazifistische Stimme nicht stirbt und ich sage Ihnen, Sie reden sehr viel davon oder reden gerne davon, wie man mit Waffen dort verteidigt. Gehen Sie denn selbst hin und verteidigen mit Waffen. Wir haben auch Soldatinnen und Soldaten, die Sie vorschicken für Ihre Meinung. Dann tun Sie es doch selbst, bitte. Ich bewundere wirklich, ich bin nicht der gleichen Meinung, aber wenn jemand selbst etwas in die Hand nimmt, aber immer Soldaten vorzuschicken und Armenen vorzuschicken, das halte ich für ziemlich feige.
Ja, das finde ich sehr gut. Und es gab diese Anne-Wil-Sendung, die du auch schon nanntest, mit der ukrainischen Schriftstellerin Petrovskaia. Da saß ja auch Lars Klingenbeil mit als SPD-Chef. Die Sendung war ja am Ende so gestaltet, dass Anne-Wil sie erst mal zu Wort kommen lassen, mit zwei, drei Runden, wo sie so sagen konnte, verstehen sie denn nicht, das ist schon der große Krieg, sie müssen jetzt hier eingreifen, die ganze Ukraine wird zerstört und Putin macht ja dann keinen Halt usw. Und dann hat Anne-Wil das Klingenbeil einfach ins Boot geholt, ins Gespräch, in dem sie zu ihm irgendwie so sagte, ja und was sagen sie ihr jetzt? Also so auf dieser Ebene, wo man irgendwie gemerkt hat, ja hier wird Programm gestaltet, so wie Talkshows gestaltet werden. Man sucht nämlich eine Kontroverse und darum baut man alle Themenbeiträge, die so zu erwarten sind. Und das, was Biermann hier sagt, Wecker, Wecker, ist ja genau der richtige Hinweis, nämlich Anne Will muss sich darüber klar werden, was sie selbst will. Gestaltet sie eine Sendung als Kontroverse, wo sie sozusagen als Anwältin des Programms die Kontroverse heraus moderierend, Lars Klingbeil provoziert oder gelten für sie bestimmte Regeln, wie zum Beispiel wir haben auch, und das ist vielleicht nicht ganz unwichtig, dass man das immer wieder, also Geschichte auch mal nach vorne denkt, so wie Harari, dass man sagt, okay, es ist jetzt der 31. März 2022, wird es irgendwann eine Zeit geben, wo wir sagen, weißt du noch, damals, da war das nur ein Krieg in der Ukraine. Da ist noch keine Atombombe auf Stuttgart gefallen, und Hörer finden immer wieder lustig, dass ich mir Stuttgart aussuche. Aber warum nicht? Man muss es ja irgendwie konkret machen. Wir können aus A teilnehmen. Es war halt bisher nur Wasser. Jetzt ist einfach verstrahltes Gelände. Und die Frage ist, kriegen wir es antizipiert, so wie wir hier auch so versuchen, so eine spontane Historisierung machen, aber jetzt auch mal nach vorne gedacht. Ich meine, der Slogan des Podcasts hier lautet, die Zwanziger waren erst wild, dann golden und am Ende endeten sie doch düster. Wer sagt uns denn, dass das nicht doch noch mal so passiert? Und klar, es war halt erst wild, Corona, und dann so ein bisschen golden. Wir sind aus Corona rausgekommen, aber jetzt droht es doch, düster zu werden. Kriegen wir im hierarchischen Sinne hin, zu antizipieren, was geschichtlich möglich ist? Also uns eben nicht auf so ein, ja ja, wenn wir noch ein bisschen durchhalten, dann gewinnt die Ukraine auch. Irgendwie so ein Bild haben wir alle im Kopf irgendwie. Stelzen Müller hat auch schon krass widersprochen, fand ich, mit so einem ganz bedachtsamen Ton, dass wir ja auch gerade so einer Propagandalyge vom starken Ukraine, und weil wir auch sehen, in Russland klappt ja nicht nur die Kriegsführung nicht, sondern auch die Propaganda nicht so richtig.
Es wäre ja zu wünschen, also es wäre ja, wenn das so wäre, das wäre ja toll.
Genau, wenn es im Juni so wäre.
Ich wäre sofort dafür, möge der Erdboden Vladimir Putin verschlucken. Aber das ist ja leider nicht so.
Genau, wir wissen es eben nicht und wir müssen uns die Alternativen offen halten. Und das muss, finde ich, von jedem Journalisten abverlangt werden, sich da ganz klar zu positionieren. Bist du gerade dabei, einen Atomangriff auf Europa zu verhindern? Ja oder nein? Oder gestaltest du gerade eine Sendung?
Denn dann macht man eigentlich noch Spaßgesellschaft. Ich würde ja diesen ganzen Leuten, die jetzt sagen, wir sind hier aus der Spaßgesellschaft mal endlich raus, jetzt werden wir erwachsen, wir hören auf zu spielen, legen das Nirwana-T-Shirt ab. Diese Leute machen ja die ganze Zeit noch Spaßgesellschaft. Denn die reden über etwas, was so schlimm wird, dass wir uns das überhaupt nicht vorstellen können. Und wir dann auch danach nicht mehr gefragt werden dazu. Damit wird rumgespielt, damit wird eine Talkshow gemacht, da werden lustige Kolumnen geschrieben und und und. Das ist eigentlich Spaßgesellschaft, statt darüber ernsthaft zu reden. Man kann dieses, wie mache ich eine Sendung, das kann man machen, wenn man hier sowas wie eine Landtagswahl hat. Und dann kann man die nochmal alle in die Bütte stellen. Und dann kann man nochmal ein bisschen Zunder geben. Und da geht es eigentlich nur darum, dass eine gute Show abgeliefert wurde, damit man aus den doch recht langweiligen Gesichtern was rausholen kann. Da habe ich ja auch noch größtes Verständnis. Du sagst ja auch immer Unterhaltung ist auch wichtig für Politik. Aber doch nicht in dieser Sache. Deswegen würde ich sagen, die sind noch alle im Modus der Spaßgesellschaft. Der Moderator fragt dann doch auch ein bisschen irritiert nach. Und Wecker, macht es nochmal deutlich? Das heißt, wenn ich sage, ich bin damit einverstanden, dass die Bundeswehr besser ausgerüstet wird und neue Waffen bekommt, ist das falsch? Wenn ich sage, ich nehme ein Maschinengewehr und fahre selbst in die Ukraine, ist es richtig?
Ich frage nicht, dass es richtig ist. Aber dann habe ich wenigstens noch ein Verständnis dafür. Als immer wieder alle Militaristen, die ich kenne, schicken eigentlich andere in den Krieg. Und immer müssen andere stärken dafür.
Krieg ist auch eine Klassenfrage, ist eine Rassismusfrage. Wir wissen in den USA, wer da eigentlich immer losgeschickt wird. Das sind nicht die Entscheider, die losgeschickt werden. Und wenn die mal da irgendwo auch in der Nähe des Krieges sind, dann gibt es ein paar gute Bilder, aber die kommen alle heil wieder nach Hause. Die Leute, die es überleben, die den Krieg als Soldaten durchgemacht haben, die nach Hause kommen, haben oft wenig Unterstützung in den USA. Aber auch in Deutschland ist diese Unterstützung auch nicht so toll. Also das ist etwas, was man auch hier ganz klar sagen muss. Da hat man eine Arbeitsteilung. Und die Arbeitsteilung ist, die einen wollen den Krieg, den verkünden sie in der Talkshow. Die anderen verdienen sehr stark an dem Krieg, der dann stattfinden könnte. Oder man hat es noch mit der Kategorie zu tun, dann die quasi die Arbeiter des Krieges sind. Und das sind die, die dann als Soldaten da wahrscheinlich sterben oder mit entsprechenden Traumata nach Hause kommen. Deswegen fand ich es auch absurd, dass derart skandalisiert hat, was Markus Lanz und Precht im Podcast verhandelt haben. Beziehungsweise Precht wurde skandalisiert, was er im Podcast gesagt hat. Wir hören uns diesen Clip mal an. Und ich kann da ehrlich gesagt nichts Empörenswertes dran finden. Jetzt kann man sagen, man kann sich da ein bisschen anders noch ausdrücken und kann manche Worte mit mehr Bedacht wählen. Aber eigentlich sehe ich da keinen Grund zur Empörung.
Ich rede aus der Perspektive der Regierung, die in Kauf nimmt, dass durch diesen Angriffskrieg Tausende, vielleicht irgendwann 100.000 Menschen ihr Leben verlieren, in einem Krieg, den man nicht gewinnen kann. Das ist falsch, Markus, und das bleibt falsch. Die Selbstverteidigung eines Einzelnen gegen einen russischen Angriff ist nicht das Gleiche wie die Durchhaltungparolen eines Präsidenten, der sein Volk in einen Krieg schickt, das es verlieren muss. Da mache ich einen großen moralischen Unterschied.
Natürlich hat die Ukraine ein Recht auf Selbstverteidigung.
Ab dem Moment ein Recht auf Selbstverteidigung, aber auch die Pflicht zur Klugheit einzusehen, weil man sich ergeben muss.
Also zu wissen, was man verloren hat, meinst du?
Und hier, finde ich, sind wir ja wirklich an einem ganz modernen Punkt, den wir vorher nie hatten, dass wir zum einen Atombomben haben. Also ohne Atombomben wäre die Sache ja geklärt. Putin kann diesen Krieg so nur weiter befehlen und zu Putin gehört aber auch so eine Hardliner Gang, die in Moskau sehr erpicht drauf ist. Nur deswegen kann er diesen Krieg so führen, weil diese Drohmacht immer noch mal um Faktor 100 auf die Spitze zu treiben dahinter steht. Aber, und das gehört auch zu dieser Moderne, wir führen ja noch auf anderer Ebene Krieg, nämlich diesen Wirtschaftskrieg. Und ich war eigentlich in der Erwartung und auch der Hoffnung, dass wir jetzt Ende März darüber reden können, aber es ist ja Null davon zu hören. Also es ist ja wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Und ich will nur mal zwei Clips von dem, jetzt häufiger von mir, Economic Challenges im Handelsplan, also Bert Rürup und Michael Hüther vom Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft, nee, IW.
Eines dieser?
Das Arbeitgebernahe Institut der Wirtschaft, wie auch immer es heißt. Na ja, die beiden sitzen in ihrem Podcast zusammen und wie soll man sagen? Das sind zwei Ökonomen, von denen wir denken, die spielen auch auf der politischen Ebene, die wissen, was Kommunikation ist. Die sollten sich irgendwie keine Ahnung, aber dieses Ausmaß an, und wir haben es eben schon beim ÖL besprochen, dass die Ökonomen überhaupt nicht wissen, was hier jetzt gerade Sache ist und so. Und das alles erstmal nur erleben. Dieses Ausmaß an, ich weiß es nicht, wir können es im Gespräch thematisieren, aber wir kommen hier auf keinen grünen Nenner, ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Also insofern ist das, sagen wir mal, hart zuschlagen, ja.
Also hart zuschlagen, geht es konkret um die Sanktion, die der Westen gewählt hat? Und dann reagiert Michael Hüther.
Aber nicht mit der Faust, ja, ein bisschen.
Naja, also nimm mal mit der Faust, wenn deine Zentralbank die eigene Währung nicht mehr schützen kann, dann finde ich, ist das schon richtig in die Fresse gehauen.
Also auf der einen Seite ein Ökonom, der, ja gut, hat eine Sanktion, kennen wir ja, wie funktioniert und so weiter. Auf der anderen Seite jemand, der nach Worten ringt, keine findet für das Ausmaß an Sanktionierung. Und dann so ein Schulhof-Slang, das ist doch voll in die Fresse, siehst du das nicht? Und an solchen kleinen Dingern sieht man immer, wie blind wir gerade, klar, wir wissen alle, 283 verschiedene Waffen und da ein Panzer und da eine Rakete und Überschall und was weiß ich, Vakuumbomben.
Wenn man ein bisschen viel N24 gesehen hat, dann kann man die auch noch alle genau bestimmen.
Aber wie munitioniert wir sind, was den Wirtschaftskrieg angeht, wissen wir nicht.
Woodrow Wilson hat gesagt, das ist schlimmer als jede Waffe, kann eine Sanktion sein. Und wenn man das nicht erkennen will, dann hat man ökonomisch einfach keine Ahnung. Genau so, wenn jetzt gesagt wird, Deutschland sei ja die ganze Zeit der schwache Mann in Europa, geht bitte mal in irgendein südeuropäisches Land, Portugal, Spanien, Griechenland und fragt mal, findet ihr auch, dass Deutschland so in den letzten Jahren immer so schwach aufgetreten ist? Dann werden die mal was erzählen. Nein, wirtschaftliche Macht, wirtschaftliche Stärke, wirtschaftliche Schlagkraft ist so immens, da braucht man nicht mit Maschinengewehren rumrennen.
Ja, es gibt diese Bildbände von Detroit und so weiter, diese alten in Amerika Industrieorte, wo die Autos hergestellt wurden, hunderttausende Mitarbeiter damals und so weiter. Und dann gibt es jetzt, gab es so zu Obamas Zeiten, es war ja auch so seine Region, seine Herkunftsregion, Chicago und so weiter, gab es so Bildbände, diese alten Industrieorte, einfach mal festgehalten, fotografisch. Und die waren in einem Zustand, wo man nicht sagen konnte, sind die einfach abgerockt und verlassen worden oder ist da gestern eine Bombe eingeschlagen? Oder so vor einem Jahr, dass die Vegetation wieder kommt. Aber es war ununterscheidbar. Und das gilt in diesem Maße eben auch für die dort betroffene Bevölkerung. Also die durchlebenden einfach 20 Jahre lang Abstieg, Leid, bis hin zu, dass man dann die Familie nicht mehr ernähren kann und man sich Jobs woanders sucht, plötzlich beginnt das Pendeln, dann ist man nur noch jede zweite Woche zu Hause, man sucht sich einen Job, der eigentlich gar nicht zu einem passt und so.
Du weißt ja, was im urbanen Raum ganz stark gegoogelt wurde. Gibt es ja jetzt schon Erhebungen. Junge Leute googeln in Russland, in den Metropolen, Moskau, Petersburg und so weiter. Wo kann ich arbeiten? Welches Land ist für mich sinnvoll zum Auswandern? Wo kann ich besser Englisch lernen?
Genau. YouTube ist immer noch online zum Englisch lernen und Auswanderungstipps geben. Genau. Alles andere ist soweit offline. Bert Rürup und Michael Hüther diskutieren das dann auch mal ganz kurz. Was wissen wir eigentlich und was wissen wir darüber, was wir wissen können?
Gibt es so etwas wie eine ökonomische Theorie von Sanktionen? Ich meine nein, aber vielleicht hast du eine andere Ansicht. Aber die zweite Frage dann, was sind denn die Voraussetzungen damit Sanktionen, die von den Parteien oder Gruppen, die sie ergreifen, die erwünschte Wirkung haben können? Und ob es nicht möglicherweise auch unerwünschte Nebenwirkungen gibt? Also fangen wir erstmal an. Glaubst du, dass es so etwas wie eine Theorie, eine ökonomische Theorie von Sanktionen gibt?
Nein, wir sind von der ökonomischen Theorie eigentlich sehr blank bei solchen Fragen. Es gibt so Randthemen. Ich meine, wenn du die Unterscheidung zwischen…
In der Außenhandelstheorie gibt es so ein bisschen was.
Ja, Tit for tat, nicht solche Überlegungen. Der eine macht den Zoll, der andere macht den Zoll.
Ja, wir wissen im Grunde nichts. Wir stehen nur daneben und beobachten.
Die Wirksamkeit auch sehr fraglich. Also Wirksamkeit im Sinne von, nicht verursachen die Sanktionen was. Also die können Armut, Hunger, alles Mögliche verursachen. Aber sind sie als politisches Instrument wirksam? Geht der Gegner auf uns in Schritt zu? Ist tatsächlich so, dass das nachgelassen hat. Diese Wirksamkeit schreibt Nicolas Mulder in seinem Buch The Economic Weapon, eine Geschichte der Sanktionen. Aber auch da kann man zwar das geschichtlich nachvollziehen, welche Sanktionen es gab, wie das rechtlich eingehegt wurde. Aber was genau passiert, ist tatsächlich vielen sehr unschlüssig. Auch die Frage, wie konnte der Rubel dann doch noch relativ stabil sein? Was passiert da eigentlich für Dinge? Das heißt, da ist auch sehr viel im Unklaren. Wir können nur sagen, dass das das Entscheidende ist, über das wir reden sollten. Und das tun wir ja in Bezug auf die Energielieferung. Da hat man jetzt irgendwie verstanden, das ist schon wichtig, dass Putin uns Gas verkaufen kann. Aber dann kann man sich ja vorstellen, wenn es jetzt so eine Wichtigkeit hat, dass diese Sanktionspolitik auch das ist, worüber wir reden müssen. Darüber kann man debattieren. All diese anderen Dinge sind, wie Sobochinsky in der Zeit geschrieben hat, tatsächlich Fragen aus alten Zeiten. Da können wir sagen, wenn es noch eine konventionelle Kriegsführung gäbe, dann kann man sagen, wir machen das jetzt mal.
Aber die gibt es nicht mehr. Als diese Idee von Putin aufkam, ich lasse mir das Gas nur noch in Rubel bezahlen, was ja bedeutet, die ganze Rubelabwertung muss dann von den Käufern geschultert werden, gab es hier im Tagesspiegel ein paar Zitate von einem Putin-Vertrauten, was auch immer. Zitat, der Vertraute des russischen Präsidenten Vladimir Putin warf dem Westen vor, einen totalen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland entfesselt zu haben. Zitat von dem Typ direkt, leider sind diese Umstände höchst unerfreundlich. Aber er spricht eben auch von einem totalen Krieg, in dem man jetzt angekommen ist. Und wir in Russland empfinden diesen Krieg so, dass die westeuropäischen Länder, die USA, Kanada und Australien einen tatsächlichen Krieg im Handel, in der Wirtschaft führen. Sie beschlagen haben unser Eigentum, unser Bargeld und blockieren unsere Finanzen. Also die sehen sich da einfach an einem echten Wirtschaftskrieg. Die sind allerdings auch auf der Empfängerseite dieser ganzen Sanktionen, während uns das Ausmaß eben jetzt so, wie soll man sagen, medialpädagogisch vermittelt werden muss. Also wir müssen es einfach verstehen, obwohl wir es nicht erleben. Das ist im Grunde Aufgabe so einer guten Erziehung in der Schule. Das ist die Schule des Lebens, aber noch nicht das Leben. Noch nicht das wahre Leben, sondern da wird man dann irgendwie vorbereitet. Und wir sind in diesem Zustand, dass wir auf der einen Seite die Sanktionen gar nicht wahrlich erleben, aber sie uns vermittelt werden müssen, als das ist echtes Handeln, schon allein um die Gemüter so ein bisschen zu beruhigen. Und dann sind aber die Ökonomen da, die den Journalisten gar kein ordentliches Briefing geben können, was jetzt hier zu vermitteln, zu beobachten usw. ist.
Sie könnten ja mal Adam Toos in eine Talkshow einladen. Der Mann hat ja Internet, den kann man zuschalten. Der würde vielleicht sogar nach Deutschland kommen. Der spricht perfekt Deutsch, weil er in Deutschland auch gelebt hat. Man fragt sich schon, warum findet das nicht statt? Warum ruft man lieber noch den hundertsten Schriftsteller an, der irgendwas von No Fly Zone erzählt und gar nicht genau weiß, was das bedeutet?
Genau. Über diese rote Linie, die nicht zu überschreiten ist, wird die ganze Zeit diskutiert. Und ich dachte auch die ganze Zeit, Adam Toos, ladet ihn doch mal ein. Ich weiß noch, wie überrascht wir waren. Wir haben dieses Buch von ihm gelesen, wo er beschreibt, wie die Zentralbanker plötzlich im Homeoffice da sitzen und die Welt retten müssen. Sie haben keinen Fluorfunk mehr. Klar, es gibt die Geschichte der Zentralbank, Entscheidungen und so weiter. Man kann ja noch mal nachlesen, aber sie brauchten ganz neue Entscheidungen. Und sie haben es hinbekommen. Und wir verstehen bis heute nicht, wie. Und haben dann dankenswerterweise vermittelt über Adam Toos erfahren, dass sie einfach allein in Amerika über 9 Programme 14 Billionen Dollar hergestellt haben. Einfach erzeugt. Und damit nicht nur Amerika, sondern auch die ganze Welt so ein bisschen gerettet haben. Also die FED wurde die Zentralbank der Welt. So hat er es ja dann geschrieben. Und diese Art von Aufklärung brauchen wir jetzt einfach. Und die gibt es aber nirgendwo. Denn so wie wir 14 Billionen zu unserem Wohle erschaffen haben, ist unser Ziel gerade, und das hat ja Annalena Baerbock gesagt, Russland zu ruinieren. Also einfach alle Billionen, die wir finden, rauszuziehen. Und es gibt keine Vermittlung für dieses krasse und eben auch so notwendige Verhalten. Also wie blind wir da sind, ist wirklich auch ein bisschen betrüblich.
Immerhin Hoffnungsfroh hat mich dann der Stern gemacht, weil er in einer Ausgabe Stimmen zu Wort kommen ließ, die sich tatsächlich für den Frieden einsetzen und genau diese Narrative hinterfragen. Wir müssen jetzt aber mal richtig handeln und warum können nicht auch unsere Soldaten sich engagieren? Da hat auch Richard David Precht einen Text geschrieben. Und es kommen jetzt auch im Laufenden so ein paar Namen. Ich will das nochmal deutlich machen. Ich bin ja überhaupt kein großer Sympathisant von Precht. Und es werden auch noch Harald Wälzer zu Wort kommen. Und Diana Kinnert auch mit denen beiden. Kann ich nicht allzu viel eigentlich anfangen. Selbst Adi Schwarzer wird jetzt noch gleich zitiert werden, die ich auch etwas heikel finde. Aber mir geht es wirklich nur um Argumente, die vorgebracht werden.
Und ich halte diese Argumente zwischen Werk und Autor.
Zwischen Werk und Autor und zwischen Argument und dem Gesamtwerk. Also man muss auch nicht immer dem Gesamtwerk eines Autors zustimmen. Aber es können auch einzelne Argumente gut sein.
Ich habe ja häufiger auch schon diesen Podcast von Florian Schröder und Serdar Samuncu so gelobt und auch ein paar Clips gehört. Die beiden haben jetzt die Woche am Dienstag einen veröffentlicht, bei dem sie auf der Bühne sitzen. Florian Schröder ist ein junger, agiler, sportlicher Typ. Serdar Samuncu ist ein bisschen älter und dicker und fühlt sich auch unwohler in dieser Rolle. Und selten, und vielleicht bin ich gerade auch sehr sensibel für solche Angelegenheiten, aber selten habe ich jemanden auf der Bühne, und sie hatten die Zeit, 3 Stunden oder so, so offen und ehrlich darüber reflektieren gehört, wie er sich gerade fühlt, in so einer Gesprächssituation ein Publikum ausgeliefert zu sein und zu sehen, dass die Resonanz beim anderen ein bisschen höher ist und sich trotzdem noch verstanden und auch von seinem Publikum ein bisschen geliebt zu fühlen, weil er zum Beispiel klar raus markiert, wer ihn hier gerade nicht mag im Publikum und sowas. Und in diesem Gespräch sagt Serdar Somuncu so nebenbei, ich habe auch schon von Alice Weidel Sätze gehört, die ich unterstütze inhaltlich. Und ich fand das einen sehr guten, wichtigen, total nebensächlichen, aber das ist vielleicht auch das Desiderat, dass sowas dann nebensächlich ist, einen sehr guten Schritt zu einer Art Verständigung, bei der wir eben das nicht mehr machen, was wir bisher immer machen, nämlich einzelne Dinge auf Twitter raushauen und dann irgendwie, das ist die Personprecht. An diesem Ding machen wir sie fest. Sondern, dass wir jetzt auch sozusagen uns Precht unter dieser Maßgabe anhören, Werk und Autor klar trennen.
Ich würde nur bei Alice Weidel sagen, dass es bei ihr ein unaufrichtiges Sprechen gibt. Das heißt, ein demagogisches, das uns in die eine oder andere Richtung führen will. Und da sehe ich einfach den Unterschied zwischen einem aufrichtigen Sprechen, dem ich nicht zustimmen würde. Also ich glaube, dass das, was Precht macht, eine Aufrichtigkeit hat. Also dass das jetzt nicht etwas ist, mit dem er demagogisch mich auf seine Seite ziehen will. Was will er auch bezwecken? Ihr könnt noch ein Buch verkaufen, aber mehr ist ja dann auch nicht. Aber das ist dann bei Rechten, die uneigentlich sprechen, nochmal was anderes. Und wir hören jetzt mal einen Abschnitt, den ich eingelesen habe, aus diesem Sternessay von Precht. Putins Niveau sollte nicht das Unsere sein. Der Motor des politischen Geschehens muss das besonnene, vernunftgeleitete Handeln werden. Nicht die Wut und nicht der Affekt. Die Menschheitsprobleme des 21. Jahrhunderts, Klimawandel, Umweltzerstörung und die soziale Ungleichheit auf unserem Planeten dulden keinerlei Rückfall ins 20. Jahrhundert. Wir können ihn uns schlichtweg nicht mehr leisten, weder sozial noch ökologisch. Die friedlichen Zeiten, meinte einst Hegel, sind die leeren Blätter im Buch der Weltgeschichte. Sie nicht mit weiterem Leid zu schwärzen, ist die Moral der Stunde. So, die leeren Blätter, die müssen wir eigentlich anstreben, dass die nicht beschrieben werden. Wir switchen jetzt mal gerade aus dem Stern raus hin zum Piratensender Powerplay Podcast. Und Samira stellt jetzt mal diese Optionen vor, die es gibt.
Nichtsdestotrotz haben wir aber diese Situation, dieses Ressourcenverhältnis und Kräfteverhältnis zwischen Russland und der Ukraine und der Aussicht auf einen sehr langen, sich verlängernden Krieg, eine sich sehr wehrende und sehr widerstandsfähige Ukraine, auch eine ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung, die sich offensichtlich mit allen Mitteln gegen die russische Invasion bzw. die Invasion durch das russische Militär wehrt. Und auf der anderen Seite das Wissen, das von vielen Militärexpertinnen zumindest so propagiert wird, um einen ziemlich sicheren militärischen Verlust vonseiten der Ukraine. Dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen wird. Und jetzt die große Frage, wenn du weißt, dass du verlieren wirst, kämpfst du weiter oder gibst du auf?
So, wir haben jetzt hier leider ausgeklammert, dass es um Atomwaffen auch geht. Aber das ist jetzt etwas, was ja erst durch eine NATO-Beteiligung dann wirklich zur heißen Angelegenheit wird. Der Podcast-Host, Co-Host Friedemann Karich antwortet jetzt auf eine vollkommen irre Art und Weise in meinen Augen, denn er sagt jetzt das hier.
Ich glaube, so wie die Frage gestellt ist, funktioniert sie in diesem Fall schon nicht. Sie funktioniert natürlich abstrahiert, das verstehe ich, aber sie funktioniert in diesem Fall schon nicht, weil Gewinn oder Verlieren glaube ich nicht die Kategorien sind, in denen die Ukraine, wenn man sie jetzt mal so personifizieren will, denkt oder denken sollte. Also ich glaube, die Führung tut es nicht, die Bürgerinnen tun es nicht, das Militär tut es nicht. Und ich finde, als politischer Akteur sollte sie auch nicht darin denken oder braucht sie nicht darin zu denken. Gewinnen oder Verlieren ist eine Frage wie in einem Strategiespiel.
Aber das leider ist ja Krieg. Und es geht natürlich der Ukraine darum, diesen Krieg zu gewinnen. Denn sonst würde es ja überhaupt keinen Sinn machen. Also wenn man nicht noch wenigstens diesen Glauben hat, dass man diesen Krieg gewinnen kann, dann kann man es ja gleich lassen.
Ich verstehe das gar nicht, was er sagt. Genau das Gegenteil ist doch wahr.
Ja, und es geht nur um solche Strategiespiele. Das ist ja das Schlimme, dass der Krieg ein ernstes Strategiespiel ist. Nichts anderes. Es geht hier nicht um Awareness schaffen. Es ist nicht ein Influencer-Marketing, wo man sagt, heute solidarisiere ich mich mit Leuten, mit denen ich sonst nichts zu tun habe. Das ist ja so, Influencer aus Berlin-Mitte solidarisieren sich mit Frauen in Brasilien. Die Frauen in Brasilien wissen nicht, dass es Influencer in Berlin-Mitte gibt, die sich mit ihnen solidarisieren. Aber man hat so ein bisschen Awareness geschaffen. Und es geht aber hier nicht um Awareness schaffen. Da sterben jetzt nicht Menschen auf dem Felde, weil hier Awareness geschaffen werden soll.
Also dieser Spruch zu sagen, es ist ja ein Krieg und kein Spiel, wie er das gemacht hat, das ist ja völlig falsch. Das Spiel unterscheidet sich ja vom Krieg dadurch, dass es normative Grenzen gibt, nämlich Spielregeln. Und dass man nicht einfach kognitive Lernerfolge umsetzen kann, weil man gegen normative Grenzen stößt. So, trotzdem sind die Art der strategischen und taktischen Überlegungen genau dieselbe, nur eben ohne diese normativen Grenzen. Was eben auch bedeutet, klar, man hat dann immer verschiedene Schlachten und einen Krieg. Also wer eine Schlacht verloren hat, hat noch nicht den Krieg verloren. Aber wer eine Schlacht verloren hat, hat schon ganz schön viel verloren. Da geht man nicht wieder zurück auf Null und beginnt von vorne. Aber in der Art und Weise, also Kriegsführung ist Spiel. Nur es geht halt um was. Man hat halt Skin in the Game und so. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach, und das scheint mir dann auch so ein, mir fällt jetzt kein gutes Wort ein, aber das scheint mir so ein westliches Vogue-Ding zu sein, dass man sich jetzt an so Signalworten aufhängt. Krieg ist doch kein Spiel. Und wir sagen aber, nee, doch, Krieg ist genau Spiel, nur ohne normative Grenzen. Die Spielregeln werden halt entwickelt und den anderen aufgezwungen. Aber es ist halt trotzdem nicht genau dieses taktische, strategische Vorgehen und eben nicht in den Tag hineinleben, sondern jetzt ist Krieg.
Schirmacher hat ein Buch geschrieben, ich sehe es nämlich hier gerade. Es steht hier Ego. Da geht es um die Spieltheorie, wie sie von den militärischen Leuten wegwandert zu Wall Street. Aber die Spieltheorie hat natürlich ihren Ursprung im Militär. Und da haben wir schon das Spielerische drin. Und es gibt sehr ernste Spiele. Und Krieg ist ein solches ernstes Spiel.
Wir haben Kampf der Nation gelesen, letzten Monat. Wo ja genau das sozusagen ins Verderben geführt hat. Dass man diese normativen Grenzen nicht mehr akzeptieren wollte. Und eben nicht innerhalb des Wirtschaftspolitischen und so weiter. Hier muss man halt innovativ sein. Hat man einfach die Spielregeln verändert. Inflationsziel halten wir nicht dran. Soll man die Franzosen machen? Plötzlich sind die im Nachteil und so weiter. Und deswegen spricht man dann eben auch vom Wirtschaftskrieg. Und ich finde, das sollte man jetzt ab sofort viel, viel, viel ernster nehmen. Weil in der Konsequenz bedeutet das eben, Stichwort Detroit und so weiter, Autoindustrie. So ziemlich das Gleiche wie ein echter Krieg, nur auf Zeitdimension halt so ein bisschen anders. Und über Zeitdimension müssen wir sowieso nochmal, je nachdem, was jetzt als nächstes, was ja nochmal Powerplay hier.
Ja, nochmal Friedemann Karich und diese Äußerung finde ich jetzt wirklich schon gefährlich.
Und ich werde auf einer emotionalen Ebene nicht vergessen, gewisse Sätze, die gefallen sind. Wie die Sätze einer ukrainischen Mutter am Anfang des Krieges über ihren Sohn, die sagte, er hat sich entschieden, die Ukraine zu verteidigen. Er hat sich rasiert, er hatte immer lange Haare. Er ist ein Designer. Zitat Ende. Und solche Menschen greifen da zur Waffe. Und deswegen finde ich, muss man extrem genau aufpassen und sich in sich hineinhorchen und sich vielleicht mal fragen, was müsste geschehen, dass ich hier mein Leben abstreife, wie diese Frisur und Abrasieren und die Waffe in die Hand nehme und in einen Kampf ziehe gegen eine Übermacht, wo viele Leute sagen, ich kann es nicht gewinnen.
Liebe jungen Leute, denn hier hören viele junge Leute zu, lasst euch nicht verführen. Also das ist eine ganz, ganz schwierige Art und Weise, wie hier gesprochen wird. Wofür man sich opfern will. Wenn wir jetzt in diesen Diskurs reinkommen, dann können wir die Frage auch gerne mal aufwerfen. Aber wofür soll ich denn sterben, wenn es heißt, ich sterbe hier für mein Land, wie das Laufen wiederholt wird? Sterbe ich dann für unsere tollen DAX-Konzerne, der Familien-Klatten-Quant-Wirt, was weiß ich? Oder sterbe ich als junger Mensch für meinen Vermieter, dass weiterhin die Wohnungen vermietet werden können und die nicht zerbohmt werden? Oder sterbe ich für den Besitz, den ich nicht habe? Gut, ich habe ein paar Anzüge mehr als die meisten Leute, aber das war es dann auch schon fast. Ich habe ja nicht irgendwelche Ländereien. Wofür sterbe ich denn bitte? Das ist eine wirklich so falsche Denkweise. Und ich würde diese Frage, die Friedemann Karich hier aufwirft, auch mal für ihn selbst schon mal beantworten. Er wäre nämlich auch nicht bereit, sich zu opfern. Er gehörte ja zu denjenigen, die im Dezember noch mal gerufen haben, wir brauchen jetzt einen Lockdown. Und war zugleich im Urlaub in Lissabon und saß ohne Maske beim Friseur. Also da ist die Opferbereitschaft jetzt auch nicht allzu hoch.
Ja, also ich habe ein besonderes Problem mit Aussagen, wie sie gerade von Friedemann Karich kamen, weil darin so eine Art, wie soll man sagen, Übernahme einer Motivation stecken, die man aber im Sinne von Konstantin Wecker nicht selbst in Handlung seiner eigenen Handlung, sondern man projiziert einen anderen auf sich und dann wieder zurück und unterstützt ihn im Grunde dabei, indem er eben hier dann einfach von außen beobachtet, du bist eigentlich ein Designer, bist aber bereit, auf deine Haare zu verzichten. Na dann, leg mal los. Das scheint ja eine legitime Motivation zu sein. Und die Handlung, die daraus folgt, ist deswegen auch nicht nur legitim, sondern sogar bewundernswert. Und nicht ohne Grund.
Dann aber das auch noch mal auf uns zu beziehen und zu sagen, und da kann sich jeder mal selbst fragen, da kann ich die Frage einfach beantworten, für wen soll ich jetzt sagen, ich sterbe für meine Eltern, die viel älter sind, natürlich als ich.
Genau, weil du immer wieder den Tod ansprichst.
Weil das heißt das ja am Ende. Was heißt das dann? Und wenn man sich mit Soldaten auch mal unterhält, es gibt ja auch solche Fragen, die die dann immer wieder in irgendwelchen Seminaren beantworten. Und da zählt diese auch dazu, wofür sind sie bereit, sich zu opfern. Und da gibt es natürlich auch zum Ankreuzen das Vaterland. Aber das kreuzen immer weniger Soldaten auch an, sondern ist es dann tatsächlich noch das Opfern für die Familie. Und das meint aber in aller Regel Eltern für die Kinder. Und alles andere nicht mehr. Und nicht die Cousine, die man zweimal im Jahr sieht.
Genau. Es ist, wie soll man sagen, in der Pädagogik ist ja ganz wichtig, dass man Kindern nicht so sehr bestraft, um sie zu begrenzen, sondern dass man sie lobt, um Eigenantriebe zu unterstützen. Und diese Eigenantriebe sind ja in unserer modernen, singularisierten Welt und so weiter. Die Argumentation ist soweit bekannt und auch nicht ganz falsch. Wir bilden Kinder für Arbeitsmärkte aus, die es noch gar nicht gibt. Und deswegen müssen sie open-minded sein, sich was zutrauen. Und umso extravaganter sie werden, umso mehr bewundern wir das. Und für Eltern ist es dann auch irgendwann schwierig, wenn die Kinder so 15, 16, 17 werden und dann plötzlich sind sie 18 und sagen, ich verbringe jetzt ein Jahr in Südamerika. Und man denkt sich so, das einzige, was ich von Südamerika weiß, das ist ganz schön nahe an Mexiko, da gibt es ganz schön viele Waffen und überhaupt, und die Sprache und wie erreiche ich dich denn da? Und da das Kind noch zu unterstützen, ist schwer, aber jeder spürt bei sich, es ist notwendig, das zu machen. Das hast du so oft schon in den Tod angesprochen. Wenn Kinder oder auch Erwachsene irgendwann Wünsche äußern, die in die Hinsicht gehen, und da hat jetzt das Bundesverfassungsgericht im sehr weite Rahmen gesetzt, ich möchte sterben, hört die Unterstützung auf. Das ist eine Extravaganz, die wir als Deviant ansehen. Und da gibt es auch nichts zu diskutieren, sondern da muss dann eine Intervention stattfinden. Und dann ist Hilfe von außen gefordert, bis die Selbsthilfe wieder funktioniert. Und in dieser Art und Weise, diese Hilfe von außen nicht zu geben, sondern es noch zu bewundern, wenn jemand in den Krieg zieht. Und noch bevor er sein Leben lässt, schon seine Persönlichkeit zurücklässt, weil er war ein Designer, jetzt ist er ein Soldat, ist ganz falsch. Ist völlig falsch. Also wenn wir so unser, wie auch immer, Dekadent des westliches Leben jetzt gestalten wollen, und dass unsere Lehre aus der Ukraine ist, dass wir sowas plötzlich bewundern und unterstützen, dann sind wir ganz falsch abgebogen. Also dann steht einiges jetzt dann doch, wir sollten einiges dann wieder zur Debatte stellen.
Müssen wir eine Lanze für die Boomer brechen? Ich hab doch bemerkt, dass je älter die Kommentatoren, desto vernünftiger sind sie meistens. Also ich hatte jetzt tatsächlich häufig zumindest diesen Eindruck, ja es gibt natürlich...
Das war bei Corona anders, ne?
Es gibt natürlich unverbesserliche, ja. Das war bei Corona anders. Und jetzt merkt man, dass man doch ganz gut damit bedient ist, mal einen 70-Jährigen zu fragen oder eine Alice Schwarzer zum Beispiel zu fragen, die dann einen Text im Stern schreibt, der so beginnt. Höre ich das Wort Helden im Zusammenhang mit Krieg, zucke ich zusammen. Denn ich weiß, jetzt wird wieder gestorben. Und es sind selten die großen Helden, die sterben, meist die kleinen Leute. Jetzt schlägt also wieder die Stunde der Kriegshelden. Wir sterben auch für euch, verkündete der ukrainische Präsident Zelensky am 14. Tag des Krieges in einem Interview mit einer deutschen Zeitung. Danke. Aber ich möchte das nicht. Ich möchte nicht, dass auch nur ein Mensch für mich stirbt. Und ich will auch nicht für andere sterben. So, das sind die Boomer-Stimmen. Man kann über sie ja meckern und sie fahren diese großen Autos und so weiter. Aber es gibt vielleicht, gerade weil sie sich diese Komfortzonen eingerichtet haben, auch ein Wissen darum, wie schlimm ein Krieg ist. Und jetzt mal ganz banal gesagt, wie unkomfortabel ein solcher Krieg ist. Und das vielleicht da auch mit dieser Geschichte im Rücken, die sie noch stärker an sich, und damit meine ich in zweiten Weltkrieg, noch stärker an sich dran haben als jetzt eine Generation, die schon die Wiedervereinigung nicht mehr miterlebt hat oder so. Dass es vielleicht da der Fall ist, aber gut. Das trifft jetzt sicherlich nicht auf alle zu. Friedemann Kahrs ist ja jetzt auch nicht jung. Aber das ist schon etwas, was mir aufgefallen ist, dass es doch immer wieder ältere Stimmen in diesem Diskurs gibt, die die vernünftige Position vertritt.
Ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal die Betonung auf ältere Stimmen legen. Denn die Boomer beginnen 1958. Also ich werde dir eine ganz klare Boomer-Definition nennen. 1958 bis 1971, das sind die Geburtsjahrgänge. Alle in diesen 13 Jahren sind, also jeder einzelne Geburtsjahrgang ist größer als jeder andere.
Gut, alle Schwarze haben keine Boomer.
Dieses Jahrgang 42. Und 42 heißt auch, sie ist ein Nachkriegskind. Also sie ist aufgewachsen, als alles im Werden war. Deutschland war im Werden, die Bundeswehr 10 Jahre später usw. Also das ist bei den Boomer ein bisschen anders. Wäre eigentlich super interessant, wenn man sich das auch Konstantin Wecker und so, wenn man das wirklich nochmal...
Konstantin Wecker ist ja auch kein Boomer, er ist 75 oder 77.
Genau, das ist nämlich doch nochmal eine andere Generation. Und wir reden ja gerade ganz viel, wir haben ja auch den Festakt zum Holocaust aus dem Bundestag nochmal gesehen, wo ja ständig jetzt immer das Dämon drüber schwebt, dass wir bald keine lebenden Zeugen mehr haben, sondern dann eben ohne. Und ich fürchte mich auch ein bisschen vor dem Moment, in dem wir nur noch die Boomer haben als ältere Generation, weil die Boomer in einer Art und Weise sozialisiert worden sind, dass sie sich nicht vorstellen können. Vielleicht ist es zu hart, das so zu sagen, weil ich will es ganz deutlich sagen, denn weil das auch echt ein Rechercheergebnis ist, die westdeutschen Boomer, also die nicht-DDR-Erfahrungen und Wende mitgemacht haben, haben ein gewisses Defizit an Empathie für weit entfernte andere, Fremde, sagen sie mal so. Weil dieses Argument, irgendwann haben wir keine lebenden Holocausts, überlebenden Werbes, machen wir dann eigentlich eine echte Fragestellung ist. Die steht nicht nur so im Raum, sondern das ist ein echtes Problem. An dem wird natürlich viel gedoktort, mit Art der Dokumentation und so weiter. Aber es ist halt ein echtes Problem. Und diese Boomer sind diese erste Generation, die das nicht mehr primär erlebt haben, sondern aus dem Fernsehen. Und in deren Sicht, finde ich, ist diese Boomer-Rolle jetzt gerade, also wir sehen halt Markus Lanz und Precht und die ganzen, was weiß ich, Norbert Röttgen und so, das sind die Boomer. Und die sind alle ein bisschen anders drauf als Alice Schwarzer und Konstantin Wecker. Das muss man einfach sagen.
Und Konstantin Wecker war Kriegsdienstverweigerer in der Nazi-Zeit. Hat es dann, so hat er es nur kurz geschildert, wohl in eine Nervenheilanstalt geschaffen, quasi als Patient. Also wurde für verrückt erklärt und hat so den Zweiten Weltkrieg überlebt. Also das sind natürlich ganz andere Biografien, die da im Rücken sind.
Also die Boomer, die wir jetzt haben, sind Besitzstandswahrer, die total glücklich damit sind, 100 Milliarden zu bekommen, damit ihr Grundstück gesichert wird.
Und die auch noch mal fragen, reicht das dann? Das ist ja auch so erstaunlich. Dann sitzt da, ich glaube, das war Maiprit Illner, die dann noch mal fragt, ja, aber Herr Scholz, reicht das denn?
Genau, also ich will es ganz deutlich markieren von mir, als ich schlage jetzt auch gerade über die Strenge, indem ich das so sage. Aber ich will es trotzdem ganz explizit so sagen. Die Boomer, die wir jetzt haben, die wollen diese 100 Milliarden, weil ihnen das ihren Besitz sichert. Und die ziehen auch ihr ganzes Wohl daraus, dass abends ein Aktienkurs, also ein DAX-Kurs verkündet wird, der kein Unheil verspricht. Obwohl das mit ihrem eigenen Leben nichts zu tun hat. Während wir wiederum da sitzen und uns fragen, warte mal, zwei Jahre Corona, es gibt kein Kulturgeld für niemanden. Diese kleinen quasi Entwicklungshilfen in Anführungszeichen, weil dein Laden zugemacht wurde, musst du jetzt auch noch zurückzahlen und drei Jahre später noch rechtfertigen. Aber diese 100 Milliarden sind einfach so da. Und das hat Olaf Scholz ja auch, also Marc Schieritz hat es in diesem Buch geschrieben, vor den Boomern hat man halt Angst. Das sind halt einfach relevante Wählergruppen, mit denen darf man sich nicht anlegen, mit denen darf man sich es nicht mal verscherzen. Da muss man auf jeden Ton achten, während man bei den Jungen einfach drüber bügelt, als wäre nichts. Weil da einfach auch nichts ist, was dem was entgegenstellt. In deren Sicht, das war jetzt nur getriggert, weil du die Boomer meintest, also Alice Schwarzer und so, das ist noch mal eine andere Generation, die bleibt uns auch noch eine Weile erhalten und dankenswerterweise, muss man sagen.
Ja, und deswegen nochmal der Appell an junge Leute, dass man sich jetzt nicht, wo man eh schon nichts bekommen hat, jetzt zwei Jahre, noch einreden lässt, dass es nichts besseres gibt, als man darüber nachzudenken, wofür man sich opfern kann. Man kann auch eine feministische Perspektive einnehmen. Auch davon gab es viel zu wenig zu hören. Aber eine wollen wir hier besonders hervorheben. Sabine Rennefanz im Spiegel schrieb Folgendes. Und war Gewalt nicht noch eben etwas, was als toxische Männlichkeit verurteilt wurde? Der Krieg scheint auch in dem Teil, den man Westen nennt, eher die alten Geschlechterrollen zu reaktivieren. Sollten Männer nicht eben noch Gefühle zeigen, gewaltfrei kommunizieren, auch mal weinen können? Und jetzt wird ein Mann gefeiert, der sagt, er habe keine Angst. Der sagt, wenn die Ukraine bei dir ist, fühlst du dich sicher. Die problematischen Seiten der Politik Zelenskis werden ausgeblendet. Zum Beispiel der Fakt, dass Männer zwischen 16 und 60 nicht ausreisen dürfen. In der Zeit verteidigt der Präsident das Vorgehen. Die Ukraine habe etwas, was Russland nicht habe. Die Menschen, die ihre Freiheit schätzen und bereit sind, dafür zu kämpfen. Darum wurde dieser Krieg ein Volkskrieg, sagt er. Es gibt aber bestimmt auch in der Ukraine Männer, die nicht kämpfen wollen, die keine Waffen tragen wollen. Was ist mit ihnen? Warum gibt es kein Recht darauf, nicht kämpfen, also nicht töten zu müssen? Und was ist mit den Familien, die zerrissen werden? Als Deutsche, die nun in dritter Generation die schweren seelischen und körperlichen Folgen von Krieg und Vertreibung aufarbeiten, die sich von Generation zu Generation weiterreichen, sollte man dafür empfänglich sein und die Not der Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer nicht zum Heldentum stilisieren. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich einfacher als zu sagen, ich fühle mich hilflos, erschüttert und traurig. Insofern wirkt die Heldenstilisierung eher wie eine Selbstberuhigungstroge. Und ein Ausdruck von Machtlosigkeit, denn das ist das, dass man versucht, seine Handlungsunfähigkeit in eine Handlungsfähigkeit zu transformieren, indem man es auf jemand anderes verlagert. Eigentlich findet da ein klassisches Outsourcing statt. Ich kenne das nur noch aus sehr linken akademischen Diskursen, bei denen man dann immer wieder in irgendwelchen muffigen Konferenzsälen sitzt und man gerade irgendeine lateinamerikanische Revolution feiert. Aber man selbst würde sich natürlich nicht mal im Geringsten hervortrauen, um auch nur zu sagen, vielleicht ist das Bologna-System nicht optimal. Aber toll, was die Leute da irgendwo im Süden machen.
Genau, dieses Sense-Making. Wir haben ja während Corona dieses Buch von Katharina Nockun und Pierre Lamberti bekommen. Fake News oder wie auch immer es heißt. Und da ist ja das zentrale Argument, Leute finden plötzlich Fanfiction total attraktiv, um ihren eigenen Kontrollverlust auszugleichen. Und wir erleben hier auch einen großen Kontrollverlust. Wir haben gar keine Handlungsmöglichkeiten. Wir wissen nicht, was wir tun wollen. Wir wollen aber so viel tun, weil so viel Hilfe ja auch offensichtlich gebraucht wird. Und wir müssen uns einfach wirklich bewusst hinterfragen, die Art und Weise, wie wir uns gerade das verbildlichen, was da passiert, unser Blick auf den Krieg, ist das so eine Art Fanfiction, die aus unserer Suche nach Kontrolle irgendwie erwächst, dass wir eben Zelensky, also dass wir, die Frage ist ja immer, wie konnte es sein, dass jemand, so ein Medienstar wie Zelensky, der das so virtuos beherrscht, dass genau der Präsident ist. Aber wie viel Zutun von uns ist es eigentlich? Ich meine, was macht Zelensky wirklich? Alle zwei Tage mal so ein Video und dann tritt er halt vor Parlamenten auf mit Reden, die er hält. Und wie viel von dem Bild, das wir von Zelensky haben, ist eigentlich gerade diese E-Mail-Genigration, diese Fanfiction, die in uns gemeinsam so wächst, durch diese andauernde Twitter-Kommunikation und jeden kleinen Schnipsel noch mal hochholen und feiern und ins Bild einfügen. Wir scheinen unserer eigenen Handlungsunmöglichkeit genauso ausgeliefert zu sein wie diese Corona-Leugner damals und es mit dieser Fanfiction beim Blick auf den Krieg völlig zu übertreiben.
Hier läuten schon die Glocken im Hintergrund. Nun, ich frage mich auch, wieso benötigt man noch den Helden, wenn man doch den Anti-Helden bzw. den Antipoden hat mit Putin. Also bei Putin ist es ja wirklich ziemlich einfach. Da gibt es ja jetzt niemand Vernünftigen mehr, der sagt, na, der macht das aber eigentlich toll oder so. Sondern das ist wirklich schlimm und es ist ein Desaster für den Weltfrieden. Es ist ein ökologisches Desaster. Es ist ein Menschheitsdesaster, das dieser Mann anrichtet. Das genügt doch. Ich brauche doch jetzt gar nicht noch ein paar Leute zu stilisieren, die ich dagegen stelle, sondern alles ist ja schon besser als Putin. Deswegen brauche ich das doch gar nicht. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, das ist doch eigentlich nur nötig, wenn man schon so alle irgendwie so gleich hätte. Und dann würde man sich nochmal so eine Lichtgestalt da kreieren wollen. Aber das benötige ich doch gar nicht, wenn ich jemanden wie Putin habe, wo ich aber auch sogar sagen würde, Putin ist ein schlimmer Politiker. Wir brauchen ihn aber auch nicht in einer Weise zu demonisieren, als sei er jetzt so eine überirdische Macht. Nein, er ist ja auch ein Politiker. Und da muss man dann auch eine politische Antwort darauf finden. Ich war sehr dankbar, dass es im BR in Zündfunk einen Beitrag gab, der sich mit dem Heroismus beschäftigt hat. Dieser Beitrag ist von Ferdinand Mayen. Und wir hören da jetzt mal drei Clips von, weil es wirklich ganz intelligent ist, was hier so miteinander mal verquickt wird. Und ich finde auch, dass dieser Beitrag mutig ist, dass das in dieser Weise mal hinterfragt wird.
Mittendrin ein Reporter in schusssicherer Weste und mit Armeehelm auf dem Kopf. Er schaut kurz in die Kamera, dann bringt er sich vor den Einschlägen in Sicherheit. Wir hören den stellvertretenden Bildchefredakteur Paul Rondsheimer in den Kriegsgebieten in der Nähe der ukrainischen Hauptstadt Kiev.
Immer noch hören wir das Donnergrollen hier in Irpin, diesem Vorort, der zur Hölle geworden ist. Das ist Kiev, das ist Putinskrieg, das ist Irpin, der Vorort hier, der Hölle.
Rondsheimers Kriegstagebuch wirkt wie die Inszenierung des Kriegsreporters schlechthin. Oder besser, des Helden im Kugelhagel an der Front. Und das sehen wir nicht nur bei Springer. Das Bild des Mannes als stolzer, tapferer Krieger feiert gerade sein Comeback.
Und wird auf Twitter dann ja auch inzwischen wieder geliked von Leuten, die eben noch erklärten Halt die Fresse-Bild. Sehr erstaunlich, dass dann auch eigentlich so ein Band wieder zwischen Springer, Igor Lewitt, Jan Böhmermann entsteht. Es wächst da zusammen, was zusammen gehört. Es ist ganz erstaunlich, welche Allianzen sich da gerade, wenn wir im Ausnahmezustand sind, sich bilden.
Ja, also Kriegsteilnehmer als Helden zu erklären, okay, das kann ich mir noch gut erklären. Also Zelensky und alle, die da wirklich involviert sind und auch was Konkretes verteidigen. Bei Ronsheimer, der also extra hinfährt, um uns das zu zeigen, was da passiert. Es gab jetzt so eine Geschichte, zwei Fotojournalisten von AP waren noch in Mariupol und wurden dann völlig überrascht von so einer kleinen Einheit ukrainischer Soldaten, die gesagt haben, so ihr kommt jetzt mal mit, wir sagen euch nicht warum, weil einfach klar war, es sind 17, also wirklich 17 russische Checkpoints, bis man aus der Stadt raus ist. Und es war den Ukrainern total wichtig, dass diese Journalisten noch aus Mariupol rauskommen, um einfach berichten zu können. Damit eben nicht nur die Ukrainer selber, sondern eben auch. Und das war eine der ganz wenigen Geschichten, bei denen ich dachte, okay, damit bin ich irgendwie einverstanden. Die brauchen mein Einverständnis nicht, aber ich kann das akzeptieren, das ist eine Mission. Es ist ein bisschen wie bei der Soldat James Ryan, wo plötzlich unglaublich viele Soldaten ihr Leben opfern müssen, damit einer überlebt, damit die Mutter da nicht alle 4 Kinder verliert, sondern eins irgendwie so bleibt. Also es sind dann so diese kleinen Sachen. Und das aber im Kontrast zu Matthias Döpfner, der sozusagen als Oberchef von Springer vor langen, langen Jahren 2014 oder so bei diesem Global Media Forum der Deutschen Welle in den Gebäuden des Bonner Bundestags, also im Plenarsaal unten einfach so in so einem Proliumsgespräch war und dann vor internationaler Presse so sagte, wir Springer sind die einzigen in Deutschland, die noch Leute ins Krisengebiet schicken. Also wenn irgendwo eine Krise ist, die ja nicht sagen, kommt mal lieber nach Hause und geht in Sicherheit, sondern fahrt dahin. Und seitdem steht für mich fest, dass ich das ablehne. Also ich das ganz falsch finde. Wir leben in einer modernen Welt, wenn jemand eine Aufklärung will, dann sollte er sich nicht bei den Soldaten embedden lassen, so wie wir es im Irak-Krieg gesehen haben, sondern dann bin ich einfach dafür, dass uns die Geheimdienste, wie sie alle da sind, kurz ihre Mittel zeigen und uns einfach, ja die machen ja diese ganze Aufklärung, die Überwachung.
Und das hier ist ja eine ganz reißerische Berichterstattung, von der ich ja am Ende nichts weiß. Also im Prinzip könnte man das, was Ronz einmal da präsentiert, auch in Babelsberg drehen. Ja, ich will damit jetzt nicht die Authentizität in Frage stellen. Nein, nein, das ist alles authentisch. Aber der Gehalt, der sich daraus ergibt, dass da jemand wirklich durch Ruinen läuft und dass es hinten raucht und qualmt, der ist ja der Informationsgehalt ein solch geringer, dass ich sagen muss, warum sich dafür opfern.
Genau. Und ich bin total dafür, dass wir einen Überblick bekommen, aber dann eben einen, der auch so ein bisschen Abroximationshoffnung, also so, dass man auch mal eine Grenze hat, von Vollständigkeit hat. Also es ist nicht so punktuell, was die Kamera gerade sieht und wo Ronsheimer gerade ist, sondern dass uns Geheimdienste, sie können es ja dann aufarbeiten, wie sie wollen. Sie überlegen ja eh gerade alle. Auch die Wissenschaftler müssen mehr Wissenschaftskommunikation machen. Politiker überlegen, wie reden wir jetzt eigentlich öffentlich, nachdem uns auch die Journalisten immer in den Rücken fallen mit ihren ganzen, wir wollen hier nur Kontroverse und so. Und ich finde, für die Geheimdienste steht jetzt auch an, so ein bisschen Öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu machen hinsichtlich, was wissen wir eigentlich über die Ukraine gerade, welche Konvois, wo einfach für ein interessiertes Publikum, damit es nicht abdriftet, damit es nicht sich Ronsheimer ausliefert. Es gibt bei YouTube so Steve Luckner zum Beispiel, der macht ein Agenda Free TV heißt das, wo er einfach live ist, dass er sich filmen lässt und dann so eine YouTube-Show macht, wie er Twitter liest, wie er die neuesten Videos aus dem Krieg usw. Und dann baut er für ein Publikum so einen roten Faden zusammen. Und da kann man sich halt einfach dranhängen. Und wenn ich das so sehe, das ist dann immer, man guckt das so 3-4 Stunden und denkt, oh man, das ist ja heute echt die entscheidende Nacht. Und dann guckt man am Morgen als erstes aufs Handy. Was ist von dem, was man da alles erfahren hat, in die Nachrichten gekriegt hat? Nichts. Also es war alles sinnlos. Ich meine da explodieren Öllager und da brennen irgendwelche Städte in Luhansk usw. Und am nächsten Morgen kriegt man damit, ah ne, das hat alles nicht die Schwelle des Nachrichtenwerts genommen. Und da können uns doch Geheimdienste einfach noch ein bisschen helfen, einfach für Orientierung zu sorgen und auch das Ausmaß an Zerstörung dann wirklich mal zu sehen. Und zwar nicht nur so punktuell, emotional, sondern einfach auch mal, ja, dass so ein Counter daneben läuft. Wie viel Schaden ist eigentlich gerade angerichtet durch diesen Krieg?
Wir hören noch mal einen Ausschnitt aus dem Beitrag von Ferdinand Mayen.
Wenn ich sterben muss, dann sterbe ich, das ist eine Ehre, in diesem Land zu sterben.
Im Vordergrund der neuen alten Männlichkeit steht dabei das Vaterland. Russen müssen für Wladimir Putins Imperialismus in der Ukraine sterben. Ukrainische Männer dürfen nicht fliehen, weil sie über 18 Jahre alt sind. Obwohl eigentlich ein Menschenrecht, ist es gerade keine Option, den Kriegsdienst zu verweigern. Der Diskurs brutalisiert sich, auch in Deutschland.
Diese Brutalisierung sieht man auch daran, dass, er wurde ja gerade zitiert, der Klitschko ständig irgendwo im Interview zugeschaltet wird, wo ich auch mich frage, ja, das ist alles sehr schlimm, aber trotzdem darf man nicht den kritischen Journalismus aufgeben. Man ist nicht einfach nur der Lautsprecher. Also wir haben ja gesehen, dass das Weiße Haus TikTokker gebrieft hat, wie sie über diesen Krieg berichten sollen. Das geht ja immer so unter der Rubrik durch Kampf gegen Fake News. Und auf so eine ganz basale Weise stimmt das selbstverständlich. Putin macht richtige Fake News, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass auch ein Weißes Haus oder eine Bundesregierung auch entsprechende Interessen haben, irgendwelche Wordings zu betreiben, Informationen besonders hervorzuheben. Das ist ja auch das, was bei der Bundespressekonferenz stattfindet. Und das, was dann eigentlich guter Journalismus ist, ist nicht einfach nur als Lautsprecher der Regierung zu fungieren, sondern erst, bevor man als Journalist, ist man nun mal Lautsprecher, bevor man diese Informationen nach draußen gibt, sie prüft und vielleicht auch kritisch einordnet. Wo aber nur noch TikTokker als Akteure auftreten für diese Politiker, die für die Politiker sprechen oder für die Politik des Weißen Hauses sprechen, da ist das nur noch, dass diese TikTokker Lautsprecher direkt für diese Politik sind. Und ich glaube, wir haben es schon mit einem Problem zu tun, wenn wir so Leute wie Kitschko einfach so unhinterfragt die ganze Zeit irgendwo präsentiert bekommen, dann ist das auch eigentlich nur der Lautsprecher, den der jeweilige Journalist oder Talkshow-Host dann auftritt.
Also mit den TikTokkern, das ist echt so ein bisschen knifflig. Es war ja so allgemein Influencer einfach. Und es war sozusagen eine Presseveranstaltung des Weißen Hauses, bei denen die gezielt eingeladen wurden. Die Taylor-Lorenz da, die ja hier häufig auch schon Thema war, hat dann darüber berichtet. Und interessanterweise ist das ja von der formalen Terminansetzung nicht ungewöhnlich. Es gibt ja Press-Briefings und so war halt ein... Man hat halt nur keine Journalisten eingeladen, sondern Influencer. Man hat es aber so transparent gehalten, dass man so rangegangen ist, ja, wenn es Thema ist, dann sollen sie zumindest wissen, was gerade Thema ist und was auch auf dem Spiel steht. Und im Zuge dessen ist mir dann auch nochmal aufgefallen, dass auch deutsche Journalisten natürlich einfach zum, nicht nur zu Pressekonferenzen, sondern auch zu dieser Art von Briefing der EU-Kommission gehen, wenn irgendwelche Sachen anstehen. Weil die bei der EU-Kommission nämlich wissen, in diesen Redaktionen kommt dieses Thema von alleine nicht auf. So wie die IG Metall festgestellt hat, krass, unsere Themen verfangen hier gar nicht mehr, weil wir haben keine Ansprechpartner in den Redaktionen. Also wir müssen hier mehr machen, als nur die neueste Informationen überliefern. Wir müssen auch den Hintergrund liefern und hier nochmal einen Ansprechpartner zur Verfügung stellen und so weiter. Also ein richtiges Key-Account-Management, damit die politische Kommunikation funktioniert. Deswegen ja, es ist diese Lautsprecherei, gerade dadurch, dass beim Krieg eben klar ist, es gibt hier Kriegsparteien und wir sind natürlich auf der einen Seite und nicht auf der anderen. Aber ich sehe da aufgrund eigener Erfahrung, sowohl aus Seiten der FAZ als auch von der anderen Seite der IG Metall, wie verzweifelt die da sind, dass sie dann nicht wissen, wen sie anrufen in der Redaktion, um ihren Tarifabschluss zu verkünden. Dass es da eine Notwendigkeit gibt und ich habe auch gar nichts dagegen, ehrlich gesagt.
Nun, ich habe dann etwas dagegen, wenn es sich um Influencer handelt, weil sie ja politisch vollkommen unbelegt sind. Das heißt, sie können es auch gar nicht einordnen. Sie sind ja gar nicht in der Lage, das zu tun. Jetzt der Spiegeljournalist, der zum Briefing mit der EU-Kommission geht, der ist ja doch in der Lage, kritisch Sachen zu hinterfragen, einzuordnen oder zu gewichten. Das können aber diese Influencer nicht. Wir haben uns das ja angesehen. Die haben ja zum Beispiel auch zum Syrienkrieg sich geäußert oder so. Das ist ja zum Haare raufen, was die da abliefern. Das heißt, die können dann höchstens genau das nochmal in der Story erzählen oder im Video tanzen, was das Weiße Haus ihnen gesagt hat. Aber es kommt nicht dazu, dass sie selbst einen wirklichen Inhalt geben. Deswegen finde ich das eine sehr schwierige Entwicklung. Und ich habe die große Angst, dass man dann fast nur noch, wenn man jung ist, das als Informationsquelle nutzt. Und da ist dann schon ein richtiger Journalismus gefragt, der eine gewisse Distanz dazu noch zulässt.
Genau, das ist aber ein Defizit des Journalismus. Und irgendwo habe ich auch einen Clip, aber ich suche ihn jetzt nicht raus. Ich kann einfach referieren. Leo Laporte hat in seinem This Week in Google Podcast nochmal davon gesprochen, wo die Kalkulationen sind. Das Weiße Haus lädt da TikTokker ein, die zehnmal mehr Reichweite haben als der Journalismus. Und wenn wir jetzt feststellen, dass es beim Journalismus ein Defizit gibt zu informieren und gleichzeitig aber sehen, naja, die TikTokker kommen um die Themen dann auch nicht so ganz drum rum, gibt es so eine Art Bedarf, der dann doch irgendwie rechtfertigt, auf der einen Seite das eine zu tun und trotzdem das Defizit zu informieren. Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr interessantes Ziel, auf der Seite des Journalismus zu bemängeln.
Wir werden sehen, wie dieser TikTok-Krieg weitergeht. Wir hören nochmal Ferdinand Mayen mit einem interessanten Vergleich.
Männer dürfen keine Schwäche zeigen, sondern müssen hart sein. Sie müssen ihre Gefühle wieder unterdrücken und den Konflikt im Ernstfall mit Gewalt lösen. Eine Position, für die AfD-Politiker Björn Höcke 2016 noch scharf kritisiert wurde, scheint gerade zum gesellschaftlichen Konsens zu werden.
Ich sage, wir müssen unsere Männlichkeit wiederentdecken. Denn nur wenn wir unsere Männlichkeit wiederentdecken, werden wir mannhaft. Und nur wenn wir mannhaft werden, werden wir wehrhaft.
Ja, also mannhaft ist halt Wehrhaftigkeit und so weiter. Da sollte man lieber mal die Finger vonlassen und dann das Feld Höcke überlassen. Diana Kinnert hat mich tatsächlich vielleicht am meisten überrascht von allen. Sie ist ja CDU-Politikerin oder zumindest Mitglied. Sie ist viel in den Medien unterwegs. Früher mit Kappe, ich glaube heute mit Hütchen.
Heute mit Hut. Großes Buch über Einsamkeit geschrieben.
Und jetzt schreibt sie einen kritischen Text zu dem entsprechenden Diskurs, über den wir hier reden. Das hat mich doch verwundert, weil in der CDU, wie wir ja wissen, durch Norbert Röttgen, der jetzt eigentlich Karl Lauterbach in den Talkshows abgelöst hat, oder? Ich glaube, dass der nächste Talkshow-Rekord wird von Röttgen aufgestellt. Na ja, Kindert hat da eine andere Position. Valeria Sharjenok, 20-jährige Fotografin aus Kiew, präsentiert ihr Leben im Bunker. Reiswaschen in Eimern und Beine vertreten auf Schutt. Andere zeigen Bauanleitungen von Brandflaschen und Benzinbomben. Teilen Selfies aus dem Hinterhalt, bejubeln ihre Widerstandsikonen. Auf das Angebot der Regierung in Washington, ihn zu evakuieren, soll der ukrainische Präsident Zelensky geantwortet haben, er brauche Munition, keine Mitfahrgelegenheit. Eine Formel, die nicht nur ukrainische Landsleute abfeiern. Europas Influencer posieren in Sturmhäuben mit kugelsicheren Westen und Schusswaffen aus dem Karneval. War Corps ist wieder da. Mittendrin statt nur dabei. Denn sie kämpfen auch für uns, unsere Prinzipien, unsere Werte, für ihr Recht auf Souveränität. Wir, Europa der Westen, stehen den Ukrainern ganz nah. Vorsicht, wer sagen will, vielleicht zu nahe. Find ich eine erstaunliche Aussage. Sehr gut. Sie beschreibt es dann noch näher. In diesem Text kann man ja nachlesen im Stern, wie da in die Läden gestürmt wird, um sich irgendwelches Kampfgerät zu kaufen, um damit posieren zu können in der Insta-Story. Ganz erschreckend. Das ist auch ein Thema für Harald Wälzer. Wir haben ihn ja schon mal harsh kritisiert im Salon. Wir haben sein Buch besprochen oder sagen wir, wir haben es verrissen. Aber wir haben, glaube ich, auch damals herausgestellt, und wenn nicht, dann tun wir das jetzt. Er ist zum einen dieser Postwachstumstheoretiker, der uns nicht so zu sagt, aber er ist auch ein Soziologe, der sich mit Gewalt und Männlichkeit, mit Soldaten beschäftigt hat und da wirklich große Forschung geleistet hat. Und natürlich jetzt da wieder bei seinem Kernthema angekommen ist und sich wie folgt im RBB äußert.
Den ukrainischen Präsidenten und den Kiewer Bürgermeister in tarnfleckigen T-Shirts, unrasiert, entschlossen, sprechen von Todesbereitschaft und davon, dass sie in jedem Fall gewinnen werden. Der Präsident wird dafür von den deutschen Medien prompt zur Widerstandsikone ernannt und wir gewöhnen uns an Begriffe wie Tapferkeit, Heldenmut oder auch Ostflanke. Und wir sehen Bilder von weinenden Frauen an Grenzbahnhöfen und Männern, die entschlossen zurück an die Front fahren, bereit zu sterben. Kurz, dieses Narrativ des Krieges ist eins, in dem alte Rollenbilder und uralte Begriffe plötzlich wieder ganz unkritisch gebraucht, gepflegt und gefeiert werden.
Und wir hören gleich den nächsten Clip von Wälzer.
Und dabei hatten wir uns doch längst als postheroisch verstanden und geglaubt, dass wir uns lange schon von traditionellen Geschlechterrollen und vor allem von Militarismus verabschiedet hatten. Und jetzt steigt man fast reflexhaft auf ein Narrativ ein, das derzeit vor dem ersten Weltkrieg entstammt und übersieht dabei auch noch, dass Präsident und Bürgermeister, die zu uns sprechen, Medienprofis sind, die genau dieses historische Narrativ inszenieren. Und ich finde das total überraschend, wie glatt das funktioniert.
Das ist auch für mich die große Überraschung. Für mich ist die Überraschung nicht, dass aufgerüstet wird. Für mich ist auch nicht die Überraschung, dass Norbert Röttgen jetzt jeden Abend im Fernsehen sitzt. Aber für mich ist wirklich die Überraschung, dass es so einen allgemeinen Konsens gibt hinzu, ja, Patriotismus ist eigentlich auch wieder toll und wofür können wir uns opfern? Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Da war ich davon ausgegangen, wir sind dann doch die Konsumgesellschaft, die sauer ist, wenn irgendwas nicht im Supermarktregal steht, aber nicht mehr bereit ist, sich solche Gedanken zu machen. Was dann am Ende daraus folgen würde, das ist ja was anderes. Aber ich hätte überhaupt nicht gedacht, dass man diese Sentiments und Ressentiments noch mal in der Gesellschaft so erleben kann.
Ich habe ja von Matthias schon mal diese ziemlich gute These hier vorgebracht, dass wir eine junge Generation haben, die über Monate und Jahre, also seit 2018, seit Greta aufkam, sich so einen handlungsfähigen Staat wünschte, der dann mal richtig sagt, so Faust auf den Tisch, wir müssen jetzt das Klima retten. Dazu kam es ja nie. Der Wunsch blieb und dann hat man ihn einfach ausgetauscht. Corona. Und dann war man ganz dankbar, als der Staat mal so richtig durchgegriffen hat, auch über die Stränge geschlagen und wir dann festgestellt haben irgendwann, naja, die Intervention gegen Corona übersteigen jetzt schon das Schadensmaß, das Corona selbst so heraus provoziert hat, so in diesem Maße irgendwie. Und wenn man den handelnden Staat als desiderat austauschen und sagen, ja, wir sind eben grundsätzlich in so einer großen Sinnsuche, wir sind materiell so irgendwie abgesichert, wir vergleichen uns mit dem Rest der Welt, gehören alle zu den Top 10 Prozent, selbst wenn wir leiden. Aber so richtig Sinn macht das doch alles nicht, ja. Und dann kommt plötzlich dieser Ukraine-Krieg und gibt dir so viel Sinn und aus diesem neuen Sinn abgeleitet so viel, wie soll man sagen, neues Wissen oder neue Vorstellungen darüber, wer man sein will, wo man seinen Platz in der Welt sieht, ja.
Das war ja auch die Androsphäre am Brandenburger Tor bei Sound of Peace.
Ja, alle verwandeln sich so plötzlich in Soldaten. Jede kleine Geste wird so hyperpolitisiert, als Kriegshandlungen mit eingepreist. Ja, und das ist, also hier wird eben wirklich, wie Herr Radwetzar sagt, einfach so aktiviert, was so in uns schlummerte. So ein bisschen wie bei der NATO, ja. Sie war halt lange einfach aussortiert, gar nicht relevant, das haben wir beim letzten Mal besprochen, und dann zack, war plötzlich mehr Sinn als jemals zuvor da. Man war so richtig froh, dass es plötzlich so ein Gefäß gab, wo man den ganzen Sinn mal reinkippen konnte, den man plötzlich so aktualisiert hat. Und dann wow, Bündnisverteidigung, Weltrettung, Kampf gegen Putin, 20 Jahre schlummerte das nur so, wir wussten gar nicht, wie, ja. Alles nur immer so Provokation, und dann plötzlich Will Smith geht auf die Bühne und haute ihn mal richtig einer runter, ja. Also plötzlich war alles mal so richtig echt, und wir konnten uns alle dazu positionieren, und das ist so eine Situation jetzt.
Und du leitest uns schon in den richtigen Pfad, nämlich den Fiktionalen, noch mal kurz einen Clip von Ferdinand Mayen.
Was macht man denn mit einem Irren, der mit einem Schwert auf einen zuläuft? Wenn man selber sozusagen nur eine weiße Fahne hat, dann wird man wahrscheinlich schlecht aussehen.
Sagt Bild-TV-Chef Klaus Strunz und erinnert damit an König Theoden in Der Herr der Ringe. Auf in die letzte Schlacht gegen den dunklen Herrscher Sauron und die Orks.
Ja, wir sind in der Fiktion dann damit angekommen. Und du hast gerade gesagt, da hat der Wälzer recht, da schlummert etwas. Wälzer fragt sich auch, wie konnte das denn so lange schlummern? Oder wir hatten das eigentlich uns aufbewahrt, dass wir das jetzt wieder hervorholen können.
Und ich kann mir das eigentlich nur so erklären. Ich meine, wir müssen ja sagen, wir haben ja denn jahrzehntelang Männlichkeit dekonstruiert, Sprache abgerüstet, Deserteure aufgewertet, Kriegshelden abgewertet. Und trotzdem funktioniert das. Und das kann ich mir nur so erklären, dass wir in der Alltagskultur den traditionellen männlichen Helden nie abgeschafft hatten. Und dass er die ganze Zeit in Kriegs- und Abenteuerfilmen, in Star-Wars-Sagas und Netflix-Serien, Comics und Ballerspielen immer weiter gelebt hat. Dann können sie so aktiviert werden, als hätten sie über 100 Jahre und mehrere Generationen durchgeschlummert. Und dann sind sie mit einem Mal so frisch wieder da, als sei zwischendurch nicht das geringste geschehen.
Weißt du noch, wie wir uns gefragt haben, wo der Reiz in True Crime steckt?
Ja.
Und jetzt haben wir plötzlich so True War.
Nicht mehr nur Avengers, 40 Filme. Mann, was für eine Arbeit. Das kostet mich ja drei Monate, das alles zu gucken. Sondern jetzt plötzlich ist man wieder mittendrin.
Ich habe auch gefragt, bin ich mit schuld an der Sache, an diesen Helden-Narrativen? Denn ich war es ja zum Beispiel, der sagte im Gegensatz zu dir, nein, der neue Bond ist schrecklich. Das ist ein Jammerlappen-James Bond, so habe ich ihn genannt. Ich wollte also das heroisch haben. Ich will das heroisch haben. Aber, und du hast es eben auch schon mal ganz am Anfang gesagt, wir wollen es in der Fiktion, da kann man es dann mal ausleben. Und das bedeutet aber nicht, dass ich auf die Straße renne mit der Waffe. Ich sehe mir einen Action-Film an und steige danach dann in diesen langsamen französischen Kleinwagen ein. Du siehst dir gerne Michael Bay-Filme an und hast, glaube ich, noch nicht mal einen Führerschein. Richtig. Da könnte man sagen, was denn da falsch? Warum machst du nicht danach einen Führerschein und willst mal ein richtig starkes Auto? Ja, machst du aber nicht, sondern du sagst, das genieße ich in der Fiktion, um es dann nicht in der Realität zu leben. Und das ist, glaube ich, diese ganz klare Trennung, die ich machen möchte. Ich will den heroischen Mann oder auch die heroische Frau auf der Leinwand durchaus mal sehen. Muss nicht immer sein. Würde sagen, bei James Bond muss das schon ein bisschen intelligenter dekonstruiert werden, als den einfach mal zu zeigen beim Müsli-Punchen. Aber wir müssen immer erkennen, das ist die Sphäre der Fiktion. Die fasziniert uns gerade auch deshalb so sehr, weil wir im gemütlichen Kinosaal sitzen. Wir wollen aber eigentlich nicht tauschen.
Genau, eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich nicht, aber ich glaube auch, dass er da einen gewissen Punkt hat. Und das bestätigt mich in meiner Ideologiekritik natürlich, dass diese Filme entsprechend da wirken. Wir wollen noch ganz kurz über Herfried Münkler sprechen, der ja diese große These von der posteriorischen Gesellschaft hat. Und er hat in der FAZ einen Text geschrieben, eine Antwort auf Karl Schlögl, den wir ja beide nicht schätzen. Und Münkler schließt sich dem an. Aber erst macht er einen anderen Punkt. Wir haben ja schon das Thema Demografie angesprochen. Er blickt da mal im Hinblick auf die Demografie auf Russland. Posteroische Gesellschaften sind solche mit niedrigen Geburtenraten. Sie haben eine strukturelle Neigung, mit der jungen Generation vorsichtig umzugehen. Wo die Geburtenrate hingegen sehr hoch ist, haben wir es häufig mit notorisch belligerenten Gesellschaften zu tun. Der Gazastreifen ist dafür ein Beispiel. Der Iran der 80er Jahre war ein weiteres. Einige afrikanische und arabische Länder sind es bis heute. Israel ist ein Ausnahmefall, eine gezwungenermaßen heroische Gesellschaft, die mit der jungen Generation sorgfältig umgeht, dadurch, dass sie sich permanent die modernste Aufrüstung verschafft. Beim Blick auf die Demografie erweist sich auch Russland als eine postheroische Gesellschaft. Das war auch schon die späte Sowjetunion, als in der Schlussphase der Militärintervention in Afghanistan viele Mütter in Moskau mit Bildern ihrer gefallenen Söhne auf die Straße gingen. Und unverkennbar steht die russische Strategie im gegenwärtigen Ukrainekrieg unter der Direktive größere Verluste zu vermeiden. Deswegen zögern die russischen Kampfverbände, einen Häuserkampf zu riskieren, sondern schneiden die großen Städte von den Versorgungslinien ab und terrorisieren die verbliebenen Einwohner mit Artillerie und Raketenbeschuss. Postheroische Kriegsführung eben, die fast immer grausamer ist als heroische, auch weil sie Zivilisten als Geiseln benutzt, um die Soldaten zum Aufgeben zu bringen. Vielleicht auch eine Erklärung, warum Putin dann nicht vorankommt, weil er da auch keine heroischen Soldaten in dem Sinne hat, sondern das ist eine Strategie, die Verluste verhindern soll, auch um weiterhin Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung zu haben, um nicht die Mütter auf der Straße stehen zu haben mit den Bildern der Söhne, denn diese Mütter haben vermutlich auch nur noch ein oder zwei Söhne.
Ganz genau. Also es ist die Erklärung grundsätzlich für diese Geruhsamkeit von alten Gesellschaften. Man kann es in ganz vielen Ländern auf die Spitze treiben, also in Deutschland. Selbst bei drei Kindern, du hast keins über, sondern alles sind unglaubliche Investitionsgüter. Also wenn du die auf 18 Jahre gelevelt hast, dann steckt da ganz schön viel drin. Dann kommt es wirklich auf jede kleine Bewegung an, dass sie noch gelingt und dann einfach zu entscheiden, ja, jetzt ist für dich Krieg, also es ist völlig ausgeschlossen. Es gibt dann so Länder, die treiben es auf die Spitze. China zum Beispiel, wo gar keine Geschwister mehr da sind, sondern wirklich nur noch so Einzelkinder-Kohorten, die sich grundsätzlich über die Frage, die haben ja so ein Konkurrenzproblem. Also Kinder begegnen sich nur als Konkurrenten, weil die in der Schule total darauf getrimmt werden, du bist unser einziger Versuch in der Familie, also setz dich gefälligst gegen alle durch und so. Und Israel ist nicht uninteressant oder eben auch angesprochen, weil Israel muss diese Wehrfähigkeit hoch haben, obwohl die unter dem gleichen Problem stecken. Sie sind ein entwickeltes Land. Und wenn man da mal in Israel ist, ich war selbst nie da, aber ich habe ganz viele Erzählungen davon gehört, Austauschstudenten oder wenn man so da arbeitet. Man ist total überrascht aus einer europäischen Sicht, wie militarisiert Universitäten dort sind. Dass dieser Wehrdienst da über Jahre geht, dass man nie so richtig aus dem Wehrdienst entlassen wird, sondern immer Reserve, immer ansprechbar. Diese ganze Thematisierung, das ist dieses ganz, ich will nicht sagen dieses Feiern des Staates Israel, aber dieses ständige Präsenthalten von diesem Staat gibt es nur, wenn wir ihn verteidigen. Und deswegen müssen alle irgendwie bereitstehen. Frauen genauso eingebunden wie Männer, also gar nicht so dieses Westeuropäische, Ach so, Werbpflicht auch für Frauen, ne, dann schafft man das. Also man macht so, im gleichen Moment schafft man eigentlich die Frau als Soldatin an, indem man auch die Werbpflicht abschafft. Also so eine ganz komische, wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht so genau, wie wir das jetzt organisieren wollen. Das ist ja in Israel alles ganz anders organisiert. Aber modernste Technik, wie Mürbenglad sagt, um dann zu sagen, Supermoderne Technik, hohe Attraktivität über die Technik, also dass man da gar nicht so als der Schützengrabenkönig, sondern du sitzt hier am Scheithebel der Macht und so weiter, ganz hohe Attraktivität darüber. Wenn man das einfach so nüchtern sieht, ist man immer ein bisschen erschüttert darüber, wie es läuft in Israel und wie tiefgreifend das ist. Aber jetzt aus der Perspektive, wie wir das beobachten, sieht man natürlich die Notwendigkeit, also diesen politischen Willen, der dahintersteckt. Aber an Beispiel Israel sieht man halt, wie schwer es ist, so was dann doch präsent und aktuell zu halten. Und wie strebend auch diese Leute ein normales Leben führen wollen. Dass natürlich nicht die ganze Zeit vom Militär dominiert wird.
Genau, und da ist auch, glaube ich, das Modell ganz schwer adaptierbar. Zumal diese Sache ist gar nicht miteinander zu vergleichen. Und das ist der Ausnahmefall, wo aber auch dann alles anders ist. Also der Umgang mit jungen Menschen dann durch diese technische Hochrüstung. Aber hier zu konstatieren, wir haben es da jetzt bei diesem Krieg auch mit einer posteriorischen Gesellschaft seitens der Russen zu tun, ist etwas, was Putin nicht gerne hören würde. Aber so ist es nun mal. Und dann geht Münkler auf Karl Schlögl. Was Karl Schlögl am Schluss seines Essays vorschlägt. Kiev braucht Waffen. Es braucht die Schließung des Himmels für die russischen Angreifer. Es wartet auf etwas wie eine Luftbrücke, die Berlin gerettet hat. Ist ein Spiel mit dem Feuer. Denn es würde den Westen, die NATO, unmittelbar zur Kriegspartei machen. Eine Flugverbotszone muss man auch durchsetzen. Und das wird nur in einem Luftkrieg möglich sein. Die Romantik des Heroischen macht sich breit, wo es an der Fähigkeit zu strategischer Reflexion mangelt. Wenn man nicht Krieg als ein Spiel, ein Ernst, das versteht, wenn man nicht versteht, was das eigentlich bedeutet, eine No-Fly-Zone, dann kommt man schnell in romantische Gefilde. Und gegen diese Romantik stellt sich Münkler. Das finde ich sehr gut, dass das hier so deutlich gesagt wird. Und ich bin auch verwundert darüber, dass gerade die, die die ganze Zeit sagen, man kann Putin alles zutrauen, ihr habt den unterschätzt. Jetzt sagen, nee, nee, das mit der Atombombe, das würde der auf keinen Fall machen. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist wichtig. Ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass man Putin nicht vertrauen darf. Und das hat er jetzt auch immer wieder unter Beweis gestellt. Und dass wir da nicht von Berechenbarkeit ausgehen kann, ist auch klar. Wenn wir das aber nicht können, dann müssen wir auch diese Atombombe als Ultima Ratio für Putin denken. Und das bedeutet dann für uns, dass wir uns entsprechend verhalten müssen. Da können wir nicht sagen, naja, aber das wird er bestimmt nicht machen. Das ist genauso wie zu sagen, naja, der Putin wird ja nichts machen. Macht euch mal keine Sorgen mit der Ukraine.
Ja, also der Olaf Scholz sagt ja immer wieder dieses Argument. Wir dürfen keine Sanktionen machen, die wir später bereuen, weil wir sie zurücknehmen müssen, weil wir sie nicht durchgehalten haben. Und wir brauchen hier bei Putin auch, ich habe gleich noch einen ganz provokanten Clip. Aber wir brauchen bei Putin auch eine Containment-Strategie, bei der wir uns nicht zu spät darüber ärgern, dass dann doch irgendwo was ausgebrochen ist. Dass irgendwas die ganzen überschritten hat.
Zum Schluss noch Olaf Müller im Deutschlandfunk. Er ist Wissenschaftstheoretiker, äußert sich aber hier zum Pazifismus und sagt erst einmal Folgendes.
Ich bin nicht derjenige, der meint, dass es moralisch verboten wäre, sich zu verteidigen. Die Ukrainer haben das gute Recht, sich zu verteidigen. Ich glaube trotzdem, dass sie nicht gut beraten sind, es so zu machen, wie sie es jetzt tun. Ich glaube, es wäre weniger schlecht, aufzugeben. Das ist bitter, das sagen zu müssen, aber angesichts der großen Übermacht der russischen Armee vermutlich die bessere Option.
Welche Option haben wir? Auch dazu äußert sich Müller.
Die allergrößte Sorge, die einen Pazifisten wie mich jetzt umtreibt, ist allen Ernstes, ohne Hysterie, die Angst vor einem Atomkrieg. Die Gefahr eines Atomkriegs ist durch Putins Einmarsch in der Ukraine drastisch gestiegen und durch unsere westlichen Reaktionen steigern wir diese Gefahr immer weiter. Es sind übrigens nicht Leute mit Jesuslatschen, die diese Gefahr jetzt besonders stark in den Vordergrund spielen, sondern beispielsweise hat in der Talkshow von Maybritt Illner, vorgestern glaube ich der Brigadegeneral aus der Dienstfahrt, das einzige Militär, das da sprach, diese Gefahr betont. Und der ukrainische Botschafter, den wir so sehr sympathisch finden, hat gesagt, Putin blöfft nur. Woher will der Botschafter der Ukraine und woher wollen die anderen wissen, dass Putin nur blöfft, wenn er damit droht?
Ja, dieses Argument, ich habe es noch im Ohr, weil es mich auch erschüttert hat von dem Botschafter, war, Putin will ein Mann der Geschichte sein und dafür braucht er noch jemanden, der seine Geschichte aufschreibt. Da habe ich gedacht, ne, also diese Art von poetischer Argumentation in einer politischen Talkshow bei der Frage, akzeptieren wir jetzt vielleicht dann doch die Möglichkeit, dass wir dann Atombomben plötzlich hier rumfliegen haben? Das kann nicht die Erklärung sein. Da müsste man dann auch ein Standbild mal kurz einschneiden, wo alle mal kurz zur Besinnung kommen, weil so kann man einfach keine Talkshow gestalten.
Nee, wir hören nochmal weiter über das Wissen und Nichtwissen.
Wenn ich den Wissenschaftsphilosophen in Ihnen mal zum Klingen bringe, würden Sie sich richtig wiedergegeben fühlen, wenn ich sage, Sie sagen, es fehlt an hinreichender Kenntnis der Folgen und Sie rechnen immer auch mit Irrtumsanfälligkeit und mit Falsifizierbarkeit?
Ja, die jetzigen Prognosen von Leuten, die sagen, wir müssen noch robuster helfen. Die Leute, die dort so tun, als ob sie wüssten, wie es dann ausgeht, die glauben, dass sie das unter Kontrolle hätten, sind Personen, die nicht sehen, dass Krieg Chaos ist, und zwar ein sehr unvorhergesehenes Chaos, wo sich Aggression, Propaganda, falsche Meinungen, richtige Meinungen, Wut, Angst und Trauer auf eine Weise miteinander vermengen und verquirlen, dass ein chaotisches System entsteht, dessen Weiterentwicklung wir nicht unter Kontrolle haben. Und je stärker wir uns in dieses Knoll hineinbegeben, desto gefährlicher wird es.
Man kann das ja bei Clark nachlesen oder bei Hobsbawm, wenn man mal wissen will, wie man in den ersten Weltkrieg hineingeschlittert ist. Und da zitiert Hobsbawm auch noch die großen Köpfe, also die Könige und Präsidenten und Minister der verschiedenen Kriegsparteien. Und am Ende sagt, ja, nee, so haben wir es ja nicht gewollt. Aber es ist dann eine Dynamik, die entstanden ist, die in dieses Chaos führt. Und dann gibt es irgendwann die Sachzwänge, die der Krieg selbst schafft. Und dagegen ist dann auch kein Kraut mehr gewachsen. Und ich finde, das ist dann so eine ganz gute Wendung, die dieses Gespräch dann hier findet. Wie ist denn das mit den Militärs? Sind das jetzt eigentlich die Pazifisten von den Schriftsteller? Nicht von allen, aber doch von vielen. Hören wir ja eher Irritierendes.
Dass ein Eintritt der NATO in den Krieg nicht einfach nur daran besteht, dass wir dorthin gehen und anfangen zu schießen, sondern dass es einen schleichenden Übergang gibt, der mit Waffenlieferungen anfangen kann. Das sehe ich ganz genauso wie das Militär. Ich glaube, die Militärs sind sehr skeptisch und sehr bedächtig und sehr zurückhaltend. Leider sind das nicht alle Politikerinnen und Politiker.
Das würde jetzt zu einer interessanten These führen, dass kluge Militärs pazifistischer sind wie die Politik.
Also, ich glaube, weil sie besser einschätzen können, wie wenig sie wissen. Das ist ja eigentlich ein philosophischer Satz. Ich weiß, dass ich nichts weiß. Ich weiß, dass ich wenig weiß. Und das ist doch fast immer so, dass Expertinnen und Experten auf dem Gebiet, wo sie sich auskennen, genau sehen die Grenzen ihrer Prognosefähigkeiten. Ich denke, dass die Militärs das besser sehen als viele Politiker.
Und deshalb sagen wir jetzt mal hier Listen to the Science.
Ja, richtig, sehr gut. Es ist dieser Dunning-Kruger-Effekt, wenn man selber nur so halblei auf so einem Gebiet ist, dann kennt man die Grenzen nicht und so weiter. Und dann redet man aber wie jemanden der, und dann will man den trotzdem überzeugen und so weiter. Es gibt ihn, du kennst ihn bestimmt, The Siege, der Ausnahmezustand, ein Film mit Bruce Willis.
Wusstest du, dass die Filmemacher, ich glaube entweder der Drehbuchautor oder der Regisseur, tatsächlich Karl Schmidt rezipiert haben für diesen Film?
Das wusste ich nicht.
Es ist auch mal ein Artikel dazu in der FAZ erschienen, ist aber schon lange her. Ich glaube damals, als er erschien, der Film von Ingeborg Fillinga.
Ist der Film vor 2001 entstanden? Dann ist es ja noch besonders. Also New York wird heimgesucht von mehreren Terroranschlägen. Und die Politiker wissen nicht mehr weiter. Und holen sich erst mal nur einen Rat bei Militär, nämlich bei Bruce Willis. Und der liegt ihnen halt so Handlungsoptionen vor und sagt aber ganz klar dazu, solange sie hier politisch entscheiden, entscheiden sie politisch. Wenn sie meinen, es reicht nicht mehr, dann geben sie mir die Verantwortung und dann mache ich das militärisch. Aber sie müssen sich vorher im Klaren sein, was das dann bedeutet. Weil dann baue ich hier Konzentrationslager in den Stadien auf und so weiter. Und dann werden hier alle, die auch nur muslimisch aussehen, erst mal interniert und dann wird hier also wirklich reine gemacht. Und die Politiker wissen nicht ein nach aus und entscheiden sich dann dafür, das so zu machen. Und sind dann selber immer wieder überrascht, was es bedeutet, so einen Plan dann wirklich durchzuziehen. Und wenn man jetzt so die Militärs in den Nachrichten sieht oder auch in den Talkshows, vor allem diesen FAD oder FLAD, oder wie er heißt, das ist schon beeindruckend zu sehen, in welcher Sicherheit er einfach weiß, wovon er spricht. Und dann auch mal das Wort Atombombe in den Mund nimmt und nicht wie Theo Koll so. Ja, weil dann ist eine Grenze überschritten und dann weiß man auch nicht so genau und so. Das ist dann halt Atombombe. Und wir können auf der Nupe-Map nachgucken, wie so die Radien sind, wenn sie auf Stuttgart fällt. Wie viele Dörfer rundherum werden denn noch verstrahlt die nächsten 30 Jahre. Also es gibt hier kein Wissensdefizit. Listen to the signs. Also man kann sich das einfach anschauen. Und in der Ansicht ist das alles schon sehr betrüblich, diese Entwicklung und diese Art der Diskussion so sieht. Ich will mal mit einem Clip hier noch kurz anschließen. Herrfried Münkler war am 4. März in das Politikteil bei Zeit Online zu Gast. Und nur weil er es da auch nochmal so ganz deutlich sagte. Den Kontext kann man jetzt komplett ignorieren. Aber eine der Varianten, die man mit ihm diskutiert, ist eben auch diese.
Insofern stehen natürlich alle Beteiligten vor dem Problem. Aus Gründen der Menschlichkeit und Humanität, könnte man der Ukraine eigentlich nur sagen, beendet diesen Krieg, bei dem die Chance, dass ihr ihn gewinnen werdet, gering ist.
Weil wir fühlen ja auch noch vielen anderen eben den Krieg.
Genau, das heißt ja nicht gleich Putin nimm dir, was immer du haben willst. Wir ziehen uns aus allem zurück und möchtest du Polen auch noch. Sondern es geht da schon um was anderes.
Genau, wir würden uns ja fragen, was wollen wir denn Putin als Gewinn gönnen? Und dann also drei Jahre dieser Wirtschaftskriege führen bleibt glaube ich nicht viel übrig, was man dann verbuchen kann und erst recht keinen Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung. Gut, wir wollen aber jetzt noch mal ein bisschen über die Stränge schlagen, denn ich habe auch gemerkt, es gibt einen großen Bedarf, sich dann doch noch mal rechts und links ein bisschen abseits der eingetretenen Korridore mit allem, was wir jetzt besprachen und auch bespielten. Was wäre, wenn es stimmt und Putin tatsächlich irre ist? Also wenn das nicht einfach nur der beste Strategie aller Zeiten, weil wir sind ja gerade näher so richtig, also wir hatten eine andere Idee von strategisch Jimmy, das was wir gerade sehen, auf allen Ebenen. Propaganda, Kriegsführung und so weiter. Und bei Esra Klein war Masha Gessen zu Gast, um mal über Radikalisierung in Einsamkeit zu sprechen. Wir hatten im Salon auch schon mal einen Text über die Frage, wer schreibt eigentlich Markus Söder gerade Hassbriefe? Und dann war der ehemalige nordrhein-westfälische Verfassungsschutzpräsident, der dann meinte, ja, das sind so diese einsam und in Einsamkeit radikalisierten 45- bis 65-jährigen Männer. Also nicht die Horde, die auf der Straße organisiert und so weiter, sondern der Einzelne zu Hause. Und diese Masha Gessen redet mit Esra Klein, wie folgt über Putin und seine Motivation?
I think it's a combination of two things. One is actual physical and mental isolation, which apparently has been exacerbated by Covid. He had an extremely tiny circle of interlocutors before the pandemic, and he has apparently cut it down to something like zero since the pandemic begun.
Sehr gut. Gessen, ohnehin hervorragende Autorin. Das kann ich sehr empfehlen, was sie so schreibt. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz obskur individualistische Herangehensweise jetzt. Aber am Ende haben wir es ja mit einem Dezisionismus zu tun. Putin spielt das für sich jahrelang durch. Was mache ich mit der Ukraine? Und dann entscheidet er sich, dass jetzt das Momentum gekommen ist, das zu tun. Und man fragt sich ja schon, was hat sich dann alles aufgesammelt? Was wurde da addiert, dass Putin zu dieser Entscheidung kommt? Es gibt auf den letzten Seiten der Autobiografie über den Krieg, über den zweiten Weltkrieg von Churchill diese interessante Frage, wann entscheidet man eigentlich? Und dann sagt er, na ja, man hat alles Expertenwissen und man hat alle Stimmen gehört. Aber diese eigentliche Entscheidung dann zu handeln, die trifft man eigentlich in so einem Schwebezustand, ohne dass man nochmal das, also da gibt es nicht mehr dieses Pro und Kon, wo man sagt, das Kon überwiegt oder das Pro überwiegt, sondern da gibt es so einen luftleeren Raum, in dem man irgendwie entscheidet. Und dahin kann einen irgendetwas bringen. Und da finde ich diese Argumentation gar nicht so verrückt, wiederum zu sagen, ja, da hat sich jemand in etwas hineingesteigert und hat dann jetzt genau entschlossen, es so zu tun. Denn wenn man sich diese Rede da auch von Putin anhört, wenn man mal davon absieht, dass es sich einfach um so ein Stück Propaganda hält, dann wirkt die Rede ja auch an sich ungeheuer irre. Also wir haben ja schon mal von Fanfiction da gesprochen in diesem Zusammenhang, wo er dann seine Geschichtsfiktion da auftut mit der Ukraine und Russen, wie sich das eigentlich verhält. Und das ist für mich schon ein Zeichen von einem unglaublich idiosynkratisch agierenden Politiker.
Also wir verklammern jetzt hier gerade zwei Themen, die uns sehr beschäftigt haben in diesen ersten zwanziger Jahren, nämlich Corona und dieser Krieg. Und wir reden einfach nur locker über so eine Verbindung, die es gäbe, dadurch, dass wir vielleicht zu lustig fanden, wie lang dieser Tisch ist, an dem Putin immer sitzt. Weil vielleicht ist es nicht nur Spiel gewesen, einen eigenen PCR-Test zu fordern von Macron und Scholz, sondern für ihn wirklich eine Überlebensnotwendigkeit. Ich will nicht in einem Raum sein, wo nur deutsche PCR-Tests sie irgendwas gemacht haben, sondern ich will die Kontrolle dann echt haben.
Die hapanische Angst vor Corona.
Genau, irgendwie so. Und wir kennen es ja auch von Trump. Der war ja auch schon, hatte Angst vor allen möglichen Kram, ist nur mit Furkoster und so was. Und Tüchern rumgerannt, die ihn wieder sauber putzen und bloß nicht zu viele Handschläge und so. Also der ja auch so ein bisschen. Und jetzt, und das kam jetzt heute oder morgen, also ich habe es heute morgen bekommen in meiner kleinen Gruppe da, Behandlung von Long Covid, eine WDR-Aufarbeitung. Schon in der Überschrift das Zitat, im psychologischen Bereich ansetzen. So, und dann Zitate jetzt nur. Wir konnten als Risikofaktor identifizieren, dass vor allem Patientinnen und Patienten, die schon psychologisch psychiatrische Vorerkrankungen hatten, besonders anfällig für Long Covid sind. Etwa Menschen mit Depression, Angststörungen, posttraumatischen Belastungsstörungen. Dann haben wir uns die Berufe näher angeschaut. Und wir fanden, dass vor allem Menschen in Verwaltungsberufen, Lehrberufen oder im Beamtentum sich signifikant häufiger bei uns in der Long Covid Ambulanz vorstellten, als Patienten und Patientinnen, die eher handwerkliche Berufe haben. Also Berufe wie Bauarbeiter oder Berufe mit starker körperlicher Arbeit. Und ich würde hinzufügen, Arbeit, die im Kollektiv, in Kameradschaft, in Sozialität, in Kommunikation stattfinden. Und vielleicht haben wir es hier wirklich mit einem ernsthaften Problem zu tun. Nicht nur bei der Frage, was hat Putin hier geritten, sondern auch, am wann befassen wir uns eigentlich mit Long-Covid und Long-Lockdown? Wir wissen ja heute schon aus dieser einen Studie, dass die Kinder sehr viel mehr von Long-Lockdown betroffen sind als von Long-Covid. Schon allein, weil mehr im Lockdown waren nämlich alle. Und jetzt wird hier für die Erwachsenen Long-Covid schon ausgeräumt in so einer Hinsicht körperlicher Kontrollverlust, der allerdings psychosomatisch ursächlich ist und nicht einfach...
Aber es gibt ja auch Leute, die wirklich ein Herzproblem dadurch bekommen haben.
Genau, die Herzentzündungen und so weiter sind ja auch so weit dokumentiert und können ja auch gut behandelt werden, wenn sie beobachtet sind. Wenn die Sensibilität da ist, so wie jetzt auch nach den Impfungen und so weiter, ist das ja alles behandelbar. Aber wir haben es hier irgendwie mit diesem Long-Covid, ich bin mal sehr gespannt, in welche Richtung das sich jetzt dreht. Das RKI kann ja dann vielleicht auch bald die Abteilung 2 wieder aufmachen, wo die endemischen, nicht infektiösen Krankheiten behandelt werden, also nicht über Viren und Bakterien, aber trotzdem halt stattfinden Krankheiten, wo ja auch das ganze Psychozeug mal behandelt werden muss. Also wir haben es hier irgendwie dann doch mit so einem, wie soll man sagen, mit einer echt großen offenen Fragestellung. Vielleicht dauert das bis nächstes Jahr, bis wir feststellen, wie kommen wir eigentlich raus aus diesem ganzen inneren Lockdown? Es scheint ja jetzt doch so ein Frühling und ein Sommer zu sein, der auch verspricht, dass es im Herbst nicht wieder große Betriebsschließungen und so weiter gibt. Mal gucken.
Ich gehe ja auch nicht davon aus und finde auch, dass man sich da ganz klar wehren sollte dann dagegen. Also in der Form, dass man einfach die Stimmen mehr zu Wort kommen lässt, die unter den Lockdowns gelitten haben, um wirklich zu sagen, was wollen wir da eigentlich erreichen? Und ich bin noch ein bisschen überrascht. Jetzt haben wir diese vielen jungen Politiker im Bundestag und die haben nichts Besseres zu tun als in jeder Impfdebatte, die es im Bundestag gibt, 15 Reden zu halten. Dann haltet doch lieber mal reden über die Fragen, die jetzt junge Leute wirklich interessieren, nicht die Impfpflicht, sondern gibt es dann vielleicht mal eine Entschädigung, ist jetzt mal wieder Feiern möglich und und und. Also da hätte man ja sehr viele Themen gehabt, die man aufgreifen kann. Und dass man diese komische Diskussion die ganze Zeit hat mit den Schattenfamilien. Also dass man glaubt, man muss jetzt nochmal die Schattenfamilien hervorholen, um damit eine ewige Maskenpflicht einzuführen. Dann finde ich auch, ist man irgendwie schief gewickelt. Denn das ist auch für mich die große Frage. Also man kann sagen, die Inzidenzen sind so hoch, deswegen können wir ihn nicht weiter lockern. Das war ja die Argumentation von ganz vielen Bundestagsabgeordneten auch. Aber dann frage ich mich für die Vulnerable, bleibt hier das Virus, das Virus und das Virus verschwindet nicht. Wollt ihr eine Maskenpflicht für immer, dann sagt das bitte. Und dann können wir gerne darüber debattieren oder abstimmen. Und da würde ich sagen, da bin ich dagegen. Wenn jemand sagt, er ist dafür, dann kann er das ja gerne sagen. Ich würde sagen, wenn wir das einem demokratischen Prozedere aussetzen, dann wird meine Seite vermutlich gewinnen.
Genau, über Corona gleich noch Clips von Drossen, die das für uns, finde ich, auch noch mal abschließen, einfach jetzt im März, damit wir es dann im April dann weg haben. Trotzdem, ich habe ja gesagt, wir schlagen noch mal kurz ein bisschen über die Stränge. kim.com, wir kennen ihn alle als den durchgedrehten Exilanten, der auf welche Irren...
Einst Internet-Millionär, Multimillionär, ein Libertärer, Netzhacker, ich weiß gar nicht, und auch so eine Galionsfigur in den 90er Jahren.
Immer mit dicken Autos rumgefahren.
Für viele, die was mit Internet machen wollten, war das doch ein Vorbild. Nun ist er... Wo sitzt er? Auf welcher Insel?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Also er ist jedenfalls im Exil und ist von dort aus meistens nur über Twitter.
Genau, auf Twitter verfolge ich es immer mal wieder so ein bisschen. Und es ist jetzt beispielhaft für... keine Ahnung, er hat es jetzt mal so ein bisschen rausgekramt, guckt sich da viel im Internet. Und weil Christian Lindner davon sprach, dass die Friedensdividende vorbei ist, und da würde ich halt hart widersprechen und sagen, ne, also wir leben hier alle im Frieden und in einem Fall hat es jetzt mal nicht funktioniert. Das heißt, wenn nicht das Prinzip aufgehoben ist. Es gibt ja auch eine Kriegsdividende und die kann man ja auch mal thematisieren. Und das ist zum einen, dass Christian Lindner jetzt einfach den Haushalt blockieren kann, indem er sagt, für alle Ansprüche, die jemals kommen, aber wir haben doch 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr locker gemacht. Wir haben kein Geld mehr. Eigentlich wir so denken, jetzt lernen doch gerade alle, dass 100 Milliarden einfach zur Verfügung stünden. Er das aber umdreht und uns dann einfach sagt, ne, ne, ne. Das ist jetzt meine Kriegsdividende, die will ich ja auch haben. Ihr kriegt ja keine Geschenke. Lasst das mal alles im privaten Sektor machen, damit auch die Return-on-Investments entsprechend privat sind. Wir finanzieren ja gar nichts mehr, weil wir haben durch die Bundeswehr schon so viel Geld ausgegeben. Und demgegenüber kann man ja eine Kriegsdividende stellen und kim.com hat nun halt einfach mal die ganzen Telegram-Gruppen leer gelesen und kam hier irgendwie auf so ein Bild von die US-Regierung wollte in der Ukraine eine Showmaster-Regierung installieren, die so als Propaganda-Könner Russland so krass provozieren und gleichzeitig so unterstellen, wir sind aber nur Show. Also wir sind ja keine echten Politiker, wir sind ja nur Schauspieler. Wenn du gegen uns Krieg führst, dann heben wir die Hände und geben uns geschlagen. Weil dann kommt die Realität. Und dass da so eine gewisse Motivation in Amerika war, um dann Russland und Putins Russland mal so richtig auszuzehren. Das, was man schon immer machen wollte.
Das ist seine Theorie, dass die das so in so einen Selinsky installiert haben, um Putin zu provozieren.
Genau, also die amerikanische Regierung installiert in der Ukraine eine Russland provozierende Regierung, die aber gleichzeitig sich als Waschlappen darstellen, sodass Putin sagt, also jetzt reicht es mir aber, jetzt übernehme ich die. Und das ist dann sozusagen der Anlass, um Russland auszubluten, wie kim.com schreibt. Und er hat das in einigen Strategy Documents of the Think Tanks gelesen. Also es gibt irgendwo Think Tanks, die ihm irgendwie so Strategy Documents...
Die einen Zugriff haben und wir aber alle nicht.
Genau, die ihm das irgendwie hingelegt haben. Und nun gut, das Ziel ist Regime Change in Russland. Und diese Spielerei kann man natürlich unendlich weit treiben, weil dann kommt man natürlich auf irgendwelche Börsenwerte. Also die amerikanische Regierung hat der Ukraine 2 Billionen, also 2 Milliarden Dollar Waffen geliefert. Das kann man ja auch soweit dokumentiert nachlesen. Heißt aber, dass damit ein Krieg befeuert wird, der eine Nachfrage schafft, der die 4 der 25 größten Waffenhersteller in Amerika, Raytheon, Lockheed, Northrop und General ID, insgesamt einen Plus an Marktkapitalisierung im Rahmen von 107, 1 Milliarden verschafft haben. Also macht er so eine Kalkulation auf.
Ja, er ist eigentlich in dem Argumentationsmuster noch wie bei Sea-White Mills, wo der militärische-industrielle Komplex einen ganz anderen Stellenwert in den USA hatte, als er es heute tut. Denn das Militär ist zwar immer noch sehr wichtig in den USA und da fließt ja auch enorm viel Geld rein. Und das ist auch für die Wirtschaft nicht ganz unerheblich. Aber doch hat das Militär nicht mehr diesen Stellenwert für die gesamte amerikanische Volkswirtschaft, wie das vor Jahrzehnten der Fall war. Und das ist immer noch eine sehr starke Argumentation, auch die wir mitunter in Deutschland finden, was die deutschen Rüstungskonzerne anbelangt. Natürlich haben die jetzt auch enorm profitiert davon, dass es so eine Ankündigung gibt, wie 100 Milliarden mehr für die Bundeswehr. Aber wenn man sich einfach den Industriezweig Reinmetall gibt, und Heckler & Koch und noch ein paar, wenn man sich die ansieht, dann sind die in gewisser Weise auch zu vernachlässigen. Das heißt, da könnte man wirklich sagen, die deutsche Volkswirtschaft würde jetzt nichts verlieren, wenn man ab sofort den Morgen den Laden dicht machen würde. Also, dass es das noch so stark gibt, wie das in den USA tatsächlich in den 60er Jahren bei Seawide Mills dann nachzulesen und auch zu beobachten war, da sind wir heute dann doch relativ weit entfernt. Also da würde ich sagen, ist das Silicon Valley am Ende immer interessanter.
Das finde ich auch. Also in Deutschland ist es ja insbesondere so, die Waffenindustrie hat nur noch eine Chance, weil sie halt über Wahlkreise einzelne Abgeordnete oder so.
Und dann noch mal irgendein CDU-Abgeordneter sagt, wir kennen uns doch aus dem Schützenverein. Da werde ich mich nochmal ein Zeug legen, dass du doch was nach Ägypt bringst.
Aber so unter diesen Fan-Fitch-Gesichtspunkten, dass man ja doch irgendwo einen Sinn sucht. Und wir jetzt schon festgestellt haben, wir fragen lieber bei der Gessen nochmal nach, ob das vielleicht so eine radikale Einsamkeit war, ob das so eine einsame Radikalisierung oder wie auch immer.
Ich finde das schön, weil es so profan ist. Deswegen finde ich das von der Gessen gut.
Einfache Erklärung. Und bei kim.com ist es halt dieses große Bild. Russland sollte eh zerstört werden. Die Frage, wie machen wir es denn nun? Na ja, wir machen von Anfang an die Strategie, dass es sich nur auf die Ukraine konzentriert und dort aber dann so ein richtiger Verzehrungskrieg stattfindet. Dass wir uns dann irgendwann im Juni fragen, womit will denn Putin jetzt Polen angreifen? Mit der allerletzten Rakete, die noch übrig ist. Weil das ist ja auch alles Importware. Klar, die stellen da viel her, aber das sind ja auch Mikrochips, die da immer zerstört werden, wenn eine Bombe explodiert. Und in deren Sicht finde ich das irgendwie so ein Bild. Also das hat eine gewisse Attraktivität. Auch wenn es wahrscheinlich mal wieder, wie bei jeder Verschwörung, einfach zu kompliziert wäre, das so zu organisieren, dass man jetzt ein Schlachtfeld hat, wo man wirklich von außen dasteht. Und ab jetzt einfach nur noch von außen immer sagen, das NATO-Gebiet ist unangreifbar, sodass die Sache in Ukraine contained ist. Und dann aber dort muss es richtig verbraucht werden. Da soll sich Russland mal so richtig verbrauchen.
Sag mir doch mal gerade, wie hoch ist die Marktkapitalisierung von Facebook gewesen? Und wie hoch ist sie jetzt? Hast du das vielleicht gerade da? Denn erstaunlich ist ja, wir haben erlebt, dass die Aktie ein Drittel an Wert verloren hat. Also jetzt mal grob gesagt von 300 Euro auf 200 Euro.
Genau, ich habe den Screenshot gestern nochmal aktualisiert. Ich wollte eigentlich im Februar schon mit dir darüber sprechen. Wir können es heute auch nur nennen. Aber wir sehen hier den Jahresvergleich. Facebook lange, lange, lange so auf diesem 300er, die Niveau und jetzt auf 200. Und es gibt diese typische Recovery, die wir immer so bewundernswert fanden. Ja, da gibt es so einen Heap von Links, aber dann drei Wochen später ist der Kurs wieder da. Und dann ist wieder, den gibt es gerade nicht. Also einen kleinen Ansätzen vielleicht kann man jetzt irgendwie sehen, aber der ist erst mal so nicht da.
Und um Kim Dotcom nämlich mit Fakten zu schlagen, die Marktkapitalisierung von Facebook ist jetzt gerade bei 625 Milliarden. Die Rechnung, die Erde aufmacht mit den Rüstungskonzernen, da dreht es sich insgesamt um 100 Milliarden. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich das BIP der USA oder so steigern will und da mit Marktkapitalisierung und mit Return of Invest kommt, dann hätte man besser an beidens Stelle gesagt, pass mal auf, Putin, ich habe hier so einen ganz tollen Facebook-Deal für dich. Oder ich verkaufe Facebook noch wo sonst wohin oder mache irgendwas. Also dann hätte man lieber sowas gemacht als dieser ganze Rüstungskram.
Genau. Und das allerdings ist auch gerade wieder eine, und das können wir kurz markieren, eine ganz große, es gibt kein gutes positives Wort dafür, Leere vielleicht allgemein für uns alle, die wir auf diesem Planeten leben. Es ist für China nachweislich einsehbar, jeder versteht es, leichter, wie soll man sagen, ordentlicher organisierbar und alles, Taiwan in den nächsten 50 Jahren einfach ökonomisch zu übernehmen, zu kaufen, als auch nur irgendeine Idee zu entwickeln, wie man diese 160 Kilometer See überbrickt, um dort einen erfolgreichen militärischen Einsatz zu vollziehen. Dieses Szenario ist gerade ganz weit ausgeräumt. Das ist ja auch irgendwie nicht schlecht. Zu Facebook gibt es noch zu sagen, werben und verkaufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Zeitung ist, zu der man dann so geht. Aber für diesen Facebook war es nicht schlecht. Die hatten im Februar noch so ein... Die Idee ist ja, Facebook hat festgestellt, dass sie es irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig hinkriegen. Erst einmal Quartalszahlen, wo es auch echt so negative Entwicklungen zu verkünden gab. Wo es also heißt, die Wachstumsidee ist nicht mehr da. Und in diesem Kost-Gewinn-Verhältnis, also da war ja, wenn man das mal so mit Standardunternehmen vergleicht, war ja Facebook immer sehr viel mehr wert, als die Umsatz- und Gewinne machen. Also war eigentlich immer eine Wachstumsidee gebunden, und die hat sich jetzt zerlegt. Und mit dieser Umbenennung in Meta haben sie dann auch markiert, dass es nicht mehr Facebook ist, sondern dass sie jetzt irgendwie versuchen, Instagram und WhatsApp so ein bisschen attraktiv zu machen. Und bei Werben und Verkaufen haben sie dann einfach die Überschrift gewählt. Meta verliert 500 Milliarden Dollar wegen Umbenennung. Und das fand ich so. Da steckte so diese ganze Hilflosigkeit irgendwie drin. Na ja, zurück zu Putin. Jetzt haben wir auf der einen Seite diese Idee von die Amerikaner wollten das so. Jetzt haben sie ein Szenario, das ihnen gefällt. Und jetzt warten sie einfach noch drei Monate, bis sich Russland leer geschossen hat. Und dann hat man endlich ein auf dem Boden liegendes Russland. Das ist nicht mehr so eine große Gefahr oder wie auch immer. Vielleicht sogar mit einem neuen Präsidenten. Auf der anderen Seite die russische Fanfiction-Idee. Mir ist hier ein Tweet untergekommen von Kamil Galeev. Keine Ahnung, wer das ist. Und er hat einen Fernseh-Clip aus Russland getitelt. Ich spiele ihn mal an, der hat aber nur Untertitel. Also ich muss gleich referieren, was da gesagt wird. So ein richtiger Tweet. Also geht jetzt erstmal Twitter auf. Und es klingt wie folgt.
Vor den Augen des Menschen Russen, vor den Augen der Armee Russen, vor den Augen der ganzen Welt.
Also wir hören so ein bisschen den Ton, mit welcher VMN es hier vorgetragen wird. Das ist ein Clip, den haben 1, 8 Millionen Menschen gesehen. Und der Typ, der da spricht, heißt Solowoyev. Und das ist wohl ein ganz enger, so aus diesem Beraterkreis, Mitdenker da in Russland, in Moskau und so. Und das, was er hier vorträgt, in so einer, zwei anderen Männer hören ihm zu, aber noch viele so zu Hause im Publikum, ist, wenn wir Putin verlieren, also wenn das amerikanische Kriegsziel ist, Putin aus dem Weg zu räumen. Und wir haben ja von Joe Biden jetzt schon dieses, es gab ein Redemanuskript und dann hat er einfach noch so eingefädelt spontan, oh mein Gott, dieser Mann darf dann nicht an der Macht bleiben. Und dann kamen ganz viele Berater aus Washington und meinten, das, was Joe Biden gerade gesagt hat, war spontan in die Rede eingeflochten, das ist nicht die offizielle Politik, wir wollen keinen Regime-Challenge in Russland. Und dann kommt zwei Tage später Biden und sagt, ich nehme davon nichts zurück. Dann alle wieder und keiner wusste genau, wie kriegt man das wieder eingefangen? Und es ist erst mal nicht eingefangen. Hacks on Tap, also David X-Rod und so, die haben eine Stunde Podcast nur zu diesem Spruch gemacht. Wie ist das jetzt zu bewerten? Und in Russland wird das natürlich irgendwie so thematisiert, entweder in der Bevölkerung allgemein oder halt in den Kreisen, dass es ein Ziel gibt, und das ist ja so Befreiung, wir befreien jetzt Russland von Putin. Und dieser Typ, dieser Berater hier, steht im Fernsehen und sagt, wenn wir Putin verlieren, ist das der eigentliche Moment, auf den die Amerikaner immerhin gezielt haben, weil sie dann ganz Russland von der Landkarte nehmen können. Also wir haben diese ganz große Verknüpfung von Putin und Russland. An Putins Leben hängt das Schicksal Russlands. Und wenn Putin erstmal weg ist, dann ist das die Gelegenheit, dass sie bei uns einmarschieren und einfach sagen, das reicht uns jetzt mit Russland, weg damit. Und das sollte man glaube ich schon im Hinterkopf haben bei den künftigen Entwicklungen. Wir kriegen ja sehr wenig mit, wie die da in Russland gerade so reden. Dieses Fernsehprogramm wird uns nicht übersetzt. Wir kriegen manchmal so ein paar Einblicke in so Highlights irgendwie. Aber in Russland gehen die Abendnachrichten gerade doppelt so lang wie üblich. Und auch die Diskussionssendungen im Fernsehen sind anders gestaltet. Also da dreht sich jetzt schon viel um den Krieg. Das ist nicht so, dass es nur eine Spezialoperation ist usw. Und naja, das sind so die Hintergedanken, die da in Russland irgendwie mitspringen, dass man da doch eine Angst hat, dass es um alles geht. Dass mehr Kalküle auf westlicher Seite vorhanden sind, als einfach nur die Ukrainer zu unterstützen. Und dass man dann wirklich nachlassen würde, wenn die Amerikaner... Also in dem Falle sagt er hier, sobald Putin auch nur eine Unterschrift unter irgendein Friedensdokument sitzt, sind wir alle verloren.
Und da sieht man, wie hoch das Risiko ist, dem wir alle ausgesetzt sind.
So und jetzt dachte ich mir, jetzt haben wir ja Corona schon angeschnitten, machen wir ein kleines Corona-Kapitel, nur mit den paar Clips, die einfach auch zu spielen sind. Am 1. März schon, also lange bevor Drosten jetzt mit 113 das Coronavirus-Update abgesagt hat, viel künftig, sagte Drosten noch mal zum Thema Öffnen usw. Folgendes.
Ganz einfach ausgedrückt, das Argumentieren für Infektionen auf dem Boden einer vollständigen Impfung, also einer dreifachen Impfung...
Aber nur dann.
Nicht das Argumentieren für Durchseuchung. Durchseuchung ist was anderes. Das ist das Argumentieren für den graduellen Erwerb einer Übertragungsimmunität in der Bevölkerung. Das muss man auch so sehen.
Das, was der Drosten hier sagt, ist ja im Grunde, bisher haben wir die Infektion vermieden. Jetzt drehen wir das Vorzeichen um. Wir brauchen jetzt die Infektion. Denn wir haben ja keine Schleimhautimmunität. Das Virus wird weitergegeben. Wir haben erst mal nur die zelluläre Immunantwort, die uns vor Krankheit schützt. Aber es gibt ja Menschen, die noch vor dem Virus geschützt werden müssen. Das klappt nur mit Bevölkerungsimmunität, die individuell auf der Schleimhaut abspielt. Das finde ich schon interessant, wie er das Argument zum einen richtig aufnimmt und es auch explizit sagt, das Virus gehört jetzt dazu. Wir brauchen das. Wir müssen jetzt Kontakt mit dem Virus haben, um in die Endemie zu kommen. Denn die einzige Alternative, dass wir auch die Schleimhautimmunität über eine Impfung herstellen, die gibt es nicht.
Die Alternative wäre, dass man Lebendimpfstoffe hätte, bei denen man sich das Vaccinevirus auf die Schleimhaut geben kann. Zum Beispiel als Nasen- oder Rachenspray. Und dort eine lokale Schleimhautimmunität aufbaut über ein dezent replizierendes, aber überhaupt nicht krank machendes Lebendvaccin. Und das könnte man der ganzen Bevölkerung verabreichen. Das wäre ideal, aber so eine Vaccine gibt es noch nicht zugelassen. Und darum ist bis zu einer Änderung dieser Zulassungssituation solcher Vaccinen der Erwerb von natürlichen Infektionen. Vor allem in der geimpften, jungen Bevölkerung über die Zeit der Schlüssel zur Unterbindung der spontanen Übertragung und zur Beendigung der Pandemie.
Das heißt, ich habe mich jetzt absolut richtig verhalten, ganz viele Veranstaltungen zu machen. Ich war auch viel aus dann im Anschluss in Restaurants und Lokalen. Wie erklärst du dir, dass ich bislang zumindest nicht wissentlich etwas habe? Das heißt, ich bin symptomfrei. Man kann ja auch Corona haben und spürt rein gar nichts. Aber wie kannst du dir erklären, dass ich, obwohl ich so viele Kontakte hatte, muss ich ja statistisch mit Leuten zu tun gehabt haben, die infiziert waren. Und dennoch...
Du hast ja auch statistisch genau in dem Moment gemacht, wo du PIK-Immunisierung durch die Impfung hast. Also bei dir ist wirklich keine Krankheit ausgebrochen. Und deine Schleimhäute haben jetzt aber das Virus kennengelernt.
Aber ich will es nicht zu laut sagen, nicht beschwörmlich. Wer weiß, vielleicht ächze ich schon nächste Woche hier am Salon am Mikro und sage, ich habe es jetzt doch aufbekommen.
Aber wir wissen, du ächzt es dann halt einfach nur im Salon rum. Und niemand muss sich ernsthaft Sorgen machen, dass es dich da hinrafft oder so. Das wollen wir ja nicht hoffen. Das gibt uns ja schon mal Hoffnung. Und das zweite große Thema und das nur in zwei Clips, was mit Corona zu tun hat. Kara Swisher hat es hier nur ganz kurz so nebenbei. Es ist schon fast so ein, ja Corona ist ja noch da und so weiter. Und inhaltlich sind die Ausmaße aber beträchtlich.
Heute sind mehr als 50 Millionen Menschen in Shanghai und Shenzhen geschlossen. Shenzhen hatte 66 neue Fälle von Covid am Sonntag.
Wir haben auch über Schenzhen gelesen und wir kennen alle Schanghai. Die beiden Orte im Lockdown. Das ist mehr Einfluss auf die Weltwirtschaft als die Weizenfelder in der Ukraine.
Nicht in Betrieb. Und trotzdem erscheinen noch täglich Artikel, in denen steht, jetzt muss die EZB aber mal was tun gegen die Inflation. Und ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, wie kann das denn eigentlich sein, wo die Dinge so auf der Hand liegen, warum jetzt gerade Preissteigerungen stattfinden. Dann kann man doch nicht ernsthaft noch sagen, die EZB soll jetzt mal mit der lockeren Geldpolitik aufhören. Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das ist für mich überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehbar, wie man einfach diese beiden Dinge immer wieder miteinander vermengen kann. Ja, das ist so, wie wenn du sagst, ich bin heute zu spät gekommen. Und dann antworte ich, ja, du liest ja auch so gerne Romane. Also da fragt man sich ja auch, ja, aber das eine hat ja mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Genau, dazu mal zwei kleine Clips. Südekum zum einen, gerade weil jetzt mit, also es verklammert sich jetzt einfach. Corona ist jetzt auch ein wirkliches Wirtschaftsthema. Und wir haben mit Corona und dem Krieg wirklich jetzt viel vor uns. Und Südekum sagt, wie du es eben auch schon angeschnitten hast, zu den Energiepreisen folgendes.
In den kommenden 90 Tagen sollen Monatstickets im Nahverkehr nur 9 Euro kosten. Die FDP-Idee vom Tankrabatt ist vom Tisch. Stattdessen wird die Energiesteuer auf Kraftstoffe gesenkt. Benzin soll so 30 Cent, Diesel 14 Cent billiger werden.
Alle Maßnahmen, die direkt versuchen, den Benzinpreis zu reduzieren, sei es ein Tankrabatt, wo staatliche Subventionen gezahlt werden, sei es jetzt temporäre Steuersenkungen, sind aus meiner Sicht nicht der richtige Weg. Denn wir müssen einfach akzeptieren, dass wir durch Putin, durch den Konflikt, den wir da haben, es mit steigenden Energiepreisen zu tun haben. Auch die müssen wir mit Energiesparen reagieren.
Ja, es führt keinen Weg drum herum. Wir können an den Energiepreisen, wenn sie so sind, wie sie sind, wenig machen. Wir müssen dann in unserem Verhalten daran arbeiten und sich dem zu stellen, finde ich einen ganz wichtigen Appell irgendwie. Weil das war ja auch grundsätzlich diese Klimaambitionen, die wir haben. Ja, die Preise sollen steigen, damit wir eben die Ausweichbewegung in die Erneuerbaren machen. Und David McWilliams hatte hier einen Gast und hat dann selber auch noch mal dieses Problem beschrieben, wie du es eben ansprachst. Was soll die Fett jetzt machen, wenn wir doch klar sehen, und das wird künftig dann auch natürlich die Ernährung sein, aber jetzt ist es erstmal der Ölpreis, wenn kann sie überhaupt irgendwas machen. Und er ist ja auch relativ eindeutig so als Ökonom. Das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem. Wenn wir jetzt die Zinsen erhöhen und damit das Geld teurer machen, hat das gar keinen Einfluss auf die Energiepreise, es sei denn, wir dämpfen die so sehr runter, dass einfach die Nachfrage nach der Energie sinkt und deswegen die Preise sich auf dem Gebiet wieder normalisieren.
Dann produzieren wir eine Rezession, unter der alle richtig hart zu leiden haben, und eine Zinsanhöhung. Für wen ist das gut? Vielleicht noch für deine Boomer, die tatsächlich noch die großen Sparbücher haben und es verpasst haben an den Märkten sich ein bisschen umzutun und die da sagen, das ist aber auch noch schön, wenn ich auf diese 200.000 jetzt nochmal ordentlich Zinsen bekomme. Denn alle anderen Leute, jungen Leute, sind ja verschuldet oder werden sich verschulden, um sich eine Wohnung zum Beispiel kaufen zu können. Und wenn die jetzt auch noch zwei oder gar drei Prozent Zinsen darauf zahlen sollen, auf diesen immens hohen Kredit, dann ist es für die ja noch schlimmer. Dann ist ja für die eine Doppelbelastung da. Zum einen müssen die mehr ausgeben für die Energie, weil sie teurer geworden ist. Und dann sollen sie jetzt auch noch mehr ausgeben für den Zins. Also man produziert im Prinzip eine Zinsinflation. Dann ist es so irre, dass man glaubt, dass irgendjemand damit geholfen wird. Und es ist aber dann ganz bemerkenswert, wenn man im Handelsblatt mal so ein bisschen liest, dann gibt es immer noch diese Kommentare und jetzt muss aber die FED und die EZB auch. Aber dann gibt es Leute, die an den Märkten richtig investiert sind, also aktionäre Spekulanten und die sagen, oh, das wäre jetzt aber wirklich doof, wenn die Zinsen jetzt zu schnell rausschrauben, dann fliehen ja viele wieder aus den Märkten raus. Und dann haben wir am Ende nicht mehr so eine bullische Stimmung an den Aktienmärkten. Und inzwischen bin ich fast froh, wenn auf die Spekulanten gehört wird, damit wenigstens dieser Wahnsinn des EZB-Bashings aufhört.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall, und das merken wir, wir haben es schon lange kritisiert, aber jetzt wird es handfest, dass die Europäische Zentralbank nur ein Benchmark hat für ihre erfolgreiche Arbeit, nämlich die Inflation runterbringen. Und sei es, dass wir die ganze Wirtschaft mal so richtig runterdämpfen, um Energiepreise zu senken, weil die in den Warenkorb-Inflation so hochrangig sind, zeigt, wie irre das ist und wie wichtig es ist, dass die EZB anfängt, dieses ganze Green Finance jetzt nach Standards auszurichten, dass die FED schon lange auch den Arbeitsmarkt und die Arbeitslosigkeit und die Arbeitslosenquote im Blick hat und daraufhin zuarbeitet. Und wir dann vielleicht auch irgendwann mal dieses BIP hinter uns lassen und mal so ein paar Nachhaltigkeitsdinger, die ja Habeck schon mit einbaut, so in seine Wirtschaftspolitik. Also das wird jetzt ganz drängend, weil jetzt an den alten Benchmarks zu bleiben und daraufhin zu optimieren, ist ganz falsch. Insbesondere bei diesen Ölpreisen. Und das ist hier so ein Clip, den habe ich ja vorhin schon mal angeteasert. Der Wilhelm mit Williams hatte einen Gast. Er hat die leider nirgendwo geschrieben, wie der heißt. Irgendwie Jean oder John, die kennen sich seit Kindertagen, keine Ahnung. Und der Typ sitzt da im Mittleren Osten und ist ganz tief drin, alltagsmäßig so im Hin- und Herdealing von dem ganzen Öl und so weiter. Und er beschreibt hier mal so eine Situation, die wir gleich noch mal einschätzen.
Die große Herausforderung dieses Moments ist, dass Öl sehr fungibel ist und Gas immer mehr so ist. Es ist wie Wasser, die auf einer Helle geht. Es wird auf dieser Helle gehen. Wenn Europa Russland, Öl und Gas-Exporten blockiert, werden sie irgendwo enden. Sie werden nicht einfach auf dem Boden bleiben. Aber im Endeffekt, die Beziehung zwischen Saudi-Arabien und China, das ist der große Schuss, wenn du magst. Saudi-Arabien ist heute viel mehr mit dem Thema, dass sie die größte Öl-Suppe in China ist, als in Amerika, obwohl sie noch Öl in Amerika verkaufen.
Es gibt Öl-Löcher auf der Welt, die sind einfach gebohrt. Und da sprudelt Öl raus. Das ist aber kein Hahn, den man zudrehen kann, wie uns immer erzählt wird. Putin dreht den Hahn zu. Sondern dieses Öl muss irgendwo hin. Im besten Fall wird es einfach abtransportiert. Im schlechtesten Fall muss es vor Ort gespeichert werden. Diese Speichermöglichkeiten gibt es nicht, auch in Russland nicht, in diesem Maße, wie man sie da bräuchte. Beim Gas umso schlimmer. Das fließt durch die Pipelines. Und wenn die Pipeline kaputt ist, tritt es aus. Wenn Putin irgendwie entscheidet, ich verkaufe das jetzt nicht mehr, weil mir die Bedingungen nicht mehr zusagen, ich will hier ein Zeichen setzen, fackelt er das dann ab, entlässt das einfach so in die Atmosphäre. Also das sind so ganz handfeste Probleme. Und er beschreibt hier......brennende Ölfelder kennen werden. So was, genau. Er beschreibt hier dieses Szenario oder dieses Phänomen, dass wir eigentlich einen echten Weltmarkt für Öl und Gas haben. Mit Anbietern und Nachfragern. Und das muss bedient werden am Ende. Nur weil es da politische Verstimmung gibt, heißt das nicht, dass die einen kein Öl mehr brauchen. Wir sehen ja unsere Ausweichbewegung. Und im Grunde bräuchten wir hier wirklich so eine ganz große Vernunft, dass man einfach sagt, Leute, es ist egal, wo es herkommt und es ist egal, wo es hingeht. Es muss halt einfach gehandelt werden. Wir können uns hier nicht so wie beim Soja leisten, dass wir den einen gar nichts mehr gönnen, deswegen nichts mehr schicken. China und dann den Bauern alles entschädigen und das Zeug, aber ja, was denn eigentlich? Auf den Müll hauen wir uns nicht. Wir tun es halt irgendwie auf den Weltmarkt. Und am Ende, und das war ja eine Lehre, das hatten wir ja auch schon mal im Podcast in dem Clip dokumentiert, war, naja, der Soja kommt in China an. Der wird halt nur vorher einmal in Australien zwischengeparkt, sodass es einen neuen Verkäufer gibt und so. Und so ist das beim Öl ja auch, bei den ganzen Energiesachen. Es macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Klar, ist alles heldenhaft, dass Habeck sich da jetzt so ins Zeug schmeißt. Aber um was denn eigentlich? Ja, damit dann auf unserem Kassenzettel steht, nicht an Putin verkauft. Also es ist schon, es ist schon wirklich sehr merkwürdig.
Und das sind die Widersprüche, mit denen wir leben müssen. Das ist ja eigentlich eine ganz kindliche Fantasie, die diese rigorosen Moralisten bei Twitter haben. Ich will nicht, dass der, was da von mir bekommt und von mir profitiert, das ist so ein bisschen, wie man teilt den Kuchen in der Klasse auf und will aber nicht seinen Erzfeind auch bedienen mit dem Geburtstagskuchen. Aber die Sache ist einfach, dass wir in einem globalen Kapitalismus diese enormen Abhängigkeiten haben und sie auch nur durch eine radikale Abschottung zu beenden werden. Also dann ist aber wirklich alles hochziehen und dann müssen wir uns komplett umstrukturieren, das kann keiner wollen. Und so werden wir immer wieder in solchen moralisch prekären Situationen sein. Also die moralische Präkarität ist immer extrem hoch, sobald man global handelt. Denn wir können ja uns mal überlegen, welche Länder noch nicht auch nach unseren Standards funktionieren, bei denen man zu Recht auch mal anfragen könnte, wollen wir mit denen noch Handel treiben. Und dann wird die Auswahl sehr beschränkt. Man kann daraus eine Politik formen. Und sowas passiert ja dann über ein Lieferkettengesetz zum Beispiel, wenn man es entsprechend durchzieht. Und das verändert dann auch das Wirtschaften in aller Welt. Und das verändert vielleicht dann so zumindest die vage Hoffnung, auch Machtverhältnisse in Ländern zugunsten von mehr Menschenrechten, mehr Demokratie, was auch immer. Aber das sind wirklich sehr kleine inkrementelle Schritte, die da gegangen werden können. Aber zu glauben, dass man ganz rigoros agieren kann, bedeutet nur, dass man hin zu einer Seite mal rigoros reagiert, um dann aber gleich wieder andere Abhängigkeiten schaffen zu müssen, die natürlich moralisch, sehen wir, ob das Beispiel Katar, hoch fragwürdig sind.
Gut, schließen wir das Ganze, weil du es noch mal angesprochen hast, mit einem Clip ab. Also das Szenario ist bekannt. Habeck fährt nach Katar. Kriegt es dort natürlich noch irgendwie hingebogen, weil es ja nicht sein Fehler ist, sondern es ist die fossile Industrie mit Merkel und so weiter. Und er versucht das jetzt irgendwie hinzubiegen. Und wir bekommen dazu eine Einschätzung von Markus Krajewski, Wirtschaftswissenschaftler der Uni Erlangen im Heute-Journal. Der einen ganz interessanten Verweis macht. Wir hatten ganz ausführlich über das Lieferkettengesetz gesprochen, auch darüber, wo es scheiterte, also dass es nicht diese Zugkraft hat. Und da fand ich diesen Clip hier dann doch recht überraschend.
Es bleibt also das Dilemma der Bundesregierung, Geschäfte mit den Demokratie-Schmuddelkindern machen zu müssen. Denn bei Gas, Öl und Wasserstoff sind die Produzenten halt überschaubar. Experten sehen aber auch Chancen. Deutsche Rechtsstandards und deutsche Hightech-Produkte könnten die Handelspartner gezwungenermaßen zum Umdenken führen.
Der Wirtschaftsminister hat ja auch zu Recht auf das Lieferkettengesetz hingewiesen. Ich gehe davon aus, dass die deutschen Unternehmen, die jetzt Verträge machen werden, sich an dieses Gesetz halten müssen und dann natürlich auch prüfen müssen, ob in ihren Zulieferern eben die Menschenrechte eingehalten werden.
Das ist ja eine Wunschvorstellung eigentlich. Wir haben ein Szenario, bei dem wir sagen, also mit Kriegstreibern, nee, da kaufen wir kein Öl. Dann, irre wie es ist, kaufen wir es halt woanders und sagen dann aber, jetzt binden wir uns von vorn herein und sagen, mit diesem Kauf des Öls stellt ihr auch bessere Bedingungen her, schreibt sie ruhig mit auf die Rechnung. Das ist ja das Szenario. Und da könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, und er verweist ja auf Habeck selbst, hat auf das Lieferkettengesetz verweist. Das hätte Altmaier ja nie gemacht.
Genau, und das ist das große Versäumnis der Merkel-Ära und auch nochmal das Versäumnis von Altmaier ganz speziell, dass solche Deals mit den Russen nicht gemacht wurden. Man hätte da nicht nur einfach sagen können, naja, wir schaffen eine Abhängigkeit und das wird schon langen und da wird Putin doch nicht. Aber man hätte vielleicht da viel stärker auf Verbindlichkeiten setzen müssen und hätte ihn nicht frühzeitig, wie manche glauben, isolieren müssen. Dann wäre er frühzeitig auch in die Ukraine vermutlich einmarschiert, sondern man hätte schauen können, ob man über diesen Weg der Verhandlungen, die über die Profitinteressen hinausgehen, ob man darüber auch hätte Politik machen können. Und ich glaube, dass da viel Potenzial verschenkt wurde.
Genau, hoffen wir, dass sie alle lernen. So, das Klima. Vom letzten Monat, das ist heute noch interessanter als damals, ist vom Wohnbautag das Thema energetisches Sanieren übrig geblieben. Und jetzt sind wir sozusagen handfest in der Realität. Was bedeutet das so ganz konkret? Wir sind ja eine Volksverschreibung, die das irgendwie leisten muss und so. Und um dieses Thema einzuleiten, will ich mal Folgendes vortragen. Und du kannst mir dann sagen, ob du davon schon gehört hattest. Und viele Hörer können sich auch überlegen, bitte was ist das jetzt? Ist das jetzt ausgedacht? Ist das Fanfiction? Ist das Dramatisierung oder ist das Realität? Also die Washington Post hat am 18. März einen Text gehabt mit Rekordhitze in der Antarktis. 70 Grad über Normal. 70. Ich habe es mal von Diebbel übersetzen lassen. Der kälteste Ort der Erde hat in dieser Woche eine Warmwetterperiode erlebt. Wie sie noch nie zuvor beobachtet wurde, die Temperaturen über dem ostantarktischen Eisschild stiegen um 50 bis 90 Grad über den Normalwert. Die Wärme hatte Rekorde gebrochen und Wissenschaftler schockiert. Zitat. Dieses Ereignis ist völlig beispiellos und hat unsere Erwartungen an das antarktische Klimasystem auf den Kopf gestellt. So Jonathan Weil, Forscher der Polar Meteorologie an der Universität Grenoble, der in Frankreich sitzt. Ich glaube, er schrieb die eben auch von einer Forschungsstation. Jedenfalls die Fakten. Statt dass es zwischen minus 50 und minus 60 Grad Celsius dort ist, war es zwischen minus 12 und minus 18 Grad Celsius. Also immer noch unter Null, aber weit drüber. Der Märzdurchschnitt von Vostok, das ist so Zentrum des östlichen Eisschilds. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Ort ist oder nur so ein Punkt auf der Karte. Es lag 15 Grad über dem vorherigen Monatsrekord. Also der Durchschnittswert des Märzes lag 15 Grad über dem bisherigen Rekord. Man misst dort seit 65 Jahren. Vostok lag 65 Jahre lang zwischen März und Oktober niemals an keinem einzelnen Zeitpunkt über minus 30 Grad Celsius und diesmal waren es minus 17 Grad. Also wir haben es mit einer unglaublichen, wenn wir jetzt überlegen, die Erde darf sich aber nicht um zwei Grad erwärmen und so weiter. Also wir haben es hier mit unglaublichen Werten zu tun.
Man müsste sich mal vorstellen, man würde sagen, hier sind jetzt mal 50 Grad gewesen in Deutschland.
Richtig. Man müsste sich mal vorstellen, es gäbe eine Anne-Ville-Sendung, in der man darüber redet, dass das Ahrtal, nach dem Schrecken der Flut, plötzlich eine Woche lang 53 Grad aufgeheizt wurde von der Sonne. Oder wie auch immer. Also so ein Szenarien. Na ja, es gibt also einen echten Bedarf, hier wirklich mal was zu ändern. Und nun, beim Bauen ist das wie folgt. Wir Deutschen sind gar nicht so schlecht beim Bauen. Und das ist ja unter anderem auch deswegen noch ein interessantes Thema, da es bei der Gasversorgung in Deutschland ein Primat gibt für das Wohnen. Hast du das gewusst? Ich wusste das gar nicht.
Nein.
Also wenn Gas knapp wird, also wenn es nicht nur teuer wird, sondern wirklich knapp, dann muss die Industrie zurückstehen. Dann werden erst Wohnungen geheizt. Ich war auch ein bisschen überrascht, weil...
Ich hätte es mir jetzt umgekehrt durchaus auch vorstellen können.
Ja, ist irgendwie, aber ist halt wie es ist. Und aus dem Wohnbautag, da wurde das ganz tiefgreifend thematisiert, auch in welcher großen Perspektive das jetzt gemacht werden muss. Aber der ist zustand, ich fand ihn erstmal gar nicht so schlecht.
Der Energieverbrauch sieht so aus, dass wir mit dem Wohngebäudebestand etwa 27 Prozent Anteil haben am Endenergieverbrauch des gesamten, des gesamten Deutschlands. Das sind 633 Terawattstunden. Diese Zahl wird uns später nochmal so ein bisschen beschäftigen. Das sind übrigens nur 18 Prozent der Emissionen. Das zeigt also, da ist eine gewisse Effizienz bereits sozusagen im System eminent. Auch hier ist es so, dass der überwiegende Teil des Endenergieverbrauchs und auch der Emissionen auf die Ein- und Zweifamilienhäuser fallen und nur irgendwie 10 Prozent um und bei des Endenergieverbrauchs und 7 Prozent der CO2-Emissionen auf den Geschosswohnungsbau, der ja überwiegend vermietet ist.
So, 27 Prozent der Energie geht fürs Wohnen drauf, aber nur 18 Prozent der Emissionen. Das ist also ein gewisser Effizienzvorteil zu einem Stahlkocher oder so. Und beim Wohnen muss man noch mal ganz hart differenzieren zwischen Geschosswohnungsbau, wo die Wohnungen sich gegenseitig so ein bisschen heizen und der übergroße Anteil an Emissionen, der eben auf dieses Einzelwohnen geht, wo wir wie Niklas Mark ja auch immer wieder betont, auch einfach, wie soll man sagen, eine Industrielobby auf den Leib gegangen sind die letzten Jahrzehnte.
Und zwar überall in den Städten, dass man dann sagte, Bauland wird erschlossen, aber bitte nur ein Geschoss durchbauen mit Satteldach. Das ist ja eine ganz erstaunliche Sache, dass man sagt, es ist eigentlich knapp und jetzt versucht man nicht in die Höhe zu gehen, sondern sagt, ne, jetzt bauen die alle nur so, dass möglichst viel Fläche verbraucht wird. Aber eigentlich bringt das nichts und jetzt hört man auch noch energetisch, das ist auch noch ein Fiasco.
Richtig und ich finde in diesem Maße, wie wir hier hören, dass zehn Prozent für den Geschosswohnungsbau draufgeht und alles andere für also diese Art von Synergien, die dann nicht ergriffen werden. Jeder braucht eigene vier Wände. Nee, man könnte auch drei Wände davon kombinieren, schon mit einer anderen Wohnung, für die das auch jeweils die vierte Wand ist und so weiter. In diesem Maße haben wir uns ja auch in die Einsamkeit reingewohnt. Das wird ja im Rednerpublik auch ein großes Thema. Also Kapitel habe ich jetzt die Tage geschrieben, das ist wirklich schlimm, wie die alten Leute wohnen. 75 Prozent der Frauen über 75 leben alleine auf 80 Quadratmetern oder so was. Also das macht nicht glücklich.
Man kann mal durch diese teuren Vororte von Groblins gehen. Da leben diese Witwinnen mit 75 auf 220 Quadratmetern alleine.
Ja, und das ist nicht das, was sie wirklich wollen, sondern die wollen einen kleinen Rückzugsort in der großen Gemeinschaft. Darum geht es. Also wir leben hier völlig falsch und das macht sich energetisch besonders nicht bezahlt. Und trotzdem gab es hier gute historische Fortschritte.
Und jetzt kommen wir nochmal zum Klimaschutz. Und da schwingt so ein bisschen auch in der aktuellen Diskussion mit, dass im Wohngebäudebereich viel zu wenig passiert ist. Das können wir nicht so ganz nachvollziehen. Seit 1990 hat der Gebäudesektor 43 Prozent CO2 eingespart. Punkt. Und in diesem Zeitraum sind über 9 Millionen Wohnungen gebaut worden und die Wohnfläche ist um 42 Prozent angewachsen. Das heißt, da ist enorm was passiert. Und nach wie vor bleibt das Gap, das Delta der Investitionen im Wohngebäudebereich, um CO2 einzusparen, um eine Tonne CO2 einzusparen. In der Wohnungsmodernisierung investieren wir zwischen 850 und 2500 Euro. Im Industriebereich liegt der Investitionshöhe, um eine Tonne CO2 einzusparen, irgendwo zwischen 10 bis 150 Euro. Also ist es im Wohngebäudebereich einfach ein vielfaches Höher. Und das müssen wir immer bei all unseren Überlegungen mitschwingen lassen. Wir müssen uns überlegen, wo ist die effizienteste Art in Klimaneutralität und in Klimawirksamkeit einzuinvestieren.
Und das fand ich ein bisschen überraschend, ehrlich gesagt, dass die Industrie da so hell hinterherhängt, weil wir es mit unglaublichen Wohnkosten zu tun haben und unglaublich viel Geld bezahlen, um dann nochmal eine Tonne rauszuholen. Und die Industrie könnte mit dem Zehntel an Investitionsgut dasselbe bewerkstelligen. Also in dieser Gesamtrechnung werden hier Menschen, die sowieso schon teuer wohnen, nochmal richtig bestraft.
Und man ist ja jetzt dabei, die Industrie nochmal zu schützen vor den hohen Energiebreiten. Das ist ja nochmal diese Idee. Eigentlich müsste man nach dem, was man da hört, sagen, nein, alle Leute, die wohnen, die bekommen jetzt eine Förderung oder die bekommen zumindest nicht noch eine höhere Preissteigerung, als es jetzt ohnehin schon ist. Aber die Industrie, die müsste man dafür mal besonders jetzt an die Kanne nehmen, damit die handeln. Denn ich glaube auch, wir haben ein relativ hohes Bewusstsein entsprechend da. Vielleicht auch, weil es so schnell für die Lebenswelt nachvollziehbar wird, wenn man die Rechnung bekommt, wenn man weiß, was irgendwas verbraucht, wenn man irgendwas an- oder ausschaltet. Da ist dann das Bewusstsein dafür da, aber dass die Industrie sich da so durchmogelt und ja doch einen ganz erheblichen Teil zu Emissionen beiträgt und auch dazu beiträgt, dass Putin viel verdient an uns, muss man eigentlich jetzt gerade die Industrie in die Verantwortung nehmen. Und Geld ist ja vorhanden. Also Geld wurde ja einfach nur wohin geschoben. Wir haben das ja bei Kurzarbeitergeld schon gesehen. Da hat man eigentlich die Aktionäre reich gemacht, die Besitzer dieser großen Unternehmen. Und jetzt müssen wir das nicht noch mal machen, sondern da könnte man jetzt sagen, ja, jetzt kostet es aber auch mal, wie man das tatsächlich ja jedem, der ein Haus baut, sagt. Dann sagt man ja, es kostet halt mehr. Du kannst jetzt nicht mehr so bauen wie vor 30 Jahren, sondern du musst jetzt mehr Geld dafür ausgeben.
Genau. Und da sehe ich einen ganz großen Auftrag und auch einen großen politischen Auftrag, dass wir das jetzt alle einfordern. Die Industrie, klar, hier geht es jetzt um Wohnbautag, aber wir haben gerade über Bande erfahren, wie viel Defizit es da noch gibt und das muss jetzt mal eingeklagt werden. Also die Industrie, so wie Südekum sagte, die Preise sind jetzt da, da kann man jetzt leider nicht rechts und links irgendwas mal mit Zinsen oder so. Und alles, das führt alles in die Irre, die Preise sind, wie sie sind. Wir wollten ja auch, dass sie steigen, jetzt sind sie gestiegen. Und damit muss man jetzt arbeiten. Beim Wohnen fand ich super interessant, dass Habeck, der als Wirtschaftsminister dann hier dastand, einen, finde ich, super kompetenten Vortrag gehalten hat. Also ich war ganz überrascht. Wir haben uns ja doch jetzt daran gewöhnt, dass er so dieser gefühlige und so. Ich nehme euch mal mit.
Aber zugleich versteht er es immer in wirtschaftlicher Weise. Das finde ich einfach beeindruckend, die jetzt so in den letzten Wochen alle Statements, die wir von Habeck gesehen haben, zeugen immer davon, dass da jemand ein volkswirtschaftliches Verständnis hat.
Genau, er ist gut gebrieft, hat dort auch klare Ansagen gemacht, die auch so ein bisschen witzig sind. Zum Beispiel meinte er, obwohl das können wir nachher vielleicht noch als Clip spielen, aber da gab es ein paar amüsante Sachen. Hier, finde ich, versteckt sich auch ein ganz großer Auftrag, an dem auch viele nicht nur finanziell profitieren, sondern auch so ideell.
Bisher kaum gesetzlichen Niederschlag gefunden und auch nicht in der Förderung Niederschlag gefunden, hat der gesamte Bereich der Digitalisierung. Darüber habe ich aber mit einigen von Ihnen persönlich und mit einigen, die hier nicht da sind, nämlich den Unternehmen, die solche Technik vorhalten, mehrfach gesprochen. Es beginnt natürlich erst einmal damit, dass vielleicht die Thermostate alle vernünftig eingestellt und gewartet werden. Und es endet aber bei weitem noch nicht die Schätzung, dass man durch kluge, intelligente Führung von Wärme oder in diesem späteren Fall dann elektrischen Energieeffizienzen von bis zu 30 Prozent heben kann.
Allein in der Umorganisation, Umstrukturierung von Steuerungs... Also wir haben ja auch hier so eine Heizung. Da geht man halt hin und drückt so ein paar Knöpfe. Und dann stellt man irgendwann so ein Frühjahr fest, ne, die muss nicht mehr bei 21 Grad laufen. Es reichen auch 19. Hier friert niemand und so, ne? Und das passiert aber nicht von alleine. Wir kriegen immer diese Rechnung vorgemacht, dass irgendwer im Fernsehen sagt, nur die Heizung 1 Grad runter drehen spart uns 6% der Gas-Importe aus Russland. Und dann frage ich mich ja, dann dreh doch die Heizung runter. Also soll ich das jetzt machen oder kann man nicht einfach mal eine Heizung runter drehen? Und habe ich halt hier die Zahl aufgemacht, es sind noch 30% an Effizienz rauszuholen. Weil man das einfach nur mal clever macht. Wenn Oma mir jetzt aber warm ist und ich mache das Fenster auf, weil sie sich nicht an die Heizung traut. Weil das halt, ne, da muss ich erst anrufen und so. Und das fand ich doch überraschend. Weil das bedeutet ja, und da frage ich mich seit langem, wo ist eigentlich das Einfallstor? Wir haben diese Silicon Valley für jeden Scheiß. Also wirklich für jeden Scheiß. Außer fürs Wohnen. Das Wohnen wurde noch nie so richtig disrupted. In keiner Weise. Außer, was weiß ich, Glühbirnen, die über WLAN-Steuerbar sind oder sowas. Und diese Art von Digitalisierung, und wir hören ja, was das für ein Markt ist, hier gibt es ja auch echte Gewinne jetzt abzuschöpfen. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt mit einer guten Idee, der dir sagt, so wie bei der Matratze, wir verkaufen dir eine Matratze und wollen dann aber die Rendite, die du aus dem besseren Schlaf hast, sozusagen abgreifen, warum das nicht auch bei dir sehr ganz... Wir helfen dir dabei, Energie zu sparen. Und die Rechnung gibt es dann in fünf Jahren. Du musst nicht jetzt ad hoc die ganze neue Heizung bezahlen, sondern solche Ideen irgendwie, solche Finanzierungs- Umstrukturierungs-Ideen gibt es ja nirgendwo, aber die bieten sich ja wirklich an, weil 30 Prozent, das ist ja nun wirklich mal eine Marke. Habeck hat dann hier beim Wohnen mal dieses Ding aufgemacht. Klar, kann man sich jetzt auf jedes Dach eine Solarzelle setzen und mit Geothermie und wie auch immer arbeiten, also unglaublich viel Energie günstig erzeugen, nur besser wäre es doch, wenn das Wohnhaus selbst Kraftwerk wäre für andere. Also dass man nicht über Energieverschwendung plötzlich macht, weil man ja eh nur die Sonne dann verschwendet statt Gas, sondern hier steckt auch, finde ich, so eine kollektive Idee für unsere ganze Gesellschaft dahinter.
Volkswirtschaftlich und energiepolitisch stößt man natürlich an eine Grenze, weil wir so einen Hunger nach Energie haben und einen Bedarf an erneuerbaren Energien. Die ganze Industrie will Wasserstoff haben. Die ganzen Autos sollen elektrisch fahren, dass wir die Anzahl von Windkraftanlagen und Photovoltaik ja irgendwie in den Griff bekommen müssen und limitieren müssen. Insofern macht es natürlich Sinn, möglichst Effizienz nach vorne zu stellen, also möglichst wenig Energie zu verbrauchen. Und das wäre meine Antwort, ohne die Studie im Detail zu kennen. Was individuell aufgeht, also das Null-Emissionshaus schlecht isoliert, aber alles mit erneuerbaren Energien, macht volkswirtschaftlich hoch ineffizient sein. Deswegen wird darüber noch ein bisschen zu streiten sein. Also schlecht isolierte Häuser mit Wasserstoff, der erneuerbar hergestellt wird, statt Gas zu befeuern, ist zwar energetisch neutral, aber die Anlagen müssen ja irgendwo stehen und möglicherweise brauchen wir sie an anderer Stelle.
Ja, möglicherweise brauchen wir sie an anderer Stelle. Wir kennen ja den Bedarf der Industrie nach Energie. Und hier kann das private Haus noch zuliefern. Und Nachbarn hier in der Nachbarschaft haben auch Solarzellen auf dem Dach. Und es stellt sich immer wieder raus, wie überraschend es ist, dass man auf der Dachfläche, die einem das normale Haus bietet, dann doch Faktor 5, 6, 7 des eigenen Stroms rausholen kann. So viel? Ja, das ist mega viel. Du brauchst ja nur Helligkeit. Im Sommer, wenn die Hitze kommt, wird es ein bisschen weniger. Also, ich wusste auch lange nicht, dass die Hitze da so, man müsste die irgendwie kühlen. Aber allein diese Helligkeit, man kann auch gut mit der Schattenseite von Dächern zum Beispiel arbeiten. Man muss dann nur ein bisschen kombinieren, dass man nicht, weil diese Anlagen, wenn man jetzt so vorbeiläuft an so einem Haus, sieht man ja immer verschiedene Platten oben und der ganze Strom, die ganze Stromerzeugung orientiert sich immer an der gerade am schwächsten beleuchteten Platte. Also man kann nicht aus jedem das Maximum, sondern wenn man dann eine Schattenseite und dann bräuchte man so zwei Systeme, also man muss das noch so ein bisschen alles organisieren.
Das heißt, es wird Energie gerade im großen Ausmaß weggeworfen, die produziert ist. Also das wäre, als würde man Kuchen backen und zwar immer so viel, immer für vier Familien, obwohl man nur eine Familie ist. Und dann würde man sagen, was machen wir mit dem Kuchen, dann werfen wir ihn mal wieder weg. Statt jetzt zu sagen, lieber Nachbar, hat da noch jemand Lust auf Kuchen. Und eigentlich machen wir das mit der Energie in einem hohen Ausmaße schon.
Absolut, es ist alles verschwendet. Du kriegst deine Solaranlage gefördert, aber nicht die Batterie so richtig. Die Batterien sind auch auf dem Markt nicht so richtig verfügbar. Da hätte man vor 15 Jahren schon mit E-Mobilität anfangen müssen, damit diese Akkus, die dann irgendwie runtergefahren werden, nur 75 Prozent Leistungsfähigkeit. Im Auto ist das blöd, mit einem schlechten Akku im Keller. Das stellt man halt in die Ecke. Also da kann auch wirklich ein doppelt so großer Akku mit einer der halben Leistung stehen, der dann einfach noch zehn Jahre runterrockt. Und dann holt man sich halt den nächsten, der aus der Mobilität rausfällt. Diese Solardächer, ich bin immer wieder verwundert, warum das so wenig Thema ist. Habeck hat das hier in ein ganz wunderbares Bild gekleidet.
Sie wissen, dass im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart wurde, dass es eine Solarpflicht für alle gewerblichen Gebäude geben soll. Und eine Sollbestimmung für Neubau auch für Einfamilienhäuser, also privat genutzte Einfamilienhäuser, das ist dann weicher. Aber im Prinzip ist es ja ein interessantes Modell. Die Flächen sollen ja bereitgestellt werden und dann über das EEG, dessen Fördersätze wir uns noch mal genau anschauen werden, dann auch Gewinn bringen. Also die Investition führt dann letztlich ja zu der, darf ich es so frech formulieren, Verpflichtung, Geld zu verdienen.
Eine Solaranlage auf dem Dach ist für dich die Verpflichtung, dann Geld zu verdienen, weil sie machen sie zur Pflicht. Ich habe ja schon mal diese Rechnung aufgemacht, wenn in Deutschland ein Haus gekauft wird, so viel Familien oder sonstiges, dann wird ja eine Grunderwerbssteuer fällig und die ist im Grunde Pi mal Daumen ungefähr doppelt so hoch, wie eine Solaranlage kosten würde. Der Staat würde sich so viel so erleichtern, wenn man einfach sagt, bezahle um den Betrag weniger Grunderwerbssteuer in dem Maße, indem du den Solardings aufs Dach haust. Da wäre so vielen geholfen, aber klar, damit sind dann halt auch die großen Energieerzeuger aus dem Spiel. Also REW.
Würde aber die Wirtschaft auf andere Weise ankurbeln.
Genau.
Diese Panels müssen ja produziert und montiert werden.
Ganz genau. Da könnte man so viel Bedarf schaffen. Und wir kennen ja den Wohnungsbau-Bedarf und dann auch den Sanierungsbedarf.
Aber da ist sehr viel Wahlkreis-Lobbyismus natürlich auch drin. Denn da könnten auch Städte mit Modellprojekten dieserweise kommen. Wir hatten das ja schon mal vor einem Jahr, als wir über die Klimakonferenz von beiden gesprochen haben, dass man anschließend nur Bürgermeister zu Wort kommen ließ, die dann beschrieben haben, was man machen kann. Und da war ja auch gerade dieser Sektor des ökologischen Bauens das ganz Entscheidende, was in Städten stattfinden muss. Aber solange natürlich da entsprechende Seilschaften bestehen und man sagt, naja, wir sind ja hier beim Energieversorger, da gibt es ja auch einige Drehtüreffekte, um es mal so auszudrücken. Solange das natürlich so stark ist, wird es schwierig.
Richtig. Und wir können jetzt, da März ist, auch kurz darüber reden, in Tesla, also Tesla hat jetzt in Grünheide diese Fabrik geöffnet. Und es ist für mich, dadurch, dass jetzt auch das erste Auto da vom Band rollte und Olaf Scholz da war und so weiter, alle super euphorisch, das ist für mich auch wieder diese große Lehre, auch jetzt so sozio-logisch super interessant einfach. Manchmal hat man es mit Produkten und Projekten zu tun, die kriegt man aus den alten Industrieorganisationen nicht mehr raus. Für die müssen die abgerissen werden und es muss alles neu gegründet werden. Bei Tesla ist ja so, dass da relativ viele ehemalige Auto-Manager und Ingenieure arbeiten, die eben lieber in Berlin leben wollen. Das heißt, da treffen sich vielleicht sogar Kollegen von früher wieder, aber eben in einem anderen Kontext, in einer neuen Institution. Und da drin steckt so eine große Lehre. Wir müssen einiges neu machen, indem wir es wirklich neu machen. Und nicht nur eine Modernisierung.
Das ist etwas, was die Autokonzerne, die Deutschen, ja lange Zeit überhaupt nicht wahrhaben wollten. Jemand wie Herbert Diess, den man jetzt im Sinne der Arbeitnehmer natürlich kritisieren kann, aber jemand wie Herbert Diess hat ja das Potenzial von Elon Musk sehr früh erkannt. Wird auch jetzt immer wieder auf Elon Musk angesprochen, kürzlich auch im Handelsblatt. Ja, aber Elon Musk hat ja da Vorstellungen, da wissen wir doch, das wird gar nicht realisiert. Und dann sagt dann Diess über seinen Konkurrenten Musk, also wir sollten ihn auf keinen Fall unterschätzen. Und Diess ist ja angetreten, um diesem doch sehr verstaubten VW-Konzern zu sagen, ihr habt jetzt jahrelang mit dem Dreck Geld verdient. Da könnt ihr jetzt auch noch sagen, es war eine schöne Zeit, aber feststeht, diese Zeit endet. Und jetzt ist es an der Zeit, auf E-Mobilität umzusteigen und das haben die viel zu spät gemacht. Und jemand wie Diess ist dann jemand, der versucht, diesen Konzern diese Richtung zu bringen, was jetzt nicht gleich bedeutet, dass das ein grüner Konzern wird. Wenn man sich ansieht, er hatte ja die Aktionärsversammlung jetzt, wo er hat dies Erfolge verkündet. Natürlich hat man SUVs noch und nöcher verkauft. Und zwar nicht nur in Deutschland, da bitte ich auch mal, den nicht ganz so eurozentrischen Blick an den Tag zu legen. In alle Welt verkauft man SUVs, weil alle Welt SUVs liebt. Das ist auch ein ganz großes Problem, dass wir damit natürlich haben. Aber was sich da deutlich zeigt, ist, dass diese extrem verkrustete Industriepolitik in Deutschland sich jahrelang die Augen verschlossen hat vor dem, was da eigentlich schon längst auf dem Vormarsch ist. Und jetzt versuchen wir noch mal ganz schnell an die Spitze des Fortschritts zu rennen. Mit Elon Maslow gab es ja damals dieses komische Video auch mit Armin Laschet. Das sieht jetzt ein bisschen besser aus, wenn die aktuelle Bundesregierung da auftaucht. Aber man muss da ganz klar erkennen, der Erfolg von Elon Musk ist eigentlich ein Zeichen für das Versagen deutscher Industriepolitik.
Ganz genau. Und wir brauchen hier ganz dringend alles neu von Grund auf. Beispielsweise, weil wir das ganze Heizen einfach mal umbauen müssen.
Wir haben im Moment in Deutschland 1, 2 Millionen Wärmepumpen. Diese Zahl muss und sollte gesteigert werden auf 6 Millionen im Jahr 2030. Den Ausbau und die Befeuerung von Wärmenetzen mit erneuerbaren Energien wäre als zweites zu nennen. Damit verbindet sich ein Quartiersansatz, dass wir die Wärmeversorgung nicht immer nur über die Einzelbefeuerungsanlage betrachten werden, sondern die Synergien, die möglichen Synergien, die im System sind, versuchen zu heben. Vorbild sind beispielsweise skandinavische Städte, die ja zwar früher damit angefangen haben, aber die durch systemischen Aufbau der verbundenen Systeme, die verschiedenen Energiequellen, die verfügbar sind, Abwärme, Abwasserwärme, industrielle Wärme, aber auch Solarthermie, Geothermie oder Biomasse verbunden haben in einem System. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht so schwer zu sehen. Und hier rede ich vor einem Fachpublikum, viel einfacher, im System etwas zu verändern, als jede Einzelheizung oder Ölheizung gegebenenfalls sich einzeln anzuschauen und die dann zu versuchen zu ersetzen.
Jetzt sagt er einfach so, das ist, glaube ich, nicht so schwer zu sehen. Ich rede hier auch vor Fachleuten. Das sind aber Fachleute, die wahnsinnig viel Geld damit verdienen, dass sie alle zehn Meter in der Straße eine neue Heizung verkaufen, was absolut nicht notwendig und bescheuert ist und aber immer weiter passiert. Das ist einfach grotesk. Also wir sitzen hier gerade in einem Dachgeschoss von sechs Reihenhäusern. Die sind ungefähr 5, 50 Meter breit, d.h. alle sechs Meter steht hier dieselbe Heizung statt einfach.
Ja, so einfach möchte man mal Geld verdienen.
Das ist unglaublich.
Das ist Wahnsinn eigentlich. Und dieses Plädoyer für Verbundsysteme und Synergieeffekte, das trifft hier halt auf ein Fachpublikum, das aber das nicht will, dass diesen Wandel einfach nicht will. Na ja, Felix Paklapa ist vom Baugewerbe und stellt mal den Bedarf von Seiten der Haushersteller her.
Kapazitätsaufbau ist so ein scheues Reh. Dafür brauchen wir verlässliche Rahmenbedingungen. Und wenn wir im Moment sehen, was wir an Bauaufgaben vor uns haben, Sie haben die Klimawende genannt, wir haben die soziale Frage, wie kriegen wir bezahlbaren Wohnraum gebaut? Und im Grunde genommen kommt noch ein dritter Punkt dazu, das ist die demografische Entwicklung. Wir müssen anders bauen für eine älter werdende Gesellschaft. Das sind drei Dinge, die wir miteinander zusammenbringen müssen. Und von daher bin ich nicht ganz überzeugt von dem, was Sie gesagt haben, dass wir als Bau- und Immobilienwirtschaft nicht auf Zielfahrt sind. Wenn wir gucken, wir sind seit 1990, haben wir mehr als 40 Prozent der CO2-Emissionen senken können, obwohl wir fast drei Millionen Wohnungen dazugebaut haben in der Zeit. Also ich glaube, das ist schon ganz ordentlich, so dass man uns die Zielfahrt nicht ganz absprechen kann. Aber was wir brauchen, ist natürlich ein klarer Fahrplan.
So ein Fahrplan. Wir brauchen ja alle einen Fahrplan, weg vom russischen Öl und Gas zum Beispiel. Und das ist die Frage, wie? Und dann hat ja Olaf Scholz schon so einen klugen Spruch gemacht, wie ja, wir haben es 150 Jahre aufgebaut und jetzt wollen wir es bis 2045 umbauen. Also in, was weiß ich, 20 Jahren. Und das ist natürlich eine echte Herausforderung. Kann man die schaffen? Die Bauindustrie sieht hier irgendwie so ein Pfad. Da können wir ja alle mal überlegen, ist das jetzt vernünftig und realistisch? Also kriegt man hier Wunsch und Wirklichkeit in eins.
Was haben wir denn eigentlich an Sanierungsraten? Sie kennen diese ja auch in der politischen Diskussion, sehr intensiv geführte Frage, wie intensiver wir in die Modernisierung einsteigen sollen, wie sehr wir eben auch die Sanierungsrate erhöhen müssen. Und im Moment zeigt sich, wir haben mal die unterschiedlichsten Studien und unterschiedlichsten Überlegungen, Szenarien ausgewertet, so ein gewisser Gemeinsinn darin zu sagen, so eine Sanierungsrate von 1, 8 Prozent auf die nächsten 23 Jahre verteilt, um dabei mindestens 40 Prozent der Gebäude zu erreichen. Das scheint sich als ein sozusagen wissenschaftlich-wirtschaftliches Optimum herauszustellen.
Also es gibt hier so ein, wie soll man sagen, ein R-Wert. Also es gibt so einen Wert. 1, 8 Prozent Sanierung über 23 Jahre bringt dann irgendwie, und dann sind wir 2045 so bei 40 Prozent, saniert. Frage ist, Sanierung wohin? Gas ist ja bis heute immer noch die beliebteste Heizung. Die kann man dann in Wärmetauscher umwandeln. Man buddelt also ein Loch und holt sich Wärme aus der Tiefe. Und das wurde hier nochmal kurz eingeschätzt von einem Experten Alexander Steinfeld von CO2 Online. Das ist so eine Beratungsagentur, die aber staatlich unterstützt wird. Wie ist das jetzt tatsächlich? Also das ist jetzt der Wunsch. Die haben so durchgerechnet, ja so 1, 8 Prozent über 23 Jahre. Das heißt, wenn man heute jemanden ausbildet in dem Beruf, kann man den 23 Jahre dann einsetzen für diese Tätigkeit. Lohnt sich also für die Industrie sowas zu machen. Wo stehen wir aber gerade? Beispielsweise bei der Frage Heizungsaustausch.
Das waren im vergangenen Jahr ungefähr 300.000 neue Heizungen, die eingebaut wurden. Ist das die Geschwindigkeit, in der das gerade funktioniert?
Also die Sanierung gerade liegt gerade bei 1 Prozent, aber sie sollte eher bei zwei oder drei Prozent liegen.
1 Prozent, das heißt, eine von 100 Heizungen wird zurzeit jedes Jahr ausgewechselt in Deutschland?
Das ist auch eine schwierige Sache. Es werden noch zu wenig Heizungen ausgetauscht. Sanierung bedeutet ja nicht nur der Heizungstausch, sondern auch andere Sanierungsmaßnahmen.
So, da kann ich aber auch nochmal die Zahl bringen, die ich das letzte Mal schon genannt habe. Die Gasheizung, die ich neu mache, weil die alte kaputt ist, kostet 10.000 Euro. Die Wärmepumpentechnik, die natürlich viel besser wäre, ökologischer wäre, kostet 30.000. Und da gibt es keine Förderung dann, die bekommt dann eher die Industrie. Und dann ist ja vollkommen klar, dass jeder sagen wird, da mache ich für 10.000 Euro eine Heizung. Denn wer gibt einfach 20.000 Euro mehr aus? So sehr kann dann auch Putin nicht pressieren, dass man das macht.
Genau, also hier gibt es einzelne Hindernisse, die müssten alle mal überwunden werden. Und ja, wir liegen weit hinter diesem Ziel auf 1, 8% Sanierung, wir liegen bei 1% und selbst da haperts und hakt überall. Und Robert Habeck stellt jetzt hier immer noch ein Problem da, das auch ein bisschen amüsant ist. Wenn es nicht so traurig wäre, könnte man drüber lachen. Bislang war das Ministerium in CDU-Hand und wir haben alle mitbekommen, dass kurz nach der Bundestagswahl die neue Regierung war gerade so im Amt, da gab es im Januar die Ansage, die KfW fördert jetzt nicht mehr diesen 55er, im Vergleich zu 1990 sind die Häuser 55% effektiver und dafür gab es eine Förderung, dieser Topf ist leer. Und jetzt steht Robert Habeck hier auf der Bühne, so ein Monat später. Der Schock sitzt in allen noch in den Knochen, weil die da auch wirklich drohten, diese ganzen Aufträge nicht mehr zu bekommen. Also es war so richtig, 20 Milliarden Förderungen sind weg und damit auch sehr relativ viele Aufträge, haben wir jetzt Überkapazitäten, was machen wir jetzt und so überhaupt. Und jetzt steht Robert Habeck auf der Bühne und sagt mit den ganzen Anwesenden mal Folgendes.
Und ich wundere mich ein bisschen als Neuminister für die Verantwortung für Bauen und Sanieren, dass man zwölf Jahre lang offensichtlich, und ich sage, da bin ich so frech sein darf, aus der Bauwirtschaft auch nicht gewarnt hat, dass die Standards vielleicht mal angepasst werden müssten. Denn die Zahlen sind ja da gewesen. Man hat ja gesehen, wie der Hochlauf da ist. Und ich fände es einen guten Deal, wenn ich den so vorschlagen darf, dass ich mit offenem Ohr auf alle Anliegen der Bauwirtschaft höre, die Studien lese, mich jeder Kritik stelle, fände es aber nicht ärgerlich, wenn die Bauwirtschaft selber nicht darauf hinweist oder die Politik darauf hinweist, wo irgendwo Mitnahmeeffekte sind.
So, es war eh schon Standard, so zu bauen. Niemand hat mehr ein uneffektiveres Haus haben wollen. Gleichzeitig hat die Industrie beim Bundeswirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier nie Bescheid gesagt, dass man eigentlich diese Förderung nur noch mitnimmt. Man baut eh schon nach dem Standard. Also hier wird gar nichts mehr motiviert oder so, sondern das ist alles schon eingepreist.
Im Prinzip, wie man bei einem Auto nicht noch mal dran schreibt, ist mit Anschnallgurt.
Genau, so ungefähr. Und Peter Altmaier hat das aber auch nie mitbekommen oder wollte es nie wahrhaben. Also wir haben es hier mit einem gigantischen Lobby-Erfolg offenbar zu tun, dass es ewig lang diese in zig Milliarden Höhe diese Förderung gab für etwas, das sowieso schon Normalfall ist, das also gar nicht förderwürdig ist und auch nur die Preise hochgetrieben hat, weil die Mitnahmeeffekte, die er hier unterstellt, liegen natürlich auf Seiten derjenigen, die die Rechnung am Ende schreiben.
Und das macht mich richtig wütend, denn die CDU tut ja gerade in den Talkshows so, inklusive Röttgen oder Jens Spahn oder Altmaier, als habe sie seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr regiert. Und als sei das jetzt alles, dass wir abhängig sind von Putin, der Ampelkoalition in die Schuhe zu schieben, was ja einfach kompletter Irrsinn ist. Und eigentlich müsste man genau diese Dinge, die jetzt hier gesagt werden, sofort als Waffe gebrauchen im Talkshow-Krieg und sagen, nein, ihr habt mit eurer Verbindung zur Bauwirtschaft, um nicht zu sagen mit euren Gerupptheiten zur Bauwirtschaft, habt ihr dafür gesorgt, dass wir eine so hohe Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas, von russischem Öl haben.
Richtig, richtig, richtig. Also hier liegen doch noch so, auf der einen Seite kann man sich darüber freuen, wie es schon so läuft beim Wohnen insgesamt. Aber hier erklären sich doch einige Gründe, warum die Wohnkosten so hoch sind und warum die Industrie so schön da durchsegelt. Und vielleicht kann man einfach hoffen, dass Robert Habeck da ein bisschen aufräumt, aber vier Jahre sind auch nie so viel Zeit. Und da wurde ganz schön viel in Argen gelegt, um es mal so zu formulieren.
Wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt angelangt, bei dem wir auf zwei Themen, die wir eigentlich ansprechen wollten, verzichten müssen, damit der Podcast nicht unendlich lang wird. Wir können aber schon mal sagen, es geht das nächste Mal um das Gehirn aus zwei sehr unterschiedlichen Perspektiven und auch ohne, dass wir das miteinander abgesprochen haben. Um meines anzutesen, es geht darum, wie man, wenn man sich gar nicht mehr bewegen kann, trotzdem kommunizieren kann. Da gibt es neue Forschungserfolge. Wir werden darüber ausführlich sprechen, auch einige philosophische Fragen, aufwerfen, auch ein bisschen fragen, was ist der Stellenwert von Familie, was bedeutet eigentlich Lebensqualität. Ein ganz interessantes Thema. Und du wirst unser Gehirn aber outsourcen.
Ja, Leute reden im Internet. So wie es die Fitnesswelle gibt, gibt es eine Productivity-Welle. Menschen wollen effektiver mit ihrer Zeit umgehen und erfolgreicher arbeiten. Und da gibt es ein Tool, um das dreht sich viel Notion. Ich habe auch letztes Mal und dieses Mal meine Podcast-Notizen schon in dieser App inklusive der meisten Clips und so weiter. Ich werde es auch mit verlinken. Da kann man sich schon mal...
Ich habe es mir schon angeschaut. Das sieht toll aus. Ich sitze ja einfach mit drei ausgedruckten Wörterteilen hier vor dir, um Zitate dich vorlesen will, parat zu haben. Aber es ist noch nicht so schön bunt wie in deiner Welt.
Genau, also wenn euch das interessiert, könnt ihr schon mal dann anklicken. Ich werde es verlinkt haben. Es ist wie so eine Art Notizblatt, große Tafel oder so, wo man alles so ein bisschen hin und her draufmatschen kann und sich so einen Überblick verschafft. Listen ein und ausklappen, so dass man die Übersicht behält. Und darüber werden wir das nächste Monat mal reden. Unter der Maßgabe, wie kommen wir zurück zum Handeln? Und wie kann man da auch leicht über die Stränge schlagen? Also wie findet man Produktivität aber eben effektiv, dass man sich nicht in der Planung verliert, sondern auch wirklich produktiv ist? Ich habe an mir jetzt gemerkt, dass ich die letzten Monate doch ganz erpicht war darauf, solche Videos zu sehen. Ganz viel in meinem Leben auch so umgebaut habe, um beispielsweise Mails, die ich noch schreiben will, schon mal anzukündigen. Dass ich den Leuten schreibe, jetzt gerade kann ich nicht, aber sei dir klar, morgen Abend schicke ich dir eine Mail. Und dann kommt die aber auch wirklich morgen Abend, weil ich mir das nämlich überall als Notiz und Erinnerung und Pipapo einfach rausorganisiere aus meinem Kopf, in dem Vertrauen, dass es zur richtigen Zeit dann mich schon wieder erreicht. Und es klappt erstaunlich gut. Also es wird nächsten Monat auch so ein Hin und Her hangeln zwischen wir machen uns lustig darüber, wie Influencer darüber reden, was sie tun. Auf der anderen Seite steckt aber auch ein echter Meer drin.
Du willst schon deine 12 Roots for Life uns schon anbieten hier.
Ja, so ungefähr. Ein paar Thesen stecken schon dahinter. Also es geht ganz konkret um Software als Second Brain, so wie man bei Harry Potter mit Zauberstäben am Kopf so einzelne Gedanken rausholt und erst mal irgendwo hin parkt, später wieder aufgreift. Also wie man so eine Kombination dann schafft. Wie gesagt, es ist auf der einen Seite eine Spielerei, viele übertreiben es. Ich finde, es gibt ein paar praktische Nutzen, man muss klare Grenzen ziehen. Aber es ist insgesamt ein amüsantes Thema, von dem ich glaube, dass es dann doch viele tangiert. Und zwar ganz konkret.
Das passt doch dann ganz gut, dass wir jetzt noch kurz über das South by Southwest Festival oder Konferenz sprechen wollen. Da ist die Gaming-Film- und Digital-Elite zu Gast, hält dort Vorträge. Wir tun das nur in sehr abgespeckter Form jetzt rezipieren. Amy Webb war dort, hat einen Vortrag gehalten. Und jetzt haben wir schon von Schnittstellen gehört, Gedanken, Outsourcen, woanders ablegen. Aber vieles wächst auch hier zusammen. Denn in ihrem Vortrag sagt sie Folgendes.
Computers and biology are becoming one. So the state of play here is that synthetic biology, just like the metaverse, just like AI, is an umbrella term for lots of different technologies. It's a relatively new interdisciplinary field of science that combines engineering, design, computers and biology and researchers design or redesign organisms to give them new or better purposes.
Synthetische Biologie? Ich fühlte mich ein bisschen erinnernd an die 90er-Jahre, wo man schon ganz stark Computer und Gehirn zusammendachte. Und jetzt geht es aber weiter, wenn sie z.B. schildert, was man eigentlich mit Daten machen kann oder wie man Daten speichern kann.
Das Metaverse wird eine ganze Bündnis von Stabilität nehmen. DNA kann digitale Informationen in einem Raum stecken, das von der Mängdheit weniger ist als die Datenzentren heute.
Hmm, klar DNA klingt natürlich erst mal nach Redware so, aber in dem Falle wärs ja wirklich einfach ein Datenspeicher, bei dem uns egal ist wie er funktioniert, dass er so funktioniert wie unser, okay. Ja, da ist auf jeden Fall noch viel rauszuholen. Es gibt jetzt diese neue Apple-Hardware, also mit diesem M1-Chip und dann nochmal M1 Ultra, wo sie den M1 Max und Pro dann irgendwie nochmal so kombinieren, dass sie 2 mit 2, 5 Terabyte Datenverbindungsgeschwindigkeit miteinander so kombinieren. Und ich sehe mir das halt auch so an, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Use-Case dafür und denke mir aber, naja, vor 10 Jahren hatte man auch keinen Use-Case für das Smartphone mit unendlicher Power. Und was macht man heute? Auf die Schnelle mal kurz Videoclips zusammenschneiden, in die Welt schicken und so. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was aus dieser Apple-Software, die sowieso schon mal bei kreativen Menschen auf dem Wunschzettel steht, was einfach so als Nächstes kommt, insgesamt. Wenn die jetzt mit sowas hier um die Ecke kommen, das sind ja auf der Seite der Technik solche Effizienzvorsprünge, dass man daraus, dass sich fast von der Leine irgendwas ergibt.
Wo du gerade von Apple sprichst, sag doch noch ganz schnell etwas, was immer wieder jetzt diskutiert wurde, nämlich dass Apple uns mit Spionen ausgestattet hat, ohne es eigentlich so richtig zu wollen. Denn das ist ja auch noch ein wichtiges, wichtiges technisches Thema.
Genau, wir machen das mal ohne Clips. Ich habe es jetzt auch gar nicht groß vorbereitet, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein mega Thema, dass wir dann auch noch mal zu sprechen kommen, wenn es handgreiflich wird, weil das wird es irgendwann. In Amerika haben sich die ersten Models beklagt, dass sie ohne es zu wissen von Airtex verfolgt werden. Und da fragt man sich so, wie was Airtex verfolgt. Apple hat im Angebot und ich habe sie auch im Einsatz, zum Beispiel im Schlüsselanhänger, im Schulranzen meiner jüngeren Tochter und in meinem Portemonnaie. Kleine Chips, nicht wirklich Chips, ungefähr so groß wie ein 2-Euro-Stück, ein bisschen dicker. Und die funken und zwar alle iPhones an, die sie sehen. Und es gibt viele iPhones, also haben sie viel Kontakt zu iPhones und sie sammeln von den iPhones die Information, wo bin ich hier gerade. Und darüber findet man dann immer sein Portemonnaie, weil das liegt dann irgendwo im Park. Und sobald es Kontakt hat zu einem iPhone, sagt es Bescheid, hier bin ich. Und ich kann dann über mein iPhone Verbindungen zu diesem Chip herstellen. Und zwar ganz oft weitergeleitet über ganz viele andere iPhones, mit denen ich gar nichts zu tun habe. Sondern Apple nimmt hier einfach in dem Sinne, ich habe ein iPhone gekauft und diene damit aber jetzt auch anderen als Service. Es ist nicht noch mein Telefon so.
Wie bei der Energie, wie wir das da haben wollen. Der Use-Case, um das noch mal klarzustellen, ist tatsächlich, dass man damit Dinge, die man leicht verlegt, wiederfinden kann. Es geht also nicht darum, dass man damit Leute verfolgt. Oder weil du sagst, man kann das auch in den Schule ranzdenken. Das heißt, man könnte auch sagen, ich weiß dann, wo mein Kind hergeht, wenn es zur Schule geht oder kann sehen, wenn da irgendwas nicht stimmt, wenn plötzlich die Richtung sich ändert.
Genau, ganz konkret, unsere ist in der Schule und kommt dann alleine nach Hause. Und ich will einfach wissen, ist sie noch in der Schule, weil sie hat so ein Zeitfenster, wo sie nach Hause kommen kann, je nachdem, ob sie gerade Spaß hat in der Schulbetreuung oder nicht. Und ich will dann nicht immer anrufen, ist sie noch da oder wie auch immer, sondern ich gucke dann einfach kurz nach, ist sie noch da? Und dann ist sie wahrscheinlich noch da. Es ist eine Sicherheitsfunktion eingebaut, die wie folgt funktioniert, wenn meine Tochter jetzt mit ihrem Ranzen einen Ausflug macht mit einer Lehrerin. Und die Lehrerin hat ein iPhone. Die Lehrerin bewegt sich also über verschiedene Orte und es ist immer der gleiche AirTag bei ihr. Also nicht im Sinne von jetzt bin ich nah an dem AirTag dran und jetzt nah an dem und so, sondern der verfolgt sie. Dann würde ihr iPhone das merken und ihr Bescheid sagen, du wirst gerade von einem AirTag verfolgt. Und dann würde ihr Handy ihr auch anbieten, zeig mir mal, wo der ist. Und du hast dann so ein kleines Radarsystem auf dem Telefon, zeigt dir einen Pfeil und auf 10 cm genau, wo liegt denn jetzt dein Portemonnaie, wo ist denn jetzt der AirTag, der dich verfolgt. Und dieses Sicherheitsding lässt sich austricksen. Also die AirTags kann man verschleiern, sodass sie Kontakt zum iPhone halten, ohne dass das iPhone getriggert wird, Bescheid zu sagen. Hinzu kommt, wenn diejenigen, die verfolgt werden, kein iPhone haben, sondern nur ein Android-Telefon.
Also ich zum Beispiel. Du zum Beispiel.
Du würdest es nicht bemerken.
Ich aufpasse in die Tasche werfen und dann kannst du gucken, ob ich heute Abend wirklich ins Kino gehe.
Ich würde dann verfolgen können, wo du bist, ohne dass dir auch nur irgendein Hinweis gegeben wird. Es ist ein riesengroßes Problem, da diese Dinger nur 25 Euro kosten. Für Apple ein untypisch billiges Gerät mit unglaublicher Funktions-Reichweite. Und das allererste und bislang einzige, was Apple gemacht hat, ist, um da Sicherheit mehr herzustellen, dass man so eine Art Gefährdeansprache, so wurde das in einem Blog genannt, ins Software-Update mit reinpackt. Also wenn du Atex benutzt, dass dir dann nochmal klar der Hinweis geben wird, was illegal ist damit. Die Frage ist nur, wen juckt's? Und es gibt zum Beispiel Lilith Wittmann, das ist eine Aktivistin, die beispielsweise von der CDU verklagt wurde kürzlich, als sie deren Sicherheitsbedenken, also als sie ihre Sicherheitsbedenken hinsichtlich der CDU-Wahlkampf-App veröffentlicht hat, die ja auch so Adressen sammelt und sowas. Und sie hat mit Hilfe von Atex den Bundes-Service Telekommunikation ausfindig gemacht. Sie wollte sich so ein großes Organigram machen, welche Organisation eigentlich wohin gehört. Und dann hat sie das so nachvollzogen, einfach gegoogelt, wem unterstellt, welches Behörde und so. Und dann hat sie irgendwo eine Telefonnummer von einem Bundes-Service Telekommunikation bekommen. Hat dann da auch angerufen und da ging auch jemand ran. Und dann verlief das aber im Sande. Sie fand nicht raus, was das ist. Also hat sie eine Adresse, die sie fand, genommen und hat ein Paket gepackt, ein AirTag reingepackt und hat dann einfach verfolgt, wo wird denn das jetzt eigentlich hingesendet. Und dann stellte sie sich raus, es gibt irgendwo beim Verfassungsschutz Bund so eine Unterabteilung Bundes-Service Telekommunikation. Und der ließ sich eben mit so einem AirTag austricksen. Da ist einfach ein AirTag angekommen, keiner hat es gemerkt, keiner wurde registriert. Und dann konnte sie an die Öffentlichkeit gehen, netzpolitik.org und so oder Logbuch Netzpolitik im Podcast, hat sie so ein bisschen beschrieben. Hat sie halt eine geheime Bundesbehörde gefunden, mit einem AirTag und sagt dann so im Podcast auch, sie konnte minutiös beobachten, da macht der LKW gerade Pause an der Tanke und steht da 10 Minuten, weil einfach zu viele iPhones die ganze Zeit auf der Autobahn dran vorbei rauschen, sie das minutiös verfolgen konnte. Und ich meine, wenn man so einen Start austricksen kann und plötzlich geheime Bundesbehörden auftauchen, nachweisbar, dann ist mit so einem AirTag doch einiges zu machen. Und das finde ich irgendwie crazy, dass Apple als Unternehmen, dem Privatsphäre so viel gilt, gerade im Widerstreit zu Google und so weiter, dass sie es nicht hinbekommen, sich beispielsweise mit Google darauf zu einigen, dass auch Google-Telefone einfach mal AirTags erschnüffeln, wenn sie da verfolgt werden und so. Weil das ist wirklich, ja, hat Apple glaube ich einen ganz großen Fehler gemacht, wieder eine eigene Technik vorangetrieben, ohne sich vorher darauf zu verständigen, wie man das mal zu einem allgemeinen Standard macht, so dass es da auch mehr Gegenwehr geben kann, wenn man sie braucht. Ja, und diese AirTag-Sache ist wirklich sehr ärgerlich. Und die eine, die jetzt gerade noch sehr kocht. Also ich bin nur sehr gespannt, wie das da noch weitergeht.
Das heißt aber auch, dass es Nachahmer geben wird, die ähnliche Produkte anbieten, die vielleicht dann auch kompatibel sind mit den anderen Smartphones, die aber dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr zu finden sind, bei denen ich dann einfach gar nicht mehr sicher sein kann, wenn ich mich nicht morgens durchsuche und meine Tasche auf links drehe, ob ich nicht doch in dieser Weise verfolgt werde.
Also es gibt Unternehmen, die das machen. Teil zum Beispiel heißt eins, die haben auch so einen kleinen Schlüsselanhänger. Du brauchst halt echt ein Betriebsoperation-System, Zugriff auf das Telefon, weil das muss ja weitersenden. Kannst ja nicht nur abgreifen. Das kleine Ding, Batterie hält der für ein Jahr, macht da wirklich nur sendet, so sein kleines. Und das iPhone verarbeitet das dann. Also ist sozusagen jedes iPhone irgendwie ein Mittäter schafft, ohne dass man es weiß. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei Corona-Warn-App. Du weißt ja gar nicht, was dein iPhone macht. Es funkt halt überall. Und dann hat man in ganz vielen Papern so erklärt, warum man darüber nicht die Lokalität nachvollziehen kann und pipa po. Und all das wurde komplett ausgespart jetzt bei diesen AirTag. Das heißt, die Gefahr selber geht jetzt erst mal nur von Apple aus. Ein nachahmer Unternehmen kann es so nicht geben, weil es können nur die großen Hersteller sein. Und in dem Fall, dass eben beim iPhone Software und Hardware von einem Unternehmen kommt, haben sie hier einfach einen Markt geschaffen für ein Produkt, das nur sie schaffen können, damit auch wieder große Marktschließung. Gleichzeitig so problembehaftet.
Und versucht Apple, das jetzt einzuhägen?
Sie wissen noch nicht genau wie, weil sie, glaube ich, noch nicht ganz verstanden haben, wie die iPhones ausgetrickst werden, dass sie nicht Bescheid sagen, wenn sie verfolgt werden.
Aber es ist mal wieder erstaunlich, dass man da im Silicon Valley offenbar etwas kreiert hat und sich noch gar nicht so über die Wirklichkeit bewusst war, sondern wahrscheinlich einfach so wieder so ein klassisches Bild hat. Wir hatten das schon häufiger. Man will eigentlich die Mutti, die einem was hinterherträgt und wenn die Mutti nicht mehr für einen kocht, dann muss das jemand bringen, das Essen. Und jetzt haben wir den Fall, Mutti hat mir sonst immer den Schlüssel hinterhergetragen oder das Portemonnaie. Wenn man das mal ersetzen könnte mit irgendwas und dann hat man das erfunden, aber gar nicht gedacht, ach, das könnte man, also das gibt es ja Dual-Use, da könnte man noch was anderes mitmachen.
Genau, dieser Dual-Use-Krank, da wurde komplett ausgeblendet und es ist, gerade weil es Apple ist, auch so erstaunlich irgendwie.
Man kann aber noch tollere Chips entwerfen, Amy Webb geht darauf ein.
Sie ist ungefähr die Größe eines P-Maschinen und hat 16.000 Transistoren und Sensoren. Ich meine, einige Leute sagen, dass die Invention dieses verrückten neuen Typen von Chip mit dem Intel-Maschinen erzeugt wurde, das erste Mikrochip 50 Jahre lang. Interessant genug, in der Biologie-Geheimdienste sind es viele der gleichen Firmen im Metaverse-Geheimdienst und viele der gleichen Firmen im AI-Geheimdienst.
So, welche Verschmelzung steht da noch bevor? Kann man fragen.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist aber... Ich will dann den Neuralink von Elon Musk auch mal sehen und so. Das ist immer alles noch so ein...
Ja, wir werden ja auf das noch eingehen, dann in der nächsten Folge nicht um Neuralink, aber wo das wirklich passiert. Und wenn man diese Leute dann auch hört, die halten natürlich von Elon Musk überhaupt nichts, sondern sagen, das ist überhaupt keine Forschung, sondern der versucht einfach noch mal neues Produkt zu kreieren, das er verkaufen kann. Man muss da vorsichtig sein. Metaverse war selbstverständlich das ganz große Thema bei dieser Konferenz und Kryptowährungen, Tokens, Coins und so weiter. Roman Kopula war da aus dem Kopula Clan, der einen Filmcoin, einen Filmtoken vorgestellt hat, mit dem man Crowdfunding betreiben kann. Er kann es selbst nicht erklären. Ich habe uns jetzt die Clips erspart. Man weiß überhaupt nicht genau, worauf er eigentlich hinaus will. Eigentlich sagt er, wir haben ja ganz viele Gatekeeper in der Filmindustrie. Wenn wir die nicht hätten, sondern mehr Crowdfinanziert wären, dann könnten auch andere Filme entstehen. Dann würde man einfach sagen, es gibt ja Crowdfunding und das gibt es schon länger. Das ist mit großen Filmen die Millionen kosten eher schwierig.
Unter anderem sprach er davon, Virtual-Reality-Brillen zu entwickeln, mit denen man echten Augenkontakt herstellen könne.
Max Hackerberg will nicht unter Leute. Er hat eigentlich so ein Putin-Problem, würde ich fast sagen. Er will nicht unter Leute. Er sagt, jetzt muss ich mal eine Brille herstellen, mit der ich einen Augenkontakt herstellen kann, wo man einfach sagen kann, dann treff dich doch mal mit jemanden. Und das ist übrigens meine große Erfahrung jetzt im März. Ich hatte ja ganz viele Veranstaltungen. Es ist richtig toll, auf echte Menschen zu treffen, nicht in Webcams zu blicken, sich mit denen zu unterhalten. Und das sind zum Teil ganz berührende oder lustige Begegnungen. Und man kann aber auch bei allen Leuten merken, die man trifft. Und oft sind es ja ganz kurze Begegnungen, weil man gar nicht allen gerecht werden kann, wenn da viele Leute stehen. Dass man doch bei allen merken kann, es sind alle sehr froh, endlich mal wieder etwas leibhaftig zu erleben und leibhaftig wirklich so begriffen, wie es gemeint ist. Denn zu glauben, man könnte das durch das Digitale ersetzen, ist einfach ein Irrglaub. Weil dann können wir längst alles aufgeben. Dann brauchen wir auch nie mehr ein Konzert zu gehen, weil wir haben ja unsere wunderbaren Streaming-Anbieter mit allen Aufnahmen der Welt, die wir eh nie hören können. Aber dass das nicht das Eigentliche ersetzt, das ist das Erstaunliche, was sich jetzt hier ganz klar zeigt. Und man sieht auch gleich, welche Energie in dem Sinne man wieder daraus ziehen kann, dass man es mit einer Begegnung zu tun hat, die in anderer Weise auch hängen bleibt, als die nur digitale Erfahrung.
Ja, also ich will jetzt ganz deutlich sagen, Corona ist jetzt hier vorbei. Ich will auch nicht mal irgendwelche Kommentare dazu. Ich werde es dann mehr über den Fernsehpodcast organisieren, aber auch hier die Ansage. Mein Plan ist jetzt, jeden zweiten Mittwoch gibt es hier Hörertreffen in Frankfurt. Wir lungern rum vor der EZB oder was auch immer, da wo man in Frankfurt rumlungert. Es gibt viele Orte, wo man ganz tolle Abende miteinander verbringen kann. Es fehlt nur noch ein bisschen die Wärme abends, dass man dann doch mal so bis halb neun noch draußen einfach rum sitzen kann. Sonnenuntergang, Skyline und alles. Und es hat mir sehr gefehlt und das kann man jetzt einfach machen. Und ich finde, das muss man auch machen, aber eben völlig zwanglos. So, dass man einfach nicht absagen muss oder so. Sondern man ist dann halt einfach da oder nicht da. Irgendwer kommt immer und so.
Wir können das schon mal sagen, wir denken darüber nach, dass wir vielleicht Ende des Jahres, unserer Abschlussjahresabschlussendung vor Publikum machen. Wir würden die Details dann zu gegebener Zeit noch bekannt geben. Wir haben aber diese Idee oder du hattest die Idee jetzt gehabt und wir haben eben nur ein paar Minuten darüber gesprochen, was ich an sich sehr gut finde und das ist sehr wichtig, jetzt sich zu treffen, mit Leuten zu Veranstaltungen zu gehen. Die Veranstaltungen sind immer noch ziemlich leer auch zum Teil. Also nicht alles. Das war jetzt beeindruckend bei der Lit Cologne, wie viele Leute da sind. Aber wenn man mal so guckt in der Philharmonie oder so, wie wenig da gerade gebucht ist, weil alle Leute vorsichtig sind. Ich würde sagen, es ist wirklich heilsam, das jetzt mal wieder an den Tag zu gehen, damit man nicht in so eine Zuckerberg-Ideologie kommt.
Scott Galloway, sehr gut. Ich warte diesen Clip an und dann will ich noch was sagen, was Scott Galloway immer gesagt hat.
Scott Galloway glaubt auch an das Metaverse, aber es wird nicht Mark Zuckerberg froh machen.
Genau.
Wirtschaftsprofesse und Podcast-Host Scott Galloway sprach auf der South By davon, dass er glaube, dass das Metaversum von Mark Zuckerberg versagen werde. Stattdessen sieht er eine andere Firma in diesem Rennen ganz vorne. Mit ihrem App Store haben sie das, was einem Metaversum am nächsten kommt.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es visuell sein wird, wie in Videospielen, sondern auditiv. Die Kopfhörer, die wir jeden Tag anziehen, mit denen wir telefonieren oder Podcasts hören, das kreiert ein Level an Intimität.
Das treibt das Metaversum mehr an, als das Visuelle.
Wird das Metaverse auditiv? Das ist eine interessante Überlegung. Bislang haben wir ja immer diese komischen Videos gesehen. Mark Zuckerberg als Fantasievogel springt da durch irgendwelche Konferenzen, wo man denkt, naja, das ist auch nicht mein ästhetisches Empfinden. Jetzt sagt Galloway, auditiv könnte es sein. Das ist sowieso was, woran wir uns auch sehr gewöhnt haben. Wir haben Stimmen im Ohr, auch die uns gerade hören haben Stimmen im Ohr.
Richtig. Also dieses Argument von Scott Galloway, ich konnte es auch erst nicht so richtig, aber jetzt ist es auch in seinem Pivot-Podcast so oft und ich bin ja nun auch in so eine Rolle reingerutscht. Also, sagen wir mal so, es gab ja immer diesen Streit, Mac oder Apple, was benutzt man eigentlich? Für mich war immer klar, also ich bin mit Windows sozialisiert, für mich ist immer noch alles Windows, also dieser Computer hier, dieser Podcast hier entsteht auf Windows-Computern. Aber ich bin das erste Mal in meinem Leben High-End ausgerüstet. Also ich habe die Apple AirPods Pro, damit die besten AirPods es gibt, ich habe die neue Apple Watch, die siebene und ein iPhone 13. Also ausgereizt im Sinne von, dass man, es ist doch erstaunlich für ungefähr ein bisschen weniger als 2000 Euro an diesem Punkt angekommen ist, wo man auch Milliardäre nicht besser ausstatten kann als jedermann. Und meine Erfahrung ist, dass Scott Galloway absolut recht hat, in einem Ausmaß, das ich selber noch nicht so richtig einschätzen kann, weil diese Integration von der Uhr und den AirPods, also dass ich einfach immer die AirPods dabei habe und dann auch in meine Ohren stecke, ohne das nicht mal bei der Maske, du hast kein Kabel, nichts. Ob die Maske schon steckt oder nicht, AirPods rein, AirPods raus, Maske absetzen, ist nie ein Problem, weil, und so, vorher mit den Kabeln, alles kreuz und quer. So, und dann, aber, und deswegen ist dieses Argument, es nicht nur zu sagen, Apple hat damit einen wirtschaftlichen Erfolg, sondern es ist auch ein Anti-Metaverse zu Mark Zuckerbergs Vorstellungen. Denn bei Mark Zuckerberg ist das Metaverse selbst schon alles, also da steckt die ganze Sozialität drin, während Apple mich einfach nur unterstützt, bei meinem eigentlichen sozialen Metaverse, mit dem, wo ich Hilfe brauche. Also Organisation von allem Möglichen, dass plötzlich alles so zu Terminen wird. Vorher hatte man ja immer so einen Kalendereintrag, also dafür ist schon eine gewisse Hürde notwendig. Jetzt habe ich für jeden kleinen Scheiß so eine Erinnerung, die ich mir einfach kurz in die Uhr einspreche und es strukturiert einfach meinen Tag grundsätzlich durch. Nicht nur kann ich damit mein soziales Leben besser organisieren, sondern ich kann auch das, was Arbeit ist und mich von meinem sozialen Leben abhält, viel besser und viel schneller und viel effektiver wegarbeiten, sodass ich viel mehr Zeit dafür habe. Und diese Sicht auf die Dinge, also nicht das Metaverse als, und damit kolonialisieren wir jetzt dein ganzes Leben, sondern dieses Assistierende, dass man auf dem iPhone wirklich alles machen kann, bis hin zu, ich bin grad hier, du bist grad hier, du musst mir aber nicht sagen, wo du bist, weil ich sehs ja, und selbst wenn du dich bewegst, weiß ich trotzdem noch den richtigen Weg zu dir. Also du brauchst keinen statischen Punkt, da treffen wir uns, sondern wir bewegen uns in einer Stadt aufeinander zu, ohne weitere Koordination treffen wir uns auf kürzesten Wege, genau da, wo es für alle am günstigsten ist. Also solche Sachen, das ist mit dem iPhone einfach wahnsinnig einfach zu machen, eine Familie zu organisieren, dieser ganze Kram, das ist einfach, also Scott Galloway hat da absolut recht, das ist das Metaverse, glaube ich. Also da, wo ich es auch akzeptiere. Während dieses ganze Mark Zuckerberg-Ding, wir sitzen zu Hause mit einer Brille auf dem Kopf, nee und das merkt man auch relativ zügig, das ist Einsamkeit, da kommt auch nichts darum. Dieser Augenkontakt, ist uns wirklich der Augenkontakt so wichtig, wenn wir beieinander sind, geht es nicht dann doch auch um die Antizipation, die Ermöglichung von echten Körperkontakt und diesem Spiel darum, findet das statt oder nicht, ja und solche Sachen. Das ist ja dann, das ist in Mark Zuckerbergs Ding nicht eingepreist.
Nee, das ist auch so eine vollkommen unsinnliche, unerotische Welt, die Mark Zuckerberg davor schwebt, wo ich sagen würde, ja, aber dann muss ich das auch gar nicht haben. Also wozu sollte ich, also dann ist ja jedes Kinoerlebnis ein emersiveres. Warum sollte ich mir diese doch sehr klinischen, ich würde fast sagen aseptischen Welten antun, in denen Mark Zuckerberg sich bewegt. Sehr eigenartig. Wir blicken noch auf ein optimistisches Szenario, dann kommt das pessimistische zum Thema KI. Wir hören nochmal Amy Webb.
So, let's look at two possible futures. AI content is identified in some way. So are the teams that created the models. There are guardrails for use and certain types of invisible, invasive biometric recognition systems, not just facial recognition. They've been banned from use in public spaces, which means it is perfectly fine to have a heartbeat. And you can feel comfortable breathing in public. It's much more intuitive and it's much more accessible now that people can have a conversation and search visually. These AI systems five years from now have really helped us automate certain tasks and they've made us have better, more productive days.
Nun, damit kann man leben, ob das jetzt so wahnsinnig optimistisch ist. Also man würde ja auch ohne das durchs Leben kommen einigermaßen. Du hast das jetzt geschildert, wie sehr das iPhone dir hilft. Und da würde ich ja jetzt gar nicht fortschrittsfeindlich sagen, nee, nee, braucht man alles nicht. Ich merke dann, dass ich es vielleicht nicht ganz so sehr benötige. Vielleicht, weil ich weniger organisieren muss, dann würde sich das schon ändern. Aber naja, das ist ein Szenario, mit dem man vielleicht leben könnte. Jetzt kommt aber das Katastrophen-Szenario von Amy Webb.
Die Probleme, die wir im Jahr 2022 hatten, wurden nur in der Jahre 2027 verabschiedet. Missinformation ist überall, aber jetzt ist es in der Form von Imagen und Videos, die spezifisch durch AI-Systeme ausgestattet wurden, und niemand kann die Unterschiede erzählen. Und wir alle tragen Prev-Mistique. Prev-Mistique ist ein neues, leichtweißiges Make-up, das schmutzige Rinkels, die die Eierpuffigkeit reduziert und sofort die Surveillance-Kameras blickt.
Intelligentes Make-up also? Aber ich sag mal so, man kann ja fast froh sein, dass wir, äh, ne, ich muss es anders formulieren. Wir sind, ich meine, das ist immer so ein Szenario, man hat so die Science-Fiction-Filme schon vor sich, die hier stattfinden. Wir wissen, es kommt hier nie so auf den einen oder anderen Tag. Also das ist das Erstaunliche, wenn man ins Kino geht, dann sieht man die Vision und sagt, so will ich aber nicht. Das Problem ist aber, dass es ja diese schleichende Entwicklung hin zu etwas gibt. Und dann wird das punktuell nochmal sichtbar, wie bei diesen Trackern, die du eben beschrieben hast. Aber wenn man sagt, naja, das könnte man noch optimieren und da könnte man noch, aber welche Hacker-Angriffe stehen dann eigentlich bevor? Ja, da muss ich wieder was zu meinem Schutz sagen. Dann ist das tatsächlich ein dystopisches Szenario, das ich wiederum gar nicht für so unwahrscheinlich halte. Und wenn wir schon sehen, wie stark die Fake-Produktion ist, was Videos und sowas anbelangt, dann können wir uns vorstellen, wie weit das in fünf Jahren fortgeschritten ist. Noch können wir es relativ gut trennen, die wir nicht unser Leben in Facebook-Gruppen verbracht haben. Aber wird das in fünf Jahren immer noch so sein, haben wir dann auch immer noch die Kompetenz, diese Unterscheidung zu treffen?
Ja, das ist, gerade dadurch, dass es so schleichend ist, ist die Herausforderung einfach... Man kann sich halt das beides anhören und denken so, ja gut, okay, jetzt mal abwarten irgendwie. Gut, ich habe keine weiteren Clips zu spielen, auch wenn noch ein paar da liegen. Aber wir freuen uns einfach auf April.
Wir freuen uns auf April. Kannst du schon was sagen, was du uns noch mit in den Salon bringen wirst? Also wir sprechen auf jeden Fall über Michael Sandel und das Ende des Gemeinwohls.
Genau, Sandel. Ich habe hier in meiner Leseliste, wo ich so ein bisschen vorsattiere, sogar diesen Text über die TikToker im Weißen Haus mit drin von Tyler Lawrence. Mal gucken. Ansonsten hat die Washington Post. Der letzte afghanische Finanzminister ist jetzt Uber-Driver in Washington DC.
Prima.
Wird so ein bisschen porträtiert. Also solche Sachen irgendwie. Das Thema Streit aus Sicht von, wenn Höflichkeit reinhaut, ein Vorabdruck eines Buches, das mich irgendwie interessiert hat. Ein Spektrum der Wissenschaft. Also wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen mit Zug. Also so in die Richtung. Lasst euch überraschen. Ich weiß es selber noch nicht so ganz genau.
Ich kann auch noch nicht allzu viel versprechen. Es wird sehr wahrscheinlich um einen wichtigen Roman einer brasilianischen Schriftstellerin gehen, über den wir sprechen können. Dann gibt es eine Kuriosität zum Herrenanzug. Der wird irrelevanter. Das kann man nicht einfach so gefühlt wahrnehmen. Es gibt da eine Indiz, dass ich dann enthüllen werde. Das hat mich natürlich sehr betrübt. Dann will ich versuchen, noch etwas Geopolitisches mit reinzubringen, was wirtschaftlich ist. Aber es sind sehr viele Texte gerade im Petto. Deswegen müssen wir mal schauen, dass wir da eine sinnvolle Kombination finden. Dass es nicht zulastig in die eine oder andere Richtung wird.
Sehr gut, damit überraschen wir euch und uns auch ein bisschen. Wir wünschen euch jetzt erst mal einen schönen April. Der macht ja, was er will. Hoffentlich nur beim Wetter. Keine weiteren Überraschungen hier erleben. Und beschließen damit den März.
Bis bald.